[Musique]
Jérôme CL, bonsoir. Bonsoir Sky. Nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne Nous te
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Serview. Nous sommes en direct
et en mode balistique aujourd'hui.
Est-ce que tu veux bien te présenter
succintement ? Moi, je t'ai fait le coup
de la particule élémentaire la fois
dernière, donc on va éviter. Bah cette
fois-ci, je dirais un ovni. Voilà, un
ovni de la prospective. Et donc, je
m'appelle Jérôme Cllèch. Je suis
prospectiviste.
J'ai je la pratique, je l'enseigne, je
forme et je fais un peu de recherche
dessus et j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion
d'en parler un peu plus avant. Et donc
vous enseignez vous, tu enseignes et tu
formes dans un club de bridge auprès
d'un EPAD, auprès de
euh
plus exactement et pour revenir à
quelque chose d'un peu plus sérieux,
on va dire à Science Po voilà s très
sérieux cette fois. Voilà. Et c'est là
que j'ai j'ai expérimenté une méthode,
c'est là que j'ai enseigné et maintenant
je forme pour des institutions qui sont,
disons préoccupés par le souci de se
ressaisir en matière de de prospective
parce que la prospective stratégique
c'est quelque chose qui est quand même
important et sur lequel on a fait un
petit peu l'impasse en fait hein si on
voit bien notre notre situation
stratégique, notre incapacité parfois
alors à prévoir, j'en parle pas, mais
même à se préparer
Et donc il y a vraiment une nécessité de
reprendre les choses de reprendre les
choses au fondement et finalement avec
des méthode renouvelé et bien
d'enseigner bien sûr pour les plus
jeunes et puis de former ceux qui sont
aux manettes pour pas dire les cadres
dirigeants mais au moins ceux qui voilà
qui sont qui managent qui sont aux
affaires à différents niveaux et les
former leur proposer de nouvelles
méthodes de prospective stratégique sur
lesquelles on va peut-être pouvoir
revenir. pas tout à fait les épades mais
c'est pas non plus la maternelle, on va
dire que c'est les corps intermédiaires,
ceux qui font le pays. D'ailleurs, si on
Google ton nom sur internet, on on peut
trouver deux quelques conférences de
formation et quel type d'institution tu
peux t'amener à former ? Quel type d'PAD
? La question c'est pourquoi ils ont eu
besoin d'avoir un troublillon,
un un quelqu'un qui pensait en dehors de
la boîte pour pour moduler ou adapter ou
se remettre en question ou trouver
d'autres pistes ? C'est parce qu'il y
avait un manque de résultat. C'est parce
qu'ils sont rendus compte qu'ils étaient
simplement spectateurs comme des vaches
regardant le TGV passé et puis de temps
en temps ils se retrouvaient au milieu
de la voie ferrée, il se faisait
écraser. Euh c'est pour une question de
business, c'est parce qu'ils sont en
train de paniquer. C'est pour pourquoi
ils ont besoin d'un jeune troublillon
turbulent pour leur secouer le cerveau ?
Mais alors jeune, je sais pas. Trublion
non plus. En faiton avec en fait en fait
le truc c'est le truc c'est que euh et
je te retrouve bien là en fait Sky,
c'est que tu veux tout rationaliser, tu
veux tout pouvoir expliquer après coup
comme si ça avait été prévu avant coup.
Et j'ai vu qu'il y avait un commentaire.
J'explique j'explique
la question c'est moi je regarde la
balance commerciale française et je
vois- 156 milliards.
Ça ça s'appelle un résultat le sujet.
C'est c'est un résultat mais c'est pas
le c'est pas la réponse à ta question.
La réponse à ta question c'est comment
on en vient éventuellement à se dire
qu'il faut penser en dehors de la boîte
et où il faut renouveler les méthodes et
cetera. En fait ça se fait pas forcément
de façon hyper rationnelle pensée,
planifié et cetera. C'est-à-dire que il
y a une prise de conscience. On voit
bien que il y a la balance commerciale
dont tu parles et puis on pourrait
multiplier les champs d'investigation
hein politique, sécuritaire, défense et
cetera, culturel aussi et cetera
logistique et on s'apercevrait
qu'effectivement il y a quand même pas
mal de curseurs au rouge et donc il y a
ce besoin comme je disais de pouvoir
sinon prévoir se préparer et dès là dès
lors qu'il y a une prise de conscience
on va dire qu'il y a un terau favorable
et puis après les trouvent les choses
trouvent leur chemin et c'est pas
forcément commandé depuis le haut c'est
pas forcément les institutions qui
trouvent leur troublillon. C'est
peut-être le troublillon qui trouve les
institutions et puis qui bottom up,
c'est les trucs managériaux que les
managers aiment bien. Moi, j'aime pas
spécialement mais enfin en bottom up, tu
apportes tes idées, tu es s tu proposes,
ils prennent, ils prennent pas et ça
trouve son chemin. C'est plutôt comme ça
en fait. Alors aujourd'hui, on va parler
géopolitique, anticipation, prospective
au temp chaîne logistique, guerre en
Ukraine, Israël et prospective à court,
moyen et long terme et surtout
astrologue de plateau télé peut-être.
On commence par quoi Jérôme ? Ah bah
c'est toi qui mène l'interview Sky ?
Ça fait 2 ans qu'on on s'est pas vu. On
s on s'est vu la première fois il y a 2
ans. En 2 ans, il y a beaucoup de choses
qui ont changé.
On parle, on va peut-être parler aussi
guerre dans l'espace
peut-être cyber cyberhacking guerry
hybride et tout toute ce tout ce collier
de perle de pseudox brassant des
concepts qu'il ne maîtrisent pas ou que
à travers de fiches Wikipédia ou que par
des ingérences étrangères financées par
la perfie d'Albion.
Jérôme CL Jérôme
est-ce que notre état major est-ce que
le renseignement militaire n'est pas
tellement dépassé qu'ils sont en train
de s'agiter parce que ils paniquent ?
Tu as secoué beaucoup de questions,
beaucoup de champs et tu se concentres
ça sur Non non mais je ne cherche pas à
gagner du temps. J'essaie de
véritablement répondre à ta question là.
Je crois que tu es venu pour pousser un
cadit. Tu as tu as tu as tu as brossé un
nombre de champs incommensurable et là
tu concentres sur le renseignement
militaire. Quand on parle du
renseignement militaire, de quoi on
parle ? Pour les gens qui nous écoutent
? Alors je vais expliquer ma question
pour les gens qui nous écoutent. Quand
on est analyste, quand on est
prospectiviste, on le fait à base de
renseignement de première main et de
haute qualité. Si ce n'est pas le cas,
ça ne s'appelle pas être analyste ni
prospectiviste. Ça s'appelle brasseur
d'air chaud ou sculpteur de fumé. Je
crois que tu as une vision erronée de ce
qui est la prospective. Mais c'est pas
grave. On a peut-être 3 heur devant
nous. Je t'en prie. Alors, qu'est-ce que
la prospective sans renseignement de
terrain ? Il y a deux choses. Il y a le
renseignement et la tentative d'analyse
d'une situation. Et attention, là, je
mets en garde les les téléspectateurs
sur les vertus ou le statut
épistémologique du renseignement. C'est
pas parce qu'on sait qu'un tel a
crocheté une serrure, le cas échéant,
qu'on va savoir ce qu'il va faire avec
ce qu'il a pris et comment ça va se
passer plus tard. Ça c'est pas vrai.
Faut pas demander au renseignement de
prévoir dans le simple domaine
militaire. Après, on peut essayer de
faire du renseignement économique, on
peut brosser tous les champ que tu as
brossé. Mais pour le cas du
renseignement militaire, le
renseignement militaire, la DRM,
qu'est-ce qu'elle va dire ? Elle va dire
voilà quelle est la situation tactique,
quelle est la situation éventuellement
stratégique avec des capacités
militaires, des troupes sur le terrain
et cetera et savoir quelle est la
configuration pour une situation de
combat donné, éventuellement renseigner
sur les comment les dispositifs ennemis
et cetera, mais elle va pas prévoir la
façon dont va se faire un combat. si le
combat va se déclencher, elle peut
émettre éventuellement des avis et par
le passé et c'est en source ouverte
hein, tout le monde sait la façon dont
la façon dont
il y a eu les commentaires sur l'analyse
de la DRM et d'autres services quand la
guerre en Ukraine s'est déclenchée. En
fait, il faut pas demander au
renseignement d'être madame Soleil et de
prévoir. Faut demander au renseignement
d'expliquer et après la question de la
prévision, de la préparation, de la
pensée, ça c'est quelque chose qui pour
le coup c'est l'air chaud dont tu
parlais. Ça ça demande en fait des
méthodes qui sont en réalité
complètement à construire et à exploiter
ensuite quand je dis à construire c'est
qu'il faut retravailler sur toute
l'approche cognitive. La façon dont se
fait la connaissance et la façon le
renseignement est un élément de la
connaissance. Mais c'est loin d'être le
seul. Il y a une époque, il y a un
service que je vais pas nommer euh je ne
dis même pas s'il est français
d'ailleurs, qui s'était mis dans l'idée
de faire une cellule prospective de
prospective en se disant bah nous
justement on bénéficie du renseignement
donc on va faire de la prospective mieux
que les autres. Et en fait, j'ai
l'impression qu'il a jamais vraiment
trouvé son segment, sa voix parce que la
partie renseignement, c'est-à-dire les
le 1 % de l'info qui manque, en réalité
quasiment tout est dans l'ouvert, tout
est dans l'ouvert ne sert pas
véritablement cette prévision ou cette
préparation ou cette façon de
construire, d'envisager l'avenir et même
et on y reviendra, de comprendre la
situation présente. Quand on est capable
de bien comprendre sous différents
angles la situation présente et donc il
y a une vision polymorphe, en fait, on
est déjà en capacité de voir ce qui peut
se produire. C'est plutôt en creusant le
présent et en ayant une connaissance
renouvelée du présent, du réel présent,
qu'on peut avoir une vision sur
l'avenir. Et pour avoir cette
connaissance renouvelée du réel présent,
il y a des méthodes que j'ai développé,
que je vais proposer, que j'ai déjà
proposé, que j'ai expérimenté dans des
cadres scientifiques et institutionnels
et qui finalement sur la partie état de
l'art peut valoriser du renseignement ce
1 % qu'on n pas où il faut crocheter la
serrure où il faut des capteurs
techniques humains opérationnels et j'en
passe. Pourquoi pas ? Mais c'est pas ça
qui va faire l'essentiel en réalité. On
va pas dire qu'on s'en privait si on
l'avait, mais c'est pas ça qui a faire
essentiel. Il y a des institutions que
je ne nommerai pas ici qui sont capables
de produire des notes d'analyse en se
fondant uniquement sur de l'ouvert et
qui sont lu avec intérêt des plus hautes
autorités. Qu'est-ce qui fait la
différence ? Ce qui fait la différence,
c'est la pensée que tu mets autour de
fait acceptés. Et quand tu les revisites
avec un regard nouveau, alors parfois on
conceptualise, c'est la partie verbau
gélatineux à poil dur que voilà tu dis
la la flû mais en réalité quand tu
conceptualises et que tuinventes un
nouveau mot tuvres tout un univers. Et
cet univers, tu l'ouvres pas que pour
toi, tu l'ouvres aussi pour les
décideurs que tu associes à ta
réflexion. Mais il faut les associer à
ta réflexion. C'estàd que si tu arrives
clé en main avec un rapport, la plupart
du temps, un rapport on sait que c'est
fait pour caler les bureaux. Par contre,
si tu associes les décideurs, les cadres
dirigeants, les managers, ces corps
intermédiaires dont je parlais, ceux qui
sont pas à l'PPAD mais qui sont plus non
plus à la maternelle, tu les associ à
ces travaux qu'en gros tu provoques, je
vais sortir un gros mot
jargonnant mais sur lequel on reviendra,
que tu les associes à ce phénomène
d'individuation, c'està-dire par lequel
en fait tu es un individu en je dire en
coalescence où tu te grandis toi-même et
où tu vois autrement la connaissance du
présent si tuis de lunett. tu enlèves
les lunettes roses, tu mets les lunettes
vertes, mais ça donne une vision en
relief. Et bien ça, si tu les associes à
ça, leur façon de décider en est
complètement changé. C'est ça la bonne
prospective. C'est pas filer un rapport
en leur disant voilà les scénarios
possibles, c'est les construire avec eux
et qu'ils en soient véritablement
pénétrés dans leur esprit et dans leur
chair pour qu'au moment où ils prennent
la décision, cette décision, elle soit
tout autre. Voilà, déjà une première
approche de la prospective, ça nous
extirpe de du renseignement proprement
militaire ou pas que. Le renseignement,
j'allais dire que peut produire les
services intérieurs, les renseignements
des douanes, les renseignements de
tracf, les renseignements de toute
l'académie du renseignement pour parler
de l'écosystème français. Alors, Jacques
Blam ont résumé ça très bien à sa façon.
Jacques Jacques nous disait
il faut toujours garder son calme
parce que moi j'aurais jamais réussi à
envoyer des ballons sur Vénus si je
n'avais pas appris à composer avec les
cons.
La question que je te pose, c'est avec
toute cette
ce jus de cerveau, ces nouvelles
méthodes, cette façon d'emmener
les gens avec toi, de les convaincre,
comment t'expliqu 156 milliards en
balance extérieure ? Comment t'explique
que on est réduit à l'état de spectateur
sur la géopolitique et les chiqu
internationales ? Comment tu expliques
que
on est devenu une puissance de moyenne
impuissance ?
Alors moi je suis pas là pour expliquer
le passé, je suis plutôt là pour tenter
contribuer à ma mesure et le futur ne
pas comprendre le passé. Ne pas
comprendre le passé. Fini ma phrase.
Ah non mais ne pas comprendre le passé.
C'est ce que je t'ai dit du
renseignement ce que je t'ai dit du
renseigne pas du tout. Je m'inscris en
faux. Alors tu as le droit de le penser
hein. C'est c'est tout à fait légitime
mais pour le coup je n'y crois pas.
Le statut épistémologique du
renseignement c'est le même que
l'histoire. Ça tombe bien c'est pas une
facilité mais c'est vrai. Et on le voit.
Tu parlais des astrologues de plateau
euh à chaque fois oh l'histoire voilà on
a connu cette situation c'est Munique
hein et on saura dans quel cas le
parallèle a été dressé je je parle pas
de ça là ça marche pas on n'est pas
condamné à revivre le passé la
prospective le renseignement infin ça
sert à quoi ça sert à protéger la France
le business de la France le PIP de la
France le rayonnement de la France mais
il faut attendre que ça produisse ses
fruit en En fait, je vais deevir les
téléspectateurs, mais en fait le
travail, il est à faire sur 25 ans.
Alors pourquoi 25 ans ? Parce que c'est
une génération. Ce que je suis en train
de te dire là, les méthodes qu'on va
mettre en place, évidemment, elles se
font ni pour la maternelle ni pour
l'épade. On va dire pour le corps
intermédiaire, mais faut que ça imprime,
que ça diffuse dans la population.
Idéalement, il faudrait alors on va
commencer par la fin de l'interview,
mais idéalement, il faudrait et j'avais
eu l'occasion de le dire à une audition
au Sénat d'ailleurs, j'avais été
auditionné en tant que quel titre ? En
tant qu'enseignant en prospective à
Science Po et auteur d'un ouvrage que
j'ai commis, que tu avais eu la
gentillesse de de présenter la dernière
fois et j'avais été invité à ce titre là
et j'avais je m'étais prononcé, c'était
sur le commissariat au plan. Je n'avais
pas ni analysé, ni critiqué, ni prononcé
sur les travaux du commissariat au plan.
J'ai simplement dit ce que de façon
positive on pouvait faire en matière de
prospective et comment on pouvait le
faire. Et le le sénateur qui m'a écouté
euh la commission euh de finances, je ne
le citerai pas ici mais euh ça peut se
retrouver très facilement. Une
commission ouverte commission euh
commission des finances du Sénat qui
ouverte. Alors, tu peux citer son nom ?
Non, enfin pardon, c'était à H clos euh
dans la façon dont ça m'a été auditionné
et je me suis contenté de de présenter
en fait mes travaux et en gros j'ai dit
bah opérer parce qu'il était euh il
était accompagné opérer par
soustraction. Moi, je vous dis la façon
dont on peut faire les choses et qui
permettrait de renouveler un peu
l'approche et puis après vous verrez si
c'est comme ça qu' les font et vous en
tirez les conclusions. Je suis pas là
pour vous apporter les conclusions. Et
j'avais conclu le propos en lui disant
en gros, il faudrait que dès la classe
de philosophie en terminale euh dans la
philosophie de l'action, il y ait
quelque chose sur la prospective. Il
faut dans le bon sens du terme former
l'esprit de nos jeunes au temps long à
la prospective, à la préparation de
l'avenir, à la façon de retraduire la
réalité présente pour savoir quels sont
les gisements et ce qui peut se produire
sans pour autant prévoir et se préparer.
Ça c'est quelque chose de fondamental.
Mais du coup effectivement ça prend du
temps et c'est pas en le faisant
j'allais dire du jour au lendemain qu'on
peut avoir des résultats des résultats
sur
il faut 25 ans. Il faut 25 ans pour
changer un état d'esprit. Il faut 25 ans
pour résultat des astres qu'on a à
l'heure actuelle.
C'est parce que ça fait 25 ans qu'on
bosse pas dans le bon sens.
Alors là pour le coup et je mais tout à
fait je m'abstrait de toute polémique.
De toute façon, la prospective est
au-dessus des polémiques et on n'est pas
là pour commenter l'action de Pierre
Paul Jacques. C'est pas le sujet. Là,
c'est vraiment collectif et ça dépasse
même les frontières. Il y a 30 ans, et
je vais sortir imponsif, mais faut quand
même le dire, il y a eu les dividendes
de la paix, il y a eu la fin Non mais
oui, mais faut le dire, mais c'est quand
même ça. Il y a eu la fin de l'histoire
de de pardon de Fukuyama. Il y a eu le
choc des civilisations qui nous a fait
croire que les guerres n'existaient plus
et que c'était uniquement culturel. Bon,
je passe surtout ces poncifs mais du
coup ça fait 30 ans qu'il y a quand même
une une forme de d'assoupissement pour
être voilà c'est assoupé euh pardon de
sédation. Alors sédation, je sais pas le
mot est fort mais on s'est assoupi. Il y
a eu un assouplissement stratégique.
Pourquoi j'utilise le mot sédation ?
Sédation dit intoxication.
Oui mais je suis pas là. Alors oui, mais
je suis pas sûr que ça vienne de
l'extérieur. Encore une fois, je pose la
question, je pose la question, je pose
la question.
Quand on voit en cus, quand on voit nos
présidents de la République écouté par
Pierre Paul Jacques et et nos amis
outreatlantiques, quand on voit les
Allemands nous tirer dans les pattes
avec le programme nucléaire, quand on
voit la guerre économique,
mais tu vois dans ce que dans ce que tu
listes là, c'est de la sédation, c'est
de la Non, c'est de la collusion parce
que dans ce que tu cites là, c'est c'est
jamais la même personne. qui est aux
manettes. Tu vois, un coup tu dis les
Allemands à bon droit peut-être, un coup
tu dis les Américains avec Ocus, c'était
ça. À bon droit peut-être, à bon droit
sûrement sur travailler là, c'est et
cetera. Donc tu c'est jamais les mêmes
en fait. Et donc tu vois bien qu'on
n'est pas dans ni dans le complot. C'est
pas ce que je dis, c'est pas le même qui
administre la sédation. Il faut que ce
soit le même médecin qui mette la
seringue. Là, c'est pas le cas. En fait,
la collusion, c'est chacun en fait tire
ses intérêts mais il y a pas de pouvoir
central. Ça va décevoir les complotistes
parce que les complotiste aiment bien
l'idée qu'il y ait un pouvoir central
qui manigance tout et dont on serait le
jeu. C'est pas le cas en fait. C'est
hyper décentralisé mais je ne t'apprends
rien et c'est pour ça que je préfère le
mot collusion à complot ou sédation. Et
collectivement, cette collusion euh et
bien a pu euh connaître une un certain
assoupissement pour certains de ces
cidation parce que quand on voit les
chiffre de l'économie française qui est
en fait le résultat de tout cet
endormissement volontaire ou
involontaire ou provoqué,
je suis pas sûr qu'il y a que l'économie
française en fait c'est l'Europe si on
veut aller plus loin il faut pas se
comparer il faut pas se comparer au
derniers de la classe.
C'est plus grave en fait. C'est plus
grave que ce que tu C'est beaucoup plus
grave que ce que ce que tu soullignes.
Tu dis la France. Bon la France OK, bon
d'accord la France mais les c'est
collectivement les Européens qui sont en
train d'être éjectés de l'histoire.
L'histoire avec un grand tâche. Te
souviens du on peut en parler
maintenant. Il est le président Sarkozi
qui avait dont le conseiller spécial que
tu avais reçu me semble-t-il avait fait
un discours discours de ah la capitale
m'échappe là l'instant c'était en
Afrique et avait dit l'Afrique n'est pas
entrée dans l'histoire et ben là
l'Europe est sur le point d'en sortir en
fait voilà l'Europe est sur le point de
sortir de l'histoire ça c'est quand même
important et on le voit j'allais dire
sur tous les curseurs
sur la l'analyse multidimensionnelle que
tu as faite initialement en me disant et
la politique et l'économie et la
technologie et les conflits et euh et
pardon les finances et le la culture et
cetera. Surtout les culseurs, on est on
est sur le point d'être éjecté de
l'histoire. Le 11 c'est l'Europe et
c'est pas l'Europe c'est pas l'Europe
d'aujourd'hui. C'est pas le Bah, on va y
aller. C'est pas l'Europe d'aujourd'hui.
C'est pas l'Europe d'il y a 5 ans ou
l'Europe d' 10 ans. C'est l'Europe en
réalité qui a déjà bifurqué il y a 30
ans d'une certaine manière. il y a 30
ans, ces fameux dividendes de la paix et
cette fameuse fin de l'histoire qui n'en
était pas une. Je te coupe parce que là
je suis en train de lire un commentaire
et on va on va lui en mettre un petit
peu dans la tête. On va le faire en
direct parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est un peu
spécial. C'est l'été, c'est la dernière
de la saison.
Donc le commentaire qui n'est pas très
respectueux mais on va le lire quand
même. Bonjour Syerview. Pourquoi prendre
le temps avec un astrologue de plateau
télé ? Il y a pas marqué plateau mais on
le pense Angeliver qui plaît au médias
mainstream et aux politiques qui sont
assez bêtes pour écouter un sculpteur
d'air chaud.
Je lis pas la fin. Alors je réponds
moi-même. Oui. Réponds réponds. Tu vas
sur Google, tu prends son nom, tu
regardes ce qu'il a fait comme vidéo et
on en reparle après. Tu viens t'excuser
après dans le chat. Non, c'est pas la
peine de s'excuser en fait. Mais je
comprends pas. Non non mais c'est même
pas la peine que ce cette personne
s'excuse parce qu'en fait je je
comprends tout à fait en fait son son
prisme et c'est là où il faut être
capable de voir le présent sous sous
plusieurs facettes et le présent il il
s'applique aux objets puis s'applique au
sujet c'estàd aux personnes en chair et
en os éventuellement de temps en temps
avec un cerveau entre les deux oreilles.
et et en fait on peut être multifacette,
on peut faire de l'information
factuelle sur le moment avec une
temporalité qui est le temps court et
qui est la vie au quotidien, la mienne,
la tienne, celle de nos concitoyens. Et
puis de temps en temps, on peut
s'abstraire de de ce de cette
temporalité là. Et c'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire ici. Ici, on est un peu
hors espace-temps là. Le temps ne compte
plus, hein. Voilà. Ça fait une faille
spatiotemporelle. Exactement.
Exactement. Je suis très content d'être
dans cette faille spatiotemporelle. Et
dans cette faille-là, on voit les choses
en temps long. On sort des polémiques,
on nabrasse pas Pierre-Pul Jacques,
personne n'est responsable de rien, on
met tout à plat et on se dit pourquoi
les choses se sont produites et pourquoi
et d'où ? À partir de quand ? Je vois
souvent cette phrase à partir de quand
ça a merdé ça. Bah à partir de quand ?
En fait, c'était il y a 30 ans. Ça s'est
pas fait tout de suite. C'est pas la
peine d'aller chercher les responsables
rue du Faubour, Saint-Honoré ou je ne
sais trop où. C'est c'est pas la peine.
C'est pas là en fait qui est le sujet.
Le sujet, il est bien avant. Il est bien
avant et il est pas ici. Il est bien
ailleurs aussi. Il est sur notre façon
collective et j'en reviens à mon truc,
il est sur notre façon collective de
travailler sur l'avenir et on serait
étonné par exemple de voir que bah c'est
éminemment culturel cette construction
de l'avenir et cette construction du
réel présent. Les Chinois par exemple
dans leur prospective eux ils
considèrent l'avenir comme passé
comme déjà réalisé. Pourquoi font-ils ça
? Je ne sais pas mais je vais leur poser
la question. Pourquoi ? Il y a sans
doute une façon en fait un biais
cognitif qui fait que quand tu
considères que les choses sont pas
encore produites, tu les envisages pas
de la même façon que si tu les envisage
comme déjà produite. Et c'est pas si
j'allais dire c'est pas si étonnant
parce que si tu as une vision linéaire
du temps, bah qui est la nôtre très oci
occidentale, bon on est là-dedans. Mais
si tu as une vision cyclique ou une
vision peut-être même atemporelle un peu
processuelle du temps et et non pas
mécanique, on a une vision mécanique
occidentaux que nous sommes, c'est une
vision un peu plus processuelle du temps
avec une vision intermédiaire qui serait
la vision de Berkson où il y a un peu du
temps mécanique et puis il y a un peu le
temps invention qui est hors tout dans
lequel il y a des une fluence d'état de
conscience qui fait que on a des
approches sur le réel qui est jamais
bien verrouillé et où une chose peut
nous apparaître d'une façon et puis
après sous une autre, c'est les
anamorphoses. Si nos téléspectateurs
regardent les anamorphoses, n'importe
quel musée ou n'importe quel truc d'art
contemporain, c'est saisissant en fait.
C'est une même chose qui se monte sous
des angles différents. C'est ça
l'approche du réel qu'il faut. Mais pour
construire tout ça et pour construire
les méthodes, je finis juste là-dessus.
Pour construire les méthodes sur tu
finis quand tu veux. Voilà pour pour
mettre en œuvre les méthodes qui rendent
opératoire ce qui paraît de la fumée.
Pour passer de cette fumée à à la fin,
on a construit quelque chose avec les
cadres dirigeants ou avec les jeunes si
on veut les former dès le départ. Bah ça
demande un peu de boulot. On le fera
vraisemblablement pas ce soir bien sûr,
mais je donne déjà rendez-vous à ceux
qui disent c'est de la sculpture de
surfumée. Je leur donne rendez-vous au
mois de décembre et je leur dirai où est
quand. Je leur donne rendez-vous au mois
de mars et je leur dirai où est quand.
Voilà. Et et d'ailleurs avant ça, je
leur donne rendez-vous au mois de
septembre et je leur dirai où est quand.
Et ils verront comment on passe de la
sculpture surfumée de "Ouais, il nous
fait voir le réel présent différemment
et ça nous permet d'envisager le futur.
Il a été aminé le mec." Non, pas du
tout. En fait, il y a véritablement une
matrice, une grande courroie de
transmission qui permet de construire
tout ça de bout en bout. Pas
surrationalisé non plus parce que là, ce
serait ridicule. Ce serait comme essayer
de mettre le le réel en équation
mathématique, mais suffisamment
pour moissonnant sur notre culture
occidentale, qui veut on est des
modernes, on a besoin d'un truc un peu
machinal, un peu opératoire, un peu
matriciel donc suffisamment rationaliser
pour nous servir de mains courante et
aboutir à quelque chose d'utile. Voilà,
tu as terminé ?
C'était beau. C'était très très une
envolée lyrique comme on aime. Tu dis,
tu vas demander aux Chinois comment ils
font ? Tu fais comment pour aller
demander aux Chinois ? Bah simplement,
il y a des scénacles où on reçoit
un endroit, un lieu de conférence
internationale où on peut recevoir tout
un tas de monde et on peut inviter
pourquoi pas des Chinois puis ils en
verront qu'ils veulent représenter la
prospective. C'est comment pour aller
les voir dans leur biotope les Chinois ?
Dans leur biotop, c'estàd leur
écosystème à eux, bah faut aller là-bas
mais là c'est pas mon sujet. Après on
peut pas exclure on des recherches
d'être amené à le faire. Pourquoi pas ?
comment un analyste, un prospectiviste
peut faire de la prospective et de
l'analyse sans prendre la température
en profondeur ? Alors attention, ça j'ai
pas dit que Attention, mais là tu me
fais dire chose que j'ai pas dit. J'ai
pas dit qu'il fallait pas prendre la
température en profondeur. L'état de
l'art, l'état de l'art quand tu fais une
thèse, quand tu fais un travail de
recherche, il est jamais fini, hein. Il
est jamais fini. Pourquoi ? Parce que
l'état de l'art, on dit voilà, j'ai fait
le tour d'un sujet et voilà ce qu'il se
dit sur le sujet et voilà l'état de la
connaissance et voilà l'état de la
vérité. Euh je me contredirai si je
disais ça parce qu'en fait euh c'est
l'état de l'art a un instant présent
selon un prisme donné et tu peux
toujours le retraduire. Donc en fait le
présent il s'investigue et la
connaissance en profondeur et c'est
jamais fini. Tout ça pour dire quoi ?
Tout ça pour dire que si il faut
effectivement aller toujours plus loin,
ça c'est quelque chose que l'on
s'interdit pas. Euh je ne dis pas qu'il
ne faut pas aller euh voyager, on sait
que c'est ça peut être nécessaire euh
pour aller chercher des informations,
pour rencontrer les bonnes personnes. Ça
c'est des choses qui sont possibles.
Après, ils peuvent venir chez nous,
c'est peut-être insuffisant parce que tu
penses qu'en les sortant de leur biotop,
ils nous diront pas forcément la même
chose. Mais la prospective et
l'influence, c'est l'avert et le revers
d'une même médaille. Mais dis-moi
comment tu fais de l'influence et je te
dirai qui tu es, hein, d'une certaine
manière. Donc c'est aussi instructif.
Moi je te dirai quels sont tes résultats
et je te dirai qui tu es si tu es le
couteau moins affuté tiroir. Ça ça ou la
chip la moins craquante du paquet. C'est
ça. Le pingouin qui glisse le moins le
moins ou le moins loin. Ouais. C'est ça.
Euh là, de ce côté-là, les résultats, il
y a plusieurs types de résultats en
prospective attendu. Le premier déjà,
alors là partir d'un truc un peu
ésotérique, mais ça a pas duré
longtemps, c'est la transformation de
soi. Je te disais, on travaille avec les
cadres dirigeants, avec ceux qui sont
aux manettes et ceux qui sont aux
affaires. Si déjà en fait, ils ont une
autre façon de voir les choses, ils sont
plus forts pour aborder les crises et la
surprise. Parce qu'en fait, tu as beau
prévoir, on veut pas prévoir en fait.
C'est illusoire de dire qu'on va prévoir
en fait. On peut pas. Mais ce que l'on
peut c'est moi je suis pas d'accord. Ce
que l'on peut. Ah bah on va rediscuter.
Mais mais oui oui mais juste
Oui. Non mais attention dans une salle
de muscu quand tu te muscles, bon tu es
formé après à soulever un poids de 2 kg
mais c'est pas forcément ce poids-ci. Ça
peut être ce poids là. Mais en gros il
fait à peu près 2 kg. Ta parabole est
pas la bonne. Si si parce qu'attends j'y
vais. Attends, attends, attends. Si tu
as bien réfléchi sur tous les les
ruptures possibles, idéalement des
ruptures qu' du sens, si tu as vu la
façon dont les choses pouvaient se
retraduire, si tu t'es préparé à des
réponses possibles, le jour où vient une
rupture, Fight Club, tu as vu Fight
Club, attends, je finis. Le jour où elle
devient une rupture, tu es pas démuni.
En fait, ton corps est préparé à prendre
le choc et ton espèce. Il y a des gens
qui font de la gonflette et il y a du
gens qui des gens qui font de la box
taille ou de la box française.
Donc quand tu t'es pris 25 patates dans
ta gueule,
tuaprends à lever ta garde. On peut
prendre cette parabole là. Si si tu fais
des muscu, tu dis "Oui, je vais préparer
mon corps à réon prenons ta part."
Est-ce que tu penses qu'on s'est pas
suffisamment pris de patates dans notre
économie, de patates dans notre
diplomatie, de patates sur les chiqu
international pour commencer à se
réveiller ? Quand tu parles à tes gens
de l'ÉPAD, d'accord ? Si tu sens une
adhérence
intellectuelle ou si tu sens qu'ils sont
pas câblés et pas équipés pour
comprendre mais si je te dis que je sens
une adhérence intellectionne, tu vas
dans le privé. Ouais. Tu vas pas sentir
plus d'adhérence dans le privé. Pourquoi
ça adhérerait plus dans le privé que
dans le public ? Cas éch les
institutions pas dans le privé au moins
tu prendras quatre fois le salaire. Oui
mais c'est pas le sujet en fait. C'est
quoi le sujet ? C'est le patriotisme.
Mais non le sujet c'est de faire des
choses qui ont du sens et en
l'occurrence si tu es capable
véritablement de faire en sorte que les
gens alors ta parabole sur le la muscu,
elle te va pas. OK, prenons celle du
sport de combat. La prospective est un
sport de combat.
Le boxeur, il est pas prêt à recevoir ce
coup de point ici. Il le prévoit pas. Il
va au mieux de temps en temps l'esquiver
en limiter l'impact parce qu'il est
entraîné à réagir à ce genre de
situation. ce genre de situation.
C'estàd qu'on travaille sur des classes.
La bonne prospective, elle doit t'avoir
transformé suffisamment pour que tu sois
prêt à traiter des classes de surprise
et que tu es des classes de scénarios
qui te permettent d'avoir des classes de
réponse stratégique et d'avoir
suffisamment envisagé avec les moyens
que tu as les bonnes capacités. Voilà.
Et typiquement, bon bah là si on disait
tiens la fameuse rupture des drones.
Bon, la rupture des drones
oui, ça est une mais d'une certaine
manière, c'est pas aussi c'est une
rupture bien sûr, mais elle est pas sans
doute pas aussi aussi franche et aussi
catégorique et aussi radicale que ce que
l'on veut bien dire
et surtout on n'est peut-être pas aussi
peu préparé qu'on veut bien le dire.
Voilà. Bon, donc en fait, c'est ces
gammes là de de ruptures, c'est-à-dire
de choses qui qui changent les
tendances. Il y a les tendances, il y a
les ruptures, on y reviendra. Euh qu'il
faut être en mesure d'absorber. C'est ça
la bonne préparation. C'est un des
objectifs de la prospective. Un autre
objectif, mais il a dire il est
incident, c'est le fait effectivement
d'avoir préparé des scénarios qui ont
une chance d'être proche de ce que l'on
rencontre. Mais c'est vraiment un
objectif mineur. En réalité, l'objectif
premier, il est sur la personne. Je
comprends, je comprends ton approche qui
est tout à fait louable.
C'est bien présenté, c'est bien designé,
tu essayes de faire de du hacking
intellectuel auprès des gens en capacité
d'eux. C'est c'est une bonne stratégie.
C'est pas un peu trop tard ?
C'està-dire la latence ? Mais déjà, il
est jamais trop tard pour bien faire
hein puisquon Bah oui. Non, mais c'est
quand Mais oui, mais c'est quand même
important. C'est quand même vrai. Le
langage courant a du bon sens. Là, on
est coincé. Tu dis rupture. Moi les gens
qui me disent rupture, je leur dis "Mais
c'est parce que vous avez pas anticipé,
tu parles des drones."
Il y a une grande il y a une grande
différence entre l'anticipation et la
prospective. D'ailleurs, je cite ça de
l'extérieur, je crois savoir que le
ministère des armées
différencie l'anticipation stratégique
et la prospective, me semble-t-il, pour
ce que je peux en connaître,
l'anticipation,
le cône, il est comme ça et donc c'est
plus les tendances, même si ça n'exclut
pas des ruptures. La prospective, on est
plus au-delà des 10 15 ans, on est plus
sur le l'horizon d'une génération parce
qu'en fait qu'est-ce qui est clé dans la
prospective ? c'est qu'il faut pouvoir
intégrer le renouvellement des esprits
que tu vas produire ou subir mais dans
tous les cas il y aura un renouvellement
des esprits. Tu connais la phrase du
guépard tout changer pour que rien ne
change. C'està-dire qu'au bout d'un
moment ce qui peut se passer et ce qui
va se passer immanquablement c'est que
le prisme d'appréciation du changement
lui-même va changer. Et si tu n'intègres
pas ça dans tes scénarios et ben tu
passes à côté en fait. Et donc le simple
fait d'avoir cette musculation
intellectuelle qui est dans des
scénarios dynamiques. Les scénarios, on
dit les scénarios mais c'est des
scénario dynamique. Ça veut dire quoi
dynamique ? Ça veut pas dire que ça
bouge. Ça veut dire qu'en fait les
éléments qui structurent le scénario
eux-mêmes vont évoluer au moment où le
scénario va se dérouler. Et ça, il faut
l'intégrer sur de l'anticipation sur des
échelles de temps qui sont plus courtes
encore qu'elles sont relativisées par ce
qui se passe parce que parfois en 2 ans,
il y a plus de changement qu'en 25 ans.
Enfin, passons. C'est pourquoi ? Bah
parce qu'il y a des ruptures justement.
Parce que les gens ont faim.
Est-ce que tu penses qu'on on on a fait
notre prospective, notre anticipation,
notre acquisition de renseignement
avec des gens qui avait pas assez faim,
pas assez les canines
en titane forgé ?
Est-ce qu'il est pas temps, tu on entend
Emmanuel Macron dire il y a il y a les
herbivores, il y a les prédateurs.
On a reçu Ça vient de chez toi ça. On a
reçu un général ici et il nous a dit
"Ouais bah quand on regarde les
scénarios, ça me fait penser à un
épisode de Jurassic Park.
Est-ce qu'il est pas temps d'aller
chercher les chez nous, les méchants,
les bad boys, les affamés, les gens qui
ont envie d'aller en découdre pour aller
chercher de l'information ? faire de la
prospective pour anticiper les méchants
et les bad boys tu cherch un job. Non
non, il paye pas assez. Passez, il y a
pas assez de reconnaissance et il y a
c'est un épatel ouvert.
Je ne sais pas quoi te répondre là parce
que je ne je pense qu'il y a une part
fantasmée dans cette idée que seuls les
méchants, les bad boys et cetera
seraient efficace. Alors dans le de la
prospective, au vu de ce que j'ai
expliqué, j'ai pas dit qu'il fallait des
lunettes roses, mais tu vois bien qu'on
n'est pas véritablement dans la débauche
de testostérone, quoi. C'est pas
vraiment c'est pas vraiment ça qui va
nous porter. Mais allons sur la partie,
j'allais dire plutôt anticipation ou
peut-être qu'il faudrait éventuellement
je fais ton jeu mais aller chercher du
renseignement qu'on aurait pas mais là
on est on est vraiment dans une part un
peu fantasmé au moins hypothétique sinon
fantasmé. Est-ce que c'est ça qui nous
manque ? Là, je fais un peu de
benchmark. Est-ce que l'prense qu'on
doit transmettre à la population, c'est
maintenant on se retrousse les manches
et on montre les cros. Ah, alors ça euh,
tu parles d'esprit de défense là à 100
%. Évidemment qu'il y a un esprit de
défense à renforcer dans la population
et dans la population, je dire
européenne au sens large, autant qu'on
peut généraliser parce que il y a
justement cet enjeu pour l'Europe de
passer à côté de de l'histoire. Voilà.
Et donc là, oui, il y a un esprit de
défense à forger. Et là, tu vas dans mon
sens, ça veut dire que ça, il faut
travailler le ministère stratégique,
c'est pas le ministère, c'est le
ministère des armées, bien sûr. Voilà,
c'est aussi le ministère, c'est aussi le
dorset, c'est aussi le ministère
stratégique, c'est l'éducation nationale
et la recherche dans mon sens mais tu es
10 m derrière, tu as pas remarqué. C'est
le ministère de l'éducation nationale et
de la recherche. C'est ça le ministère
stratégique parce que il est là. Si tu
formes à l'esprit de défense, à la
prospective, à l'idée du temps long, à
cette capacité d'avoir une plasticité
sur le réel, à se reconfigurer et peu
importe que tu es prévu, même le temps
n'arrive pas à le prévoir hein. J'avais
vu un des commentaires sur euh sur ton
miniature là sur Twitter, euh tu as dit
"On va exploser l'incertitude, on y
reviendra". Puis quelqu'un un internaute
qui a immédiatement mis René Tom. Bon,
René Tom euh théorie du chaos, prédire
n'est pas expliqué, c'est son bouquin,
enfin un de ses bouquins. Voilà, éminent
mathématicien euh qui a travaillé sur la
théorie du chaos, sujet euh que j'ai pu
appliquer dans le cadre de ma thèse il y
a 15 ans. Bref, bon, on peut pas prédire
ça. Il y a une c'est fondamentalement,
il y a une part d'indéterminisme qui
fait que voilà la prévision est de toute
façon pour des raisons pratique
épistémologique voire ontologique hors
champ. C'est pas un cach sexe ça. Mais
non, justement si tu prends conscience
de ça et du coup bah tu me donnes
l'occasion d'une transition, on n'est
pas dans
exploser l'incertitude, on est dans
exploiter l'incertitude. En fait
l'incertitude et la complexité n'accable
pas. C'est un gisement de liberté et
d'invention. En fait, on cherche pas à
prédire, on cherche à inventer et à
préampter. Si tu es capable de faire le
futur ou de peser dessus suffisamment
pour qu'il ressemble un peu à ce que tu
veux, t'en fous de le prédire. Tu l'as
fait, c'est beaucoup mieux. Là,
typiquement, les États-Unis, ces
derniers jours, il ils ont un petit peu
pesé sur le futur. Bon, ils ont pas eu à
le prévoir, ils l'ont fait. Bon, c'est
une façon de faire le futur. Ils sont
peut-être tombés dans un piège. Mais qui
se soit laissé emporter, c'est un autre
sujet. Que ils aient suivi Israël plus
qu'il ne l'ai devané, c'est possible
aussi. Mais au final avec leur poids,
leur vision des choses et cetera, ils
ont décidé ce qu'ils ont décidé et au
final ils ont fait le futur. Bon, c'est
une façon de le préempter. Voilà. Euh
quand tu fais de la prospective,
j'allais dire de façon plus
homéopathique et plus douce, euh sans
aller jusqu'à prendre le cerveau, mais
la guerre cognitive, c'est la maîtrise
et la prise des cerveaux. La prospective
est au cœur de la guerre cognitive. si
tu es capable d'avoir les bons récits
euh de diffuser les bons récits
construits sur des bons scénarios qui
ont été pétri euh accouché euh non pas
par un gourou qui se présente comme
prospectiviste mais euh par toute une
classe de décideurs qui ont travaillé à
ça et qui s'en sont véritablement
pénétrés et qui se retrouvent convaincus
et et qui qui s'en sont convaincus parce
qu'ils ont contribué à le construire.
C'est la coproduction au sens
véritablement noble du terme et pas
creux. Et là le signe noir arrive. Bah
le signe noir, le signe noir tu sais tu
disais il faut aller à l'extérieur, il
faut Oui, peut-être qu'il faut aller
chercher l'info, faut aller chercher un
mais mais c'est d'abord connais-toi
toi-même la prospective c'est d'abord en
soi. Les connaissances en réalité on les
a toujours. C'est plutôt la façon de les
mettre en relief. Donc mettre en relief
les connaissances. Voilà. Je voudrais te
mettre un peu en stress test. Quelles
sont tes connaissances des fondamentaux
de soutenabilité d'une économie
thermoindustrielle ?
Il y a beaucoup de mots barbar
là-dedans. Thermoindustriel. Bah alors
la soutenam thermoindustriel en gros, tu
me dis est-ce qu'on peut continuer comme
ça avec le pétrole ? C'est ça ? Avec
l'énergie carbonée. Est-ce qu'une
société carbonée peut encore une durée
de vie suffisante ? C'est c'est ça la
question. Éc l'économie c'est quoi ? Bah
l'économie c'est une façon de créer de
la richesse et idéalement de la
partager. Convertir, c'est de convertir
c'est de convertir de l'énergie, c'est
convertir de la matière en énergie puis
de l'énergie en service en bien et euh
faire en sorte que la maison commune
hein, l'économie soit bien gérée que bon
d'accord. Quelles sont tes connaissances
des grandes tendances qui vont mettre
sous contrainte nos économies
thermoindustrielles ? Alors, je cherche
pas à contourner la question, mais la
question telle que je la comprends,
c'est quand même rien qu'en formulant la
question, hein. Non, ce que je vais
essayer de la de la traiter euh sur un
angle où je pense y avoir suffisamment
réfléchi pour dire un truc euh qui a un
peu de sens et pas répéter des trucs
d'économistes bien plus capé que moi et
que je vais anonner. Donc c'est pas la
peine. Je suis capable d'en nonner
quelques-uns mais ça n'a aucun intérêt
ici. Il faudra les économistes parlent
moins plus de géologue de prospection
importe ou je vais pas non plus dire ce
que dit Jeankovichi, faudra l'inviter.
Tu l'as certainement déjà invité c'est
un voilà mon sujet moi mon sujet c'est
penser en dehors de la boîte c'est
toujours voir les choses autrement.
Quest question tu peux aussi. Oui. Bah
justement, c'est quand tu me dis voilà
réponds à la question comme ça, on va
traiter la question mais je vais pas
l'attaquer comme ça. Voilà, si je dois
euh si je dois percer le coffre avec la
femme au milieu et les épées, bah ce
sera jamais l'épée que tu me donnes. Je
vais en prendre une autre et je vais
percer autrement. Prestig prestitig.
Oui, mais je te montrerai pas mes trucs.
Voilà, ma façon de voir les choses sur
cette histoire d'énergie carbonée. Et
j'ai pas posé ça, j'ai pas posé les
questions d'énergie. Tu commences ton tu
commences avec ça si tu veux. Bon,
thermoindustriel thermoindustriel bref
qui une économie qui repose sur de
l'énergie. Bon, des matières et des
matières. Le gros problème fondamental
quelle que soit l'énergie alors énergie
renouvelable on en discutera, on va y
venir.
C'est le caractère fini des ressources.
Ça on l'a tous
traité 25 fois su sur votre chaîne. On
l' traité 25 fois. Là, je veux que tu me
parles de fournisseur. Je veux que tu me
parles de rétorsion, de sanctions
économiques, de murs économiques, de
rideau de fer pour anticiper les
tendances à 2 ans. C'est-à-dire si tu
veux me parler de la finitude, de
machin, le pic énergétique, le pétrol,
le pic cuivre, ainsi de suite, notre
communauté est suffisamment affutée.
Oui, mais ce que je vais te dire là et
laisse-moi le dire et après tu verras si
tu veux poursuivre sur le sujet ou si tu
veux vraiment changer en me déclarant
incompétent et on ne changera de sujet.
C'est qu'en fait on est parti avec un
postulat qui est un mantra qui est les
énergies sont finies donc cure
d'amaigrissement pour tout le monde et
donc sanction et donc décarbonation et
donc cetera et c'est punitif et c'est
pour ça que ça foire en fait parce qu'il
y a pas eu de prospective sur le sur le
climat. Il y a eu un travail éminent.
Attends, attends, attends, laisse-moi
finir. Il y a eu un éminent travail de
scientifique et on connaît les tendances
pour le coup du climat. On sait que les
1,5°gr de Paris déjà ça c'est mort,
c'est déjà fini. Ce sera 2,5 au mieux
peut-être davantage et on exclut pas.
éventuellement à la fin de d'ici la fin
de siècle, je parle sous couvert des des
climatologues qui de l'Académie des
Sciences ou d'ailleurs peuvent attester
de ce que je dis hein. Voilà, ça sera
vérifié dans le facting. On nexclut pas
un emballement de la machine climatique.
Bon bref, donc ça c'est prévu. Mais
autour de ça, soit tu te dis bon bah il
faut tout décarboner, il faut faire en
arrière et cetera soit euh tu imagines
autre chose. Con Musk lui il
va régler le problème en élargissant la
question des ressources et de l'espace
vital enant sur une autre planète. Bon
c'est sa façon de voir les choses.
Passer la seconde là et tu fais seconde
rupteur rupteur 3è 3è rupteur. Il y a
une autre façon d'envisager les choses
mais pour ça il va falloir parler plus
doucement et réfléchir plus finement
c'est-à-dire se dire on voit bien que
l'homme il est en train de changer. Il y
a un bouleversement anthropologique mais
si il est en train de changer, il est en
train de s'informatiser. Qu'est-ce qui
se passe ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe si la
Qu'est-ce qui se passe si la Russie par
2 ans à 2 ans ? Ça m'intéresse pas en
prospectiviste 2 ans. Ça m'intéresse pas
parce que tu l'as déjà traité. Mais non
mais ça à 2 ans, ça m'intéresse pas. Ça
t'intéresse pas ? En tant que
prospectiviste, en tant que citoyen, à
qui on doit poser la question qui est
censé émettre des scénarios pour ou des
prospectives sur le fait que si la
Russie nous coupe les les vivres, les
engrais, si la Chine nous dit "Bon alors
maintenant ton slip à 2 € c'est 15
balles, qu'est-ce qui se passe pour
l'instant ?" Déjà sur la dépendance, la
dépendance à la Russie, elle a été
singulièrement réduite. Il faut poser la
question aux Allemands. Ça leur pose un
peu plus de problèmes qu'à nous déjà.
Bon donc pose déjà la question des
Allemands pour le gaz et pour le gaz et
pour le pétrole ça pose un peu moins de
problème. L'énergie nucléaire attends
attends attends parce que prospectiviste
quand tu as vu tu parlesie nucléaire en
temps prospectiviste quand tu as vu
Emmanuel Macron fermer faitim tu t'es
dit oh ce mec va nous sauver Bibi Fock
c'est un grand un grand un grand chakra
de la prospective ou c'est simplement
quelqu'un qui fait la subordination
titre personnel je crois à la filière
nucléaire et je pense que ça a toujours
été une vision de courte vue que de
vouloir supprimer le nucléaire cela dit
je crois pas que ce soit la vision du
président Mais c'est pas mon sujet.
Voilà. Euh ça a peut-être été la vision
d'un certain nombre de de groupes écol
un moment où il fallait et qui commence
d'ailleurs à en revenir soit dit en
passant. Mais la filière nucléaire, il y
a pas de sujet là-dessus.
Quand tu as vu ça, tu t'es dit quoi ? La
la mais la filière nucléaire, c'est une
filière c'est une filière j'allais dire
la filière nucléaire, c'est ce qui fait
que c'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
l'Allemagne peut nous envier peut nous
envier ce choix stratégique sur le plan
énergétique. Donc ça il y a pas de sujet
sur la filière nucléaire. C'est
évidemment la bonne alternative. Ça veut
pas dire qu'il faut pas faire du
renouvelable mais pour faire du
renouvelable il faut aussi travailler
sur les batteries de haute capacité. Ça
c'est une vraie question. Ça c'est des
questions à court terme. Il faut combien
de temps pour construire un réacteur ?
Non, j'ai jamais travaillé sur le
nucléaire et surtout il faut il faut il
faut combien de kilos d'uranium quand tu
as un nouveau réacteur ? Ah mais la
question des minerais, elle est
importante. Bien sûr qu'il faut une
indépendance en matière
d'approvisionnement stratégique mais là
j'allais dire combien de mines à l'heure
actuelle
d'uranium dans le monde ? Il faut
combien de temps pour réouvrir une mine
? Il faut combien de temps pour ouvrir
une mine ? Mais est-ce qu'on souffre d'
Non mais attends là, je te pose la
question. Est-ce que la France, pour
prendre que la France he cherche du
boulot, est-ce que la France souffre
d'un problème d'approvisionnement
en uranium 238 ?
Bah non.
Non, mais c'est voilà, c'est quoi la
question en fait ? On n pas de problème
là-dessus. Le problème pour le coup pour
le coup, qu'est-ce qui te permet
d'affirmer ça pour le coup ? Qu'est-ce
qui te permet d'affirmer ça ? Pour le
coup, qu'est-ce qui te permet d'affirmer
le contraire ? Ah bah nous on a fait nos
recherches. On a x ministres qui sont
passés, on a x monsieurs qui travaillent
dans l'énergie atomique qu'on a
travaillé au corps. On a Est-ce que tu
as reçu le directeur de la filière
nucléaire de DF ? Je suis pas lequel ?
Celui qui peut répondre ou celui qui
peut pas répondre ? Bah le directeur du
parc nucléaire de DF. Non, on l'a pas
reçu en direct. Je te pose la question.
Qu'est-ce qui pass un ancien directeur
de cabinet ? Qu'est-ce qui te permet
d'affirmer que la France n'aura aucun
souci d'approvisionnement en uranium ?
Je ne sais pas si je peux pas affirmer
qu'il y aura aucun souci, mais je ne
peux pas euh infirmer euh je ne peux pas
te soutenir la thèse contraire. En tout
cas, c'est pas un problème. On va faire
une expérience de pensée toi et moi tout
de suite. Les approvisionnements
stratégiques, c'est stratégique mais en
terme d'anticipation
à court terme, évidemment que c'est des
choses qui doivent être sécurisées et je
donne un scénario mais sur le plan
prospectif. Attention, attends,
laisse-moi parler s'il te plaît. Là,
c'est un peu particulier. C'est la
dernière de la saison. Mais sur le plan
prospectif, sur le plan prospectif, tu
t'es mis en fait, je je te dis, tu t'es
mis en fait, tu t'es tu t'es mis dans
une seringue sur le plan prospectif. Tu
t'es dit de toute façon le carbone c'est
il y a que ça et s'il y a pas ça, c'est
le nucléaire et je suis d'accord avec
toi à court terme. Les énergies
renouvelables si on peut, mais là tu
t'es mis dans une seringue parce qu'en
fait sur le plan prospectif à 25 ans, je
vais te mettre à l'aise tout de suite. À
25 ans à 25 ans les problèmes dont on
parlera, ce sera plus les mêmes à 25
ans. Inchallah.
Ah mais j'en suis persuadé. D'accord.
C'est un peu comme le secret défense,
c'est 150 ans maintenant. Donc je te
pose la question. Il y a combien de
réacteur actif dans le monde à l'heure
actuelle ? Tu sais, tu sais pas. Ah bah
je sais pas. Combien il y a de réacteurs
qui sont éventuellement en projet de
construction dans le monde toute
puissance confondue.
Est-ce que tu sais ou tu sais pas ou
voulez-vous en venir ? Je te pr tu en
venir. Non. Ben non. Non c'est pas non.
Comment tu veux faire de comment tu veux
faire de la prospective ? Comment tu
veux avoir une clé de lecture si tu ne
connais pas les fondamentaux ? Mais déjà
c'est un sujet parmi d'autres. Attends
alors alors alors alors attends, on va
faire de la prospective sur ce sujet-là.
On se donne rendez-vous à un jour donné,
on va exploiter toute la batterie. On va
prendre les bons experts pour parler du
Moi je fais de la prospective. Je suis
pas spécialiste du nucléaire. Tu fais de
l'investissement en bourse Tu fais de
l'investissement en bourse ? Et la la
Non, je ne répondrai pas à cette
question
mais non, je n'en fais pas. Quelles sont
tes performances ? Non, mais j'en fais
pas. Je viens de te dire que j'en sais
pas. Et si tu en faisis, tu penses avoir
des bonnes performances ou pas ? Non,
mais la stockic n'est pas prévisible, on
le sait bien et je ne suis pas un robot
investissement hyperfréquence, donc
c'est pas le sujet. Encore une fois, si
on devait faire de la prospective sur la
question des approvisionnements
stratégiques et de la question nucléaire
en particulier, moi mon sujet et là où
ma compétence aurait du sens, c'est pas
savoir si je connais mieux le nucléaire
que les les pros du nucléaire, c'est pas
le sujet. Pour faire de la prospective
correctement, faut connaître un peu de
tout. C'est de la pluridisciplinarité.
Voilà. Et il faut être capable de
prendre les bonnes personnes. Attends,
attends, attends, attends, j'ai pas
fini. Tu veux qu'on le fasse et tu veux
pas qu'on le fasse ?
Et il faut prendre les bonnes personnes,
il faut poser les bonnes questions, il
faut avoir les bonnes méthodes, faut
dérouler et à la fin, au fil des
scénarios, bien sûr qu'on aura eu
connaissance de toutes les questions que
tu m'as posé, mais moi, c'est pas mon
sujet de savoir ça, exactement. Moi, je
suis là pour faire de la prospective. Je
suis pas là pour être expert du
nucléaire. un jour, je vais faire de la
prospective sur le nucléaire, un jour,
bon après, mes sujets, c'est davantage
des sujets, on va dire euh des sujets
liés euh euh au monde au monde
stratégique. Voilà. Alors, je ne dis pas
que évidemment l'énergie c'est
stratégique, mais euh c'est plus du
domaine économique comme tu disais.
Donc, voilà. C'est ce qui te manque ?
Qu'est-ce qui te manque ?
Euh pour faire de la prospective,
l'équipe je l'ai mais après de toute
façon, tu sais, c'est les gens du
voyage, la prospective hein. Tu changes
de sujet, tu changes de tu changes de
groupe d'experts, hein. Voilà. Tu as pas
l'impression que les prospectivistes
pour les affamés changes d'experts pour
les affamés, il faut qu'ils mangent leur
propre prospective.
C'est-à-dire, je suis pas sûr de bien
comprendre la question. Un jour, on a eu
une discussion avec un un grand
directeur de fond d'investissement et il
m'a toujours dit "Les mecs qui te filent
des conseils en investissement, faut que
tu leur demandes s'il s'appliquent les
mêmes conseils." Ah, doute, on ta
question de l'investissement en bourse
et cetera. Si tu es capable d'investir
en bourse et de faire du pognon, c'est
qu'à priori ce que tu prévois est bon.
Mais là encore hors sujet parce qu'en
fait euh là encore oui ça fait deux fois
que tu me provoques. Méfie-toi. Non non
mais hors sujet pourquoi ? Parce que
parce que c'est un M51 en plein direct.
Non, mais hors sujet, pourquoi ? Parce
que euh en finance, on sait bien que la
prévision euh à moyen long terme, elle
est pas vraiment possible. Voilà, hein.
Euh je crois qu'il y en a qui qui le
savent pour l'avoir payé euh euh pour
l'avoir payé de leur poche. Euh et à
très court terme, on laisse faire euh le
trading haute fréquence. Là
effectivement, il y a un moyen de
travailler sur les comment les les
variations stocastiques et voilà les
robots peuvent éventuellement enerrer
l'incertitude à très très court terme et
arriver à rentabiliser tout ça. Bon mais
on n'est pas dans la prospective là. Ça
n' rien à voir tu es plutôt défensif ou
offensif ? bah offensif mais dans le bon
sens du terme. C'est-à-dire que l'idée,
la prospective offensive, c'est préamp,
c'est-à-dire en deux mots envisager
le réel présent de différentes manières
de façon à se dire ça pourrait être
notre futur. Construire un futur. Et là,
il y a une part idéologique he dans la
prospective à un moment donné, il y a un
moment, je préfère ce futur que
celui-là. Voilà. Et après, je vais
l'imposer, mais je vais pas l'imposer en
disant en disant c'est mon futur qui
même me suivent. C'est tu l'imposes par
le travail d'influence. Et là, il y a
tout un tas d'outils dans le bon sens du
terme, l'influence pour faire en sorte
que ça gagne le cœur et les esprits.
Alors déjà, il y a le travail de
coproduction hein, voilà, il se fait
encore une fois au niveau des corps
intermédiaires, donc ça va de la
formation des jeunes au cadre dirigeant.
Et puis après, il se fait effectivement
par une forme bah par une forme de
j'allais dire de de prosélitisme. Le mot
est mal choisi en fait hein. Mais euh
mais euh oui, par une forme de euh
d'essémage. Après, il faut faut relier
ce qui est éparse, quoi, en quelque
sorte, hein. Voilà. C'est-à-dire chacun
sans pénètre et puis après on on fédère
on fédère les forces. Mais oui, là c'est
de l'offensif, c'est très offensif.
C'est pas en réaction hein. Si tu devais
noter l'anticipation et la prospective
européenne puisque tu as l'air de te
soustraire de la France. Et ben écoute,
je sais que je sais que le la Commission
européenne s'était saisie de l'intention
est déjà bonne de la Non mais oui, quand
on commence comme ça, c'est mal parti.
Bon euh c'était saisi de de la
prospective stratégique en 2020 avec un
commissaire au nom, pardon pour lui
imprononçable et donc je ne polonais je
crois de de de
nationalité euh si je ne m'abuse et et
qui euh voilà qui est en charge de la
prospective et il y a un rapport de
prospective stratégique qui sort chaque
année. Voilà. Bon euh c'est de la
prospective institutionnelle donc c'est
pas facile. La prospective
institutionnelle c'est difficile
d'accoucher d'autre chose que de l'
tiède. Ça voilà ça le mérite d'exister.
Il y a une prise de conscience. On
commence pas en étant directement 5e.
Voilà, il faut passer la première, la
deè la 3è. Euh les autres sont déjà au
fond de rupteur de 4e.
C'est possible. Voilà. Mais il y avait
déjà cette prise de donc c'est bien le
j' le sacle pour reprendre ce mot existe
euh le véhicule existe, l'écosystème
existe. Bon bah après faut renouveler
euh faut renouveler les méthodes. On
renouvellera j'en profite pour tes un
peu. Euh on renouvellera on proposera un
renouvellement des méthodes concrets
présenté exemplifié en septembre en
décembre et on fera un benchmarking
européen au mois de mars. Quel ÉPAD ça ?
Euh je ne sais pas le la le nom ni la
couleur de l'ÉPAD mais ça viendra en son
temps et les gens trouveront l'endroit.
C'est pas le sujet. Quand ça va
ruisseler, quand ça ruisselle la
prospective de Sénacle. Tu peux
m'expliquer comment ça se fait que tu
sais on a des obus 155. Oui. Il faut du
coton dedans.
Du moins pas dedans mais il faut du
contant du coton pour faire la bour.
Non. Alors peut-être. Oui. J'avoue que
j'ai pas le voilà. Il faut il faut de la
poudre aussi pour mettre ça c'est sûr.
Oui. Ouis. Ça c'est sûr. Sû. Et puis il
faut peut-être du métal. Oui, encore des
approvisionnements stratégiques. Tu vas
me renouer là-dessus. Les minerais,
l'économie de guerre et comment ça se
fait qu'on arrive pas en produire ? Non,
non mais c'est comment ça se fait qu'on
Mais ta question est légitime hein.
Comment on s'est pas dit bah ah ben les
gars, on fait des obut 155 mais on n pas
de coton pour la bour. Il vient d'où le
coton ? Il vient de Chine le coton.
Et les Chinois s nous disent bon bah
écoute maintenant tu es bien gentil, tu
bouges plus. Mais tu sais là, j'ai j'ai
une réponse, c'est pas l'idée tac au tac
avoir la réponse. J'ai une une réponse à
laquelle bah voilà. Bon, c'est c'est
l'idée c'est pas d'être dans l'ajoute
verbal, c'est vraiment de te dire la
façon dont je pense les choses. C'est
qu'à un moment on peut pas allouer plus
de moyens à un sujet que la population
n'est prête à le faire. Or, je reviens à
mes 30 ans de dividende la paix. Ben
oui, mais à un moment c'est ça si tu
veux. On est quand même dans une
démocratie et l'Europe est une
démocratie elle toute seule hein. C'est
ça, c'est sa valeur suprême, hein. C'est
érigé en valeur suprême hein, uni dans
la diversité. Voilà. Bon et donc un
moment si tu veux si les populations
ne sont pas pétr l'esprit de défense à
tort ou à raison et longtemps elles ont
eu raison de ne pas le l'être hein.
Peut-être qu'and voilà autour des années
2000 elles avaient raison de pas le on
était dans les opérations de maintien de
la paix he ça porte bien d'ailleurs son
nom. ça euphémise la guerre alors que il
y a c'est quand même un bain de sang et
de l'acier hein malgré tout. Euh bon
donc euh on était là-dedans et donc les
populations était certainement pas prête
à voir 5 % du PIB. Je dis ça aujourd'hui
parce que comme tu le sais c'est le
sommet de l'OTAN euh et que c'est 5 % du
PIB 3,5 + 1,5. Bon bah 3,5 % du PIB
c'est la course vers laquelle les pays
européens, la France et d'autres
s'inscrivent. Voilà, c'est jamais que ce
qu'on avait à peu de choses près dans
les années 90, c'est-à-dire avant la fin
de la guerre froide, avant les 30 ans de
dividendes de la paix dont je parle. Euh
et ça ça posait de problème à personne.
Les armées étaient évidemment moins
perfectionnées, mais en terme de volume,
elles ont elles avaient pardon le volume
que l'on va que le les armées que le
monde de la défense va chercher à va
chercher à reconstruire. 90, tu avais 20
ans, c'est ça ? en 90. Non, j'étais plus
jeune que ça. Euh, j'avais pardon euh 13
ans. Pardon ? 13 ans. Tu te rappelles
pas du prix du litre de gasel en franc ?
Euh
toc toc toc. Vu nez comme ça, ça c'était
pas 5 ou 6 francs ? un truc comme ça
truc dans ce goût là la baguette
comptait la baguette coûtait de 2 francs
10 de mémoire un truc comme ça les prix
en voilà tu parles de sacle de
commission censé faire de la prospective
européenne ça nous intéresse pas si si
alors européenne j'avais pas eu le temps
de finir mais juste j'en profite. Là, il
y aura un benchmark euh bah un
comparatif entre les différentes
méthodes, ce qui peut se faire au plan
européen un jour en France autour du
mois de mars. Voilà. Et celui qui perd
et qui est moins efficace, il finit quoi
? Au trou, il fait 500 pompes, on lui
diminue son salaire par les de tiers.
Comment ça se passe ? Non, on alors là,
tu vas me dire "Voilà, ça y est, enlève
les lunettes roses." On s'enrichit de la
différence. C'estàd que personne va
perdre. Mais non, mais personne va
perdre. En fait, on essaie de construire
quelque chose. Donc c'est pas l'idée de
dire "Ah bah tiens, lui c'est bien ce
qu'il fait, l'autre c'est nul." En fait,
c'est forcément pas nul parce qu'en fait
euh c'est quelque chose qui atteste d'un
état d'esprit euh d'une institution d'un
sur le moment et c'est à prendre tel
quel et c'est quelque chose qui autour
duquel il faut construire. En fait, il
faut une démarche dans le bon sens du
terme et Dieu sait que j'ai erreur des
trucs bien pensants. C'est une démarche
positive, c'est-à-dire qu'on amène, on
construit et on fait avec les choses
telles qu'elles sont. Et on va essayer
de de bah de s'enrichir de ce que
proposent les autres et d'entrer de
plein pied dans la prospective
stratégique. On va ouvrir une parenthèse
parce qu'il y a celui qui avait commencé
à être méchant avec toi. Non, non, mais
là là à mon avis, il est gentil.
Maintenant,
il te pose une question. Alors oui,
pourquoi ou comment fait-il pour être
aussi serein en ayant autant
d'informations et de prospectives ?
Alors que les prospectivistes, alors ça
je sais pas d'où tient d'où il tient son
information alors que tous les
prospectivistes
sont sous antidépresseurs. Oui, mais
alors Ah oui, ça c'est hyper important.
Alors l'idée, je considère la question
n'est pas de remettre en question mais
tous les prospectivistes,
c'est qui ? Parce que des
prospectivistes, parle du chinois, du
russe, de l'américain, il y en a mais
des prospectivistes, ne serait-ce qu'en
France, il y en a une quantité mais
incroyable en fait de gens qui font de
la résultat, ils sont où ? Mais qu' des
résultats encore une fois les résultats
c'est quoi ? Si tu pars du principe,
protéger le PIB français. Oui, mais tous
ne travaillent pas à faire de la
prospective pour protéger le PIB
français. celui qui est prospectiviste
chez Axa, ça se passe bien pour lui
parce que là typiquement le prix le prix
du kilo le prix du kilo assuré sur les
navires qui passent dans des trormous,
il a doublé. Donc alors c'est pas de la
prospective donc je suis sur un terrain
sur lequel tu étais avant et je suis en
train de me tirer une balle dans le
pied. Bon mais honnêtement
façon de te rassurer non mais
honnêtement c'est vrai que voilà pour
celui qui va faire de l'anticipation et
de la prospective à court terme en gros
de la prévision qui n'est pas de la
prospective là ça se passe bien pour
lui. Voilà. Bon euh maintenant euh il y
a différents domaines. Donc c'est quoi
tous les prospectus ? Tu suis tu suis en
tant que prospectiviste, est-ce que tu
suis par exemple le Baltique l'ARPEX ?
Le Baltic Dry index ou l'ARPEX ? Je je
non je suis pas spécialement euh voilà,
je regarde l'indice d'incertitude par
exemple du FMI. Ça ça m'intéresse parce
que du FMI Oui. qui qui quantifie
l'incertitude. Ça ça en France. Ça ça ça
m'intéresse. Pourquoi ? parce que le
cœur de la méthode que je propose vise
justement comme je te disais non pas à
exploser l'incertitude mais à
l'exploiter et donc arriver à objectiver
ce que représente l'incertitude c'est
intéressant et d'ailleurs on voit que le
profil de l'incertitude alors a augmenté
l'incertitude augmente. Ce qui est
intéressant c'est pas tellement qu'elle
augmente en fait c'est que le spectre
donc sur ce soit étalé. C'estàd qu'avant
on était sur une goienne où il y avait
des éléments très incertains et puis il
y avait des choses qui étaient quand
même tendantielles, assez bien assez
bien enraciné, assez bien convenu où à
l'horizon de 10 ans, on pouvait euh
prolonger les courbes pour faire simple.
Et puis là, en fait, le truc s'aplatit,
le spectre s'aplatit si bien qu'en fait
bah tout est un peu
du registre de la rupture. Donc si tout
est rupture, plus rien ne l'est. Mais ça
veut dire que les tendances euh il y en
a plus vraiment. On peut plus vraiment.
Alors, sauf il y a des choses qui sont
quand même bien établies, hein. Quelle
était la question que je t'ai posé sur
deux indexes sur deux
euh sur tous les prospectivistes ont le
moral dans les chaussettes. Euh pourquoi
ça t'inquiète pas ? Déjà, bon, je ne
suis pas sûr que tous les prospectifs et
le moral dans les chaussettes. Et en
l'occurrence, moi ça m'inquiète pas.
Pourquoi ? parce que euh
avec ma méthode, je je me dis voilà, je
suis passionné par ce que je fais et
j'allais dire euh
traçant mon sillon, il y a moi et les
petits oiseaux, tu vois. C'est-à-dire
que et les vieux, l'idée c'est de me
dire voilà, je développe ce truc et j'y
crois et ça apportera quelque chose. Ce
sera sûrement pas suffisant. Petits
oiseaux, tu les choisis comment pour
qu'il te fassent remonter de
l'information ? Non, mais quand je dis
les petits oiseaux, c'est pour dire que
euh je ne j'essaie de pas trop me
laisser embarrasser par le bruit
environnant, euh
me laisser perturber par euh les mauvais
coucheurs, me laisser perturber par le
mearassement bien, me laisser tout ça je
pousse, tu vois. J'ai un côté un peu
diogène là, tu vois. Comment ? Bah
comment justement en m'adonnant à à ce
travail, en le développant. Diogène,
c'est pas un syndrome où tu accumules
tout ? Non, Diogène, tu sais, c'était un
sceptique qui était dans son tonneau et
et qui voulait pas qu'on lui cache son
soleil. Voilà. Et donc et donc je ne
veux pas qu'on me gâche mon soleil. Et
mon soleil, c'est de développer cette
méthode et d'essayer d'essimer. Et
voilà. Et après, j'allais dire soyons
humble.
Moi, j'ai l'âge que j'ai. Euh une fois
que j'aurais poussé ça euh jusqu'au
bout, euh est-ce que j'aurais encore de
l'énergie pour me lancer dans un
vraiment une un grand projet de cette
envergure-là ? C'est pas certain. Donc
euh ça c'est je dire c'est vraiment la
euh Ouais. Ouais. Voilà. C'est vraiment
ce que je vais pousser de mil feu. Et
puis Aen que pourra
bien tu me donnes une très bonne
transition.
À quoi ça sert d'être un bon
prospectiviste, un bon analyste ?
Quand on voit l'état du pays, comment il
est gouverné et l'inertie, là on voit
beaucoup de prospectivistes,
d'analystes, des bons qui ont eu
énormément de trophées dans le passé,
qui se sont qui ont été absus par
l'histoire. Ils se disent "Maintenant,
mais à quoi ça sert de rester dans ce
[__] de pays ? On est fiscalisé euh
ras la gorge, on est dans une
insécurité. Nos gamins, ils peuvent pas
se balader à la fête de la musique sans
se faire suriner. piquer à la seringue,
se faire taper dessus. Euh euh les
grandes tendances étaient marquées en
long, en large travers. Ils ont fermé
les yeux, ils ont fait de la suordnation
de vote.
Quel message tu pourrais dire à un bon
analyste, un bon prospectiviste qui a
déjà été absus par l'histoire pour
éviter qu'il se barre à l'étranger,
ouvrir un bar en Thaïlande ou à Angia ?
J'ai pas exactement le même ressenti que
toi. Euh c'est pas un ressenti qui est
Non, mais là, tu t'adresses à quelqu'un
qui a fait ses preuves, si nous on en
croise, on en connaît qui ont été bons,
vraiment très bon, qui ont d'ailleurs
fait du fric avec ça. Et là, ils se
disent "La France est mort, c'est mort.
Le poisson pourrit toujours par la tête.
Nos institutions
sont grab à terires,
ils sont pas agiles. À supposer que tu
es raison et que ton raison. Je
t'adresses à quelqu'un qui a fait ses
preuves et qui a été absus par quoi pour
éviter qu'il se barre du pays parce
queil pense que la France est un pays de
grabataire qui n'est plus agile,
gangrainé par une classe politique qui
est en querelle de chapelle, incapable
de trouver un consensus, incapable de
faire un plan à 30 ans en intrigue tous
les jours. Et je te parle même pas du
fait qu'on soit vérolé, infiltré
et je t'en passe des meilleurs.
Qu'est-ce que tu dis à un jeune analyste
un bon pour qu'il reste au pays ?
Alors à supposer, permets-moi de mettre
non mais oui mais c'est important quand
même. Je peux pas apprendre pour argent
comproprier
le propos évoque la galère là-dessus.
Donc non à supposer que tu es raison
déjà. Est-ce que ça gagne pas le cas
échéant d'autres pays et pas uniquement
la France et l'Europe plus généralement
et peut-être le monde occidental encore
plus généralement. la question de la
existentielle de l'Occident se pose.
Voilà. Donc déjà
circonscrire le problème, le cas échéant
à la France, c'est déjà une question
dans la question. Et à supposer qu'on
parte de ce de ce de ce postulat là et
qu'on fasse une expérience de pensée,
euh qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire pour
j'allais dire aller de l'avant ? Bah en
fait, c'est très simple, c'est
travaillons sur les jeunes. Moi, j'ai si
j'avais un truc à dire et que la caméra
se coupe là, c'est
que ceux qui sont en mesure de décider
de ça fassent en sorte que nos jeunes le
plus tôt possible et dans tous les
métiers
soient prospectivistes. C'est-à-dire
qu'en fait le problème c'est qu'il y a
des prospectivistes. Tout le monde
devrait être pétri de l'esprit de
défense, citoyen en armes, nation en
armes. Avec les armes, elles peuvent
avoir plusieurs forme, y compris
intellectuel, y compris spirituel, y
compris y compris citoyenne. Voilà. Et
tout le monde doit être un peu
prospectiviste sans le savoir. Tout le
monde devrait être un peu monsieur
Jourdin sur le plan de la prospective.
Qu'on soit architecte, tu imagines un
peu l'architecte qui est pas un peu
prospectiviste quand il construit ça
dure un siècle. Or, quand on sait le
poids sur le social, sur le sociétal des
infrastructures,
la façon dont ça pétrit toute une
société, hein, qu'on construise
verticalement ou qu'on construise autre,
c'est c'est les architectes ont un rôle
social mais considérable. Bon, donc si
les architectes sont pas un peu
prospectivistes, ça pose un problème.
Les ingénieurs parlent même pas et
cetera et cetera et cetera. Donc s'il y
avait un truc, je dis euh pour être
opératif, c'est quoi ton truc ? Et ben
pour être opératif, c'est que euh ceux
qui peuvent décider fassent en sorte que
la prospective irrigue euh dès le début
les plus jeunes et que toutes les
formations, tous les métiers en soient
pénétrés. Première chose. Et deuxième
chose, à ton analyste, je lui dis bah
viens, on constitue une rende à la
française, j'expliquerai ce que ça peut
être et puis bah on est la matrice et on
sème et on forme des formateurs. Voilà.
Et puis un beau jour, au bout de 10 ans,
et ben euh ça aura gagné le pays et au
bout de 25, ça produira des résultats.
Voilà, c'est c'est quand même c'est pas
si mal comme proposition. On mange pas
les les pic par la racine.
Bah et oui, mais enfin bon euh si on
construit pas quelque chose, tu sais
quel je sais plus quel philosophe disait
que voilà bah c'était pas un philosophe,
c'était G, c'était un poète. C'est qui
disait en gros que nous sommes ici bas
pour donner du sens à ce qui est fini.
Voilà, c'est notre façon de prendre en
compte la finitude. En substance,
c'était ça. On est là pour donner du
sens. Donc euh voilà, je pense que à ton
analyste, à ton prospectiviste, plein de
désarrois. Si on lui disait "Tu vas
construire une matrice et euh former les
formateurs et esser et faire en sorte
que ce pays-là bah puisse avoir des
prospectivistes et ne puisse ne plus
avoir besoin de toi et de tes analyses
merdiques parce qu'au final c'est les
prospectivistes qui sont finalement un
peu défaillants sur cette affaire."
ceux qui interprètent la prospective.
Non, bah euh c'est ceux qui la font. Or
là, l'idée dans ce que je te propose,
même si on va pas dans le détail, c'est
quand même que ce soit coprit,
c'est-à-dire d'associer. Par tu parles
d'irriguer, de vasculariser. Oui. Tu
fais comment en fait
si tu vasises et que tu irrigues un
membre gangrainé ?
Ah, je suis pas sûr que tous les membres
soient gangrainés. C'est notre problème
entre toi et moi Sky, c'est qu'on n'est
pas toujours d'accord sur le postulat de
départ. Évidemment, si tu membres est
grand grainé, bon bah là il faut passer
un autre membre, tu l'oublies. Voilà, il
faut passer un autre membre. Tous les
membres sont pas gangrainés. Est-ce
qu'il faut le couper ? Ah oui, moi je
suis pas chirurgien moi. Est-ce qu'il
est-ce qu'il y a des chir Je suis pas
chirurgien ? C'est trop tard pour ça.
J'ai fait beaucoup d'études hein. Mais
ça, j'ai pas fait d'études de médecine
encore. Ça viendra peut-être un jour.
Bétaillère volante. Ça viendra peut-être
un jour. J'ai pas fait C'est quoi comme
bétaill que tu es qualifié ? Ah mais
c'était il y a longtemps ça. Les
internautes regarderont, ils trouveront
forcément, ils trouveront. Tu rendes
combien de vaches des pades là-dedans ?
Euh allez à l'époque ça devait être
[__] j'ai oublié mais allez entre 60
et 90, ça dépendait des configurations.
Oui. Alors après, il faut pas qu'il
fasse trop chaud hein, parce que s'il
faisait trop chaud, en mettait un peu
moins quand même. Question.
Quand tu te retrouves avec des secteurs
qui n'ont pas fait leur preuves, qui
sont payés, irrigués avec nos salaires,
nos labeurs d'argent public qui se sont
toujours plantés, tu les curtes, tu les
coupes, tu les amputes, tu fais quoi
avec ces gens-là ? Ce qui est bien,
c'est que tu as toujours le sens de la
mesure en fait. C'est c'est toujours un
plaisir. Il a une progressivité. Je t'ai
dit Kurte. Oui, je sais, j'ai bien noté
la gradation. Tu les amputes ? J'ai bien
après. Est-ce que tu veux que j'ampute
avant ou après l'articulation ? Non,
j'ai bien noté la gradation. Est-ce que
tu veux que j'ampute avant ou après
l'articulation ? Si tu veux, on peut tu
le préfères. Tu veux que j'essaie de le
garder ton genou ? Faut raisonner en
dehors de la boîte. Toi, tu te dis j'en
machin truc, tu pars du principe qu'en
fait il y a pas de renouvellement. Mais
il y a un tas de bestioles dans la
nature. Il y a Attends, attends,
attends, laisse-moi finir. Il y a un tas
de bestioles dans la nature. Tout se
régénère. Tu sais ce que c'est un tenia
où tout bah par exemple voilà les
tenignas de la prospective les tenignas
de la prospective les tenignas de
plateau télé
tu as pas l'impression qu'il nous
intoxique et qu'est-ce que tu appelles
alors précise qu'est-ce que tu appelles
un teignade de plateau télé j'ai pas dit
un tenia de plateau télé alors les
tenignad de plateau télé ceux qui sont
indéboulonnables et qui se sont toujours
plantés
la prospective elle se fait pas sur un
plateau de télé quand on est sur un
plateau de télé on est dans une autre
logique qui qui est celle de
l'information pour les journalistes et
puis celle de la communication. C'est
deux choses différentes, on est bien
d'accord. L'influence de l'influence, du
rayonnement, de l'influence, de la
communication, de la guerre hybride, de
de la allez de la guerre
informationnelle, voilà,
dont la guerre hybride se se nourrit.
Voilà, c'est une dimension importante
fondamentale même de de la guerre de la
guerre hybride, la guerre
informationnelle. Donc les journalistes
bah informent et je ne j'ai rien qui me
laisse à penser que leur déontologie
serait écorné parce que euh pour ceux
que j'ai pu rencontrer en tout cas euh
c'est des gens bien quoi. Enfin, je veux
dire, ils font leur leur boulot euh
comme euh comme euh beaucoup devraient
faire le leur euh donc ils le font ils
le font bien. Après, ceux qui viennent
communiquer, bah ils ont leur agenda.
Alors il le montrent ou ils le montrent
pas, ils ont leur agenda. Moi le mien
c'est que j'ai toujours une petite
pensée pour la prospective quand quand
il m'arrive ici et là d'être invité sur
un plateau. Préfè que tu me dises "J'ai
toujours une petite pensée pour la
France et le drapeau." Ça aurait quand
même de la classe. Oui mais ça c'est
j'allais dire c'est by design me
concernant. Bonne réponse. Voilà, on
passe un peu, bon maintenant qu'on a
fait les présentations, qu'on s'est mis
un petit peu en jambe. On passe à la
politique internationale. Jérôme,
je On l'avait déjà été un petit peu dans
la maison-y. Non, là c'était la petite
apéritif. D'accord. OK.
Là, on va rentrer dans le dur. Alors, on
va avoir l'écume des jours. Alors, si si
on passe à la politique internationale.
Bien. Comment tu juges la stratégie et
la prospective et les besoins et les
anticipations ? d'Israël.
Ah, intéressant, intéressante cette
question. Elles sont toutes
intéressantes mais euh
il y a déjà il faut qu'on s'accorde sur
la façon dont on pense qu'il voit les
choses et puis après on verra comment
les juge. Si toutefois on a à juger mais
déjà bah oui, il faut qu'on soit
d'accord déjà sur la façon dont il est
Je te mets dans le contexte je te mets
dans le contexte. Israël qui a été
peuplé avec des gens qui se sont fait
torturer, gazer, violer, dépossédés
où ils ont vu leurs enfants, leur
famille, ça se témoigne même dans
l'épigénétique.
Tu les mets
là-bas, ils sont quand même un peu
sensibles et ils font peut-être des
stratégies à court, moyen, long et très
long terme.
Ils sont entourés de pays pas vraiment
amicaux
et ils sont beaucoup. Je t'écoute.
La perception que j'en ai c'est que
c'est un pays, un peuple qui se pense
en guerre permanente et dont il est
difficile de savoir en fait la façon
dont ils veulent arriver à la paix. Hein
? Euh Socrate l'a dit, hein. Tout le
monde aspire au bonheur, hein. Tout ce
que l'on fait est dicté tendu par euh la
recherche du bonheur. Alors là, en
l'occurrence, est-ce qui c'est la paix
par la paix ou est-ce que c'est la paix
par la guerre permanente ? Il y a deux
possibilités de voir la survie aussi. Où
est-ce que c'est la sécurité ? Est-ce
que c'est la paix par la paix ? Est-ce
que c'est la paix par la guerre ? Est-ce
que c'est la sécurité par la guerre
permanente ? de ce que j'ai pu observer
et comprendre parce que c'est quand même
aller au Moyen-Orient compliqué avec les
idées simples. Voilà, on connait la
phrase, tout le monde l'aura reconnu
mais c'est quand même toujours un peu ça
quand même. Et quand tu as des analystes
qui connaissent bien le sujet régional,
tu vois qu'à la fin bah ils en
comprennent pas forcément plus que toi.
Il complexifient, compliquent, parfois
ils complexifient pas, ils compliquent
mais à la fin la conclusion est la même.
C'est que personne n'arrive vraiment à
se déterminer. Et donc ce que j'ai pu
m'en faire comme idée, c'est que c'est
plutôt la sécurité par la guerre. Et ça,
j'allais dire de façon presque
indépendante de la personne qui a à la
tête du gouvernement. Al c'est plus ou
moins fort là avec le le dirigeant
actuel c'est particulièrement fort et il
y a une évidence, c'est que c'est plutôt
effectivement la sécurité par la guerre.
Là aujourd'hui euh les Américains ont
réussi
un petit peu mais c'est une journée en
suspension dans laquelle on est hein.
Est-ce qu'ils arriveront véritablement à
faire en sorte que ce cesser le feu
tienne et que le leader le leader
israélien s' s'en contente ? C'est pas
certain parce qu'ils avaient
certainement autre chose en tête.
Peut-être un changement de régime,
peut-être faciliter ce changement de
régime. Alors le faciliter peut-être le
provoquer mais au-delà de la question
nucléaire. Ce qui est certain aussi,
c'est que cette question nucléaire fait
consensus euh en Israël. C'est un des un
des sujets sur lesquels tout euh le
peuple israélien s'accorde. Voilà, ils
sont pas tous d'accord sur la priorité
des otages à Gaza, même si euh euh
effectivement Netaniaou a été quand même
là, euh même si voilà, mais euh sur le
nucléaire, ils sont tous ils sont tous
Oui, ils sont tous ils sont attends, je
finis mon propos. Ils sont tous ils sont
tous d'accord sur le fait que bah voilà,
le nucléaire iranien c'est un problème
existentiel. Bon et euh le régime des
mol
sûrement peut-être sûrement peut-être
voilà donc tant qu'il y aura ce problème
existentiel bah il y a un besoin une
aspiration légitime à la sécurité et
cette sécurité euh ils ont décidé
qu'elle passait par la guerre et là elle
est mise entre parenthèses
momentanément. Est-ce que ça peut
conduire à la paix ? Ça, c'est très
difficile de le dire parce que ça dépend
de la volonté. Si la volonté c'est la
sécurité permanente par la guerre et la
campagne entre les guerres, c'est
quelque chose qui est qui est théorisé
hein, c'est campagne entre les guerres
pour Israël.
Et bien la réponse est dans la question
et donc ce sera la sécurité par la
guerre et ce sera toujours plus ou moins
la guerre. Voilà pour qui a la paix. Bah
les les tous les diplomates d'Europe,
j'allais dire du monde entier, pas
forcément mais d'Europe le disent. C'est
la solution à deux états. Mais ce
deuxième état, par voie de fête,
aujourd'hui, le territoire, on le
cherche, l'autorité politique, on la
cherche et la population palestinienne,
bah de plus en plus parce que elle est
quand même réduite à faire un
commentaire de plateau télé là. Euh non,
je suis en train de te dire que euh si
euh s'il doit y avoir la paix, ce sera
euh vraisemblablement la sécurité,
pardon, euh c'est mon 3è scénario, ce
sera vraisemblablement par une forme de
de de guerre permanente avec euh des
oscillations, une forme de guerre
permanente. Je ne crois pas, au vu de ce
qui se profile que une paix durable,
entérinée soit possible et en fait je ne
crois pas qu'elle soit souhaitée. Là,
c'est important ce que je te dis quand
même parce que sont les intér il y en a
des qui vont pas trouver ça bien que je
dise ça qui bah il y a plein de gens
pour qui dire que Israël ne souhaite pas
forcément la paix, qu'elle souhaite la
sécurité par la guerre c'est quelque
chose c'est quelque chose d'important
quand même. Enfin d'important, je sais
pas si c'est important mais enfin c'est
c'est c'est une vision, c'est une
analyse qui n'engage que moi
naturellement.
Quels sont les intérêts des États-Unis
dans la région à court, moyen et long
terme ? On sait quels sont les intérêts
des États-Unis dans la région. On sait
qu'il y a des intérêt énergétique de
moins en moins puisque les États-Unis
sont quand même autonomes sur le plan du
pétrole. Donc ça c'est quand même un
point important, même si néanmoins il y
a quand même il reste quand même un
intérêt dans la région. Il y a un besoin
de de peser naturellement. Il y a euh
toutes les toutes les bases, il y a de
nombreuses bases en Irak, en Syrie, euh
euh au Qatar, à Louide par exemple,
voilà, la 5e flotte à Baragne. Bon bref,
il y a les intérêts stratégiques,
militaires, énergétiques dans une
moindre mesure. Les États-Unis, il y a
pas une région du monde où ils n'ont pas
d'intérêt en fait hein. Je sais pas si
ça répond à la question. Quelle était la
finalité de la question autre autre que
la question de cours moy est-ce que
est-ce qu'à moyen terme, il va y avoir
une compétition dans la région entre
Israël et les États-Unis ?
Pour le coup, je vois pas comment on
peut s'installer une compétition entre
les deux parce que Israël est un éémon
dans la région. Ça c'est aussi une
rupture et je crois qu'on peut le dire
aujourd'hui. Israël est un égémon dans
la région, ce qui a pas toujours été le
cas. Euh la Syrie off, euh Iran off, euh
l'Arabie Saoudite quand même moins
importante. Bon bon, donc c'est un
égmond de la région, ça c'est clair.
On voit bien que
Israël se sait assurer du soutien des
États-Unis et ça lui permet d'aller de
savoir jusqu'où elle peut aller trop
loin mais que quand même avec l'aide des
Américains sur les frappes de Fordaux,
elle s'est rangée à la demande de cesser
le feu du président Trump. C'est enensus
en pointill, on va voir si c'est
maintenu, mais on voit bien que les
États-Unis ont quand même et pour
longtemps me semble-t-il, je veux pas
dire que ta question n'a pas de sens
hein, je la prends, je la traite hein,
mais j'ai quand même l'impression quand
même que les États-Unis resteront
malgré tout largement un rapport de
force, de puissance, d'influence
supérieure à Israël dans la région.
Voilà. Même si même si je tempère Israël
a évidemment une puissance d'influence
très importante aux États-Unis que l'on
connaît et qui fait qu'il y a aussi ce
lien indéfectible. Le lobby arabe aux
États-Unis est aussi très puissant mais
enfin il produit quand même pas les
mêmes effets. Question : qu'est-ce qui
se passe si les États-Unis dans un une
expérience de pensée h tombent dans le
piège iranien à être obligé de déployer
des hommes
sur place ?
Alors, on n'est jamais obligé d'abord.
Est-ce qu'ils sont courbes ? Est-ce que
c'est un nouveau Vietnam ? Est-ce
qu'ensuite leur opinion domestique va
réclamer le retour des boys à la maison
? Est-ce que ça va provoquer un
affaiblissement
de de des États-Unis ? Alors, on est on
n'est jamais obligé d'envoyer
des troupes et des hommes des boots on
the ground. On n'est jamais obligé de le
faire ça. Voilà pour le coup le changer
de régime attends oui mais justement euh
pour le coup le président Trump a été
élu sur le fait qu'il ne s'engagerait
pas et qu'il serait plutôt l'homme qui
termine les guerres plutôt qu'il ne les
commence et il a pris un grand soin à
circonscrire dans sa communication les
l'opération aérienne d'envergure et
soi-dite en passant euh sur le plan
purement opérationnel et technique tout
à fait remarquable. et je referme la
parenthèse ou la note de bas de page.
Voilà, il a pris soin de de bien dire
qu'en fait il n'était pas en guerre
contre les Iran ni même contre les MOLA
que c'était une opération circonscrite
qui avait vocation voilà à détruire, il
a dit dévaster voilà et qu'il avait
complètement soi-disant oblitéré. C'est
sûrement pas le cas d'ailleurs, mais on
aura le battle damage assessment sous
peu. C'est en cours au Pentagone. Malgré
les déclarations du Pentagone, il a dit
que tout avait été oblitéré, dévasté et
que il y avait plus rien. Bon voilà.
Mais il a tenu à circonscrire. Donc il
est pas en guerre. Il est plutôt c'est
plutôt lui qui freine qui freine Israël
sur cette affaire très clairement. Et il
a été entraîné par Israël, ça c'est
certain. Il a été obligé de finir le
boulot commencé par Israël qu'elle ne
pouvait pas finir faute de détenir les
capacités nécessaires pour frapper
Fordaux, Nathan de Sisparan et en
particulier Fordau. Voilà. Donc la
question d'être emmené sur le sol, euh
c'est une question euh qui est au 2e
voire au 3e degré parce qu'il y a déjà
beaucoup beaucoup d'étapes à franchir
avant que d'en être là. Après, sur la
question du changement de régime, encore
une fois, il ne souhaite pas pour
l'instant changer de régime. S'il devait
le faire, euh vraisemblablement
aujourd'hui, ce serait entraîné par
Israël. Et ça ne semble pas être le cas.
Ce qui est certain, c'est que les
frappes encore hier d'Israël visaient
euh des piliers du régime, la direction
du renseignement, euh le corps des
gardiens de la révolution responsable de
la répression des soulèvements internes
euh et d'autres bref, une porte de
prison aussi et toute la et tout. Ça
ressemblait un peu à l'Irak quand ils
ont fait péter les portes de prison, non
? Oui, je bon, j'ai pas fait le
parallèle, mais euh ce qui est certain,
c'est que on voit bien qu'ils essayent
de d'affaiblir tous les piliers du
régime de sorte à ce que euh la comment
le soulèvement populaire puisse trouver
sa place. C'est ça qu'il souhaiterait
idéalement et peut-être que Trump peut
le souhaite aussi, mais les Israéliens
s'en sont à peine cachés. Ils ont invité
au début de leur frappe le peuple
iranien à se soulever. Ils ont redit
leur proximité et leur leur comment leur
leur amitié au peuple iranien. Ils ne se
sont déclaré hostile commeola. Donc si
le peuple iranien à 82 % je crois euh
contre le régime des Molas par qu la
source. Alors la source c'est un
islamologue qui dont j'ai le nom que je
mais je vais pas le je veux pas donner
son nom là mais vous pouvez retrouver la
source. Voilà. Euh
donc, mais c'est
c'est cacher, si je puis dire, c'est
plus de 80 % de de contestation, mais
que cette contestation se euh
convertisse en une force agrégée et de
de de force politique qui pourrait
éventuellement euh constituer une
alternative solide sans qu'il y ait une
guerre civile après la fin du régime des
Molas, ça c'est pas du tout sûr. Et donc
l'idée d'Israël, telle qu'on peut la
lire, moi je livre la façon telle que je
l'ai lis. J'ai pas dit que c'était ça et
puis personne n'est venu m'appeler pour
me dire que c'était comme ça. Mais tel
qu'on peut le lire, c'est vraisemblement
faire en sorte que le régime ait toutes
toutes les toutes les capacités, je puis
dire, ou les incapacités à rester qui
puissent s'effondrer de lui-même si
toutefois la contestation naturelle
pouvait marcher. il y a quand même
quelque chose qui est important et là
aussi j'auraai pas de source mais c'est
des analyses partagées avec avec
d'autres analystes sur le sujet et on
est assez d'accord pour dire que là
aussi j'en reviens ce que je te disais
la vertu épistémologique de l'histoire
on n'y croit pas trop c'est-à-dire dire
bah oui mais vous avez bien vu que ça
marche pas en Libye ça marche pas en
Syrie. le régime change euh en ça marche
pas pardon en Irak, ça marche pas en
Libye, ça a plutôt marché en Syrie et on
a rien fait et en Afghanistan ça n'a pas
marché non plus et cetera. Bon en Syrie,
ça a marché ? Bah pour le coup on est
responsable de rien. Israël a un petit
peu aidé. On sait pas si ça va marcher,
mais en tout cas le leader a quand même
été reçu en France et dans d'autres
pays. Libye ça a marché ? Ah non, Libye
ça a foiré bien sûr tout le monde le
sait et ça il y a plus personne pour
dire que c'est une réussite. Ce qui veut
pas dire que l'opération pour le coup
sur le plan purement, j'allais dire
technique et opérationnel euh
elle était plutôt bien menée. Ça non
mais sur le plan mais attention mais il
faut différencier deux choses. Faut
différencier deux choses. L'outil
militaire Non mais tu t'es esclaves mais
l'outil militaire il a pas vocation à
faire la paix. Il a pas vocation à
produire des solutions politiques. Non
mais l' militaire mais quand c'est bien
mené. Non non mais attends pardon quand
c'est Non non mais attends je finis
parce que je peux pas le falom. C'est ce
que c'est un fake calom. Oui non. Oui
d'accord. Oui un truc bouché dans le
voilà. OK. Tu préfères que je te le
sorte au pied de biche ni l'un ni
l'autre ou que je te le sorte avec deux
doigts. Ni l'un ni l'autre. Ce que je
suis en train de te dire c'est l'outil
tu préfères lequel ? Non mais ce que je
suis en train de te dire c'est que
l'outil militaire c'est Aaron qui disait
ça. Ça suffit pas. Raymond Aron. Oui
Raymond Aron
sans l'outil militaire tu fais rien mais
avec tu peux pas tout. En substance
c'est ce qu'il disait. Bon ben voilà une
fois que tu as dit ça et là ça a pas
changé. Avec tu peux pas tout. Donc tu
peux très bien mener une opération
militaire. Et celle qui avait été menée
par l'OTAN sur la Libye du point de vue
aérien du point de vue de l'intégration
des effets. J'allais dire pour les les
hommes de l'art ce ce qu'on peut
observer. Voilà. Euh le job était
parfait. Euh c'est pas le sujet. Le
sujet il est pas là. Le sujet il est pas
là. Il est la façon job était parfait.
C'est pas là qui est le sujet. Le sujet
il est sur la finalité politique. Le le
job était parfait à court, moyen ou long
terme. Il est forcément à cour, il est
sur l'effet produit sur le plan
cinétique, sur le plan militaire. L'été
finale.
L'état final recherché c'est le
politique qui se débrouille avec ça.
C'est au politique dire ce qu'il veut.
C'est pas au militaire le militaire
quand on lui dit "Vas-y Coco, fais ça du
mieux que tu peux,
il y va." Non. Alors là, tu reprends.
C'était le général McCrystal qui s'est
fait virer d'ailleurs. Celui qui s'était
avec sa petite copine qui était bizarre.
Oui. Alors ça je sais pas mais je
connais pas les histoires comme ça mais
euh voilà, c'était sur l'Afghanistan.
Général Macrystal qui avait précédé si
je dis pas de bêtises au général
Petraus. Bon et en gros, il disait voilà
quand je m'adresse à l'autorité
politique,
il leur demande ce qu'ils veulent faire,
quel est l'état final recherché, à quoi
ils veulent parvenir et après lui il
propose des effets pour arriver à ça.
Des effets c'estd qu'il arrive pas en
disant j'ai tant d'hommes, tant d'avion,
tant de bateaux. Il propose des effets
puis après il fait sa sauce en agrégeant
en faisant combien de points de suture ?
en faisant voilà, il fait euh ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui du multimilieu,
multichamp, c'est-à-dire qu'il fait du
terre herm cyberespace informationnel,
il fait son truc et ça produit l'effet.
Oui. Non mais c'est ça à un moment
donné, c'est ça la science militaire. Il
produit des effets. Voilà. Et ça marche.
Et ça marche. Mais après le relais, il
est diplomatique, il est économique, il
est et cetera politique pour une
solution politique. Ce qui est souvent
reproché à Benamin Nietaniaahu en
particulier puisque c'est lui qui a la
tête du régime, c'est on dit bah Israël
sur le plan militaire impeccable. C'est
comme dans les bouquins, c'est une leçon
pour des officiers de l'école de guerre
à chaque fois en terme d'opération
aérienne, c'est de l'or fèverrerie. Mais
quel est votre objectif politique ?
Qu'est-ce que vous cherchez à faire ? La
paix ou la sécurité par la guerre
permanente ? Moi, c'est je pense que
c'est la sécurité par la guerre
permanente avec peut-être des trêves et
cetera, mais c'est toujours la guerre
permanente pour la sécurité. Tu sais ce
que c'est l'arithmétique de la rébellion
? Oui. Oui. Ça c'est le Hamas. Bah c'est
que quand Bah oui mais enfin alors je
finis mon propos ou je réponds à une
question de cours. Bon alors l'abbétique
de la la rébellion c'est typiquement bah
les détracteurs de l'opération euh
l'opération visant les membres du Hamas
sur Gaza disent voilà si vous abattez un
membre du Hamas faites quelques dommages
collatéraux
que tous les occidentaux ont fait un
jour ou l'autre hein dans leur frappe et
dans leur lutte contre le terrorisme.
Après la question de la proportion la
question de bon tout ça est à discuter.
Ça pose des problèmes effectivement en
terme de d'éthique, c'est un autre
sujet. Voilà. Mais le fait est que
forcément si vous faites des dommages
collatéraux et que vous touchez le gamin
d'à côté et cetera et pas celui qui est
encore d'à côté, bah celui qui est
encore à côté qui a pas été touché lui
développe une haine farouche et donc tu
as neutralisé un terroriste du Havas
peut-être deux et finalement derrière il
est pétri d'une idée de revanche et il
va t'en multiplier 10, il va en faire 15
et donc tu arrêtes et ça repousse comme
si comme si plus que ce qui se serait
produit si tu n'avais pas agi. C'est ça
la logique arithmétique, c'est qu'en
gros, tu génères un mal supérieur à
celui euh celui auquel tu prétends
t'opposer et celui que tu prétends
neutraliser. Voilà, un peu comme quand
on appuie sur un bouton, bon bah à la
fin essai mais il y a plein de
furoncles. Alors que si on l'avait
laissé tranquille, peut-être qu'il
aurait fini par mourir de lui-même. Mais
c'est pas sûr. Je pense que c'est ça
marche pas pour le terrorisme. Voilà,
c'est ça la logique arithmétique. Et
cette logique là, je peux pas dire en
tant que prospectiviste, il faut
regarder la réalité sous la réalité
présente sous toutes ses formes, sous
différentes facettes et dire "Ah non,
mais ça c'est pas vrai cette logique
là." Bien sûr qu'elle est vraie. Bien
sûr qu'elle est vraie, mais après ça
confine à l'inaction. Si si tu veux
faire que des choses pures, des choses
dont la logique est jamais, j'allais
dire frelatée, n'est jamais écorné,
c'est Quant. Mais Kant, il a les mains
pures mais il a pas de bras, ça on le
sait. Donc un moment, il y a forcément
que des compromis. Il y a des compromis,
c'est on agit ou on agit pas. Si on
décide d'agir, c'est le politique, bah
c'est celui qui fixe le but de l'action.
Voilà. Et le militaire lui après, bah le
militaire il propose des effets pour
arriver à l'état final recherché. Donc
il n'est qu'une composante. On a depuis
longtemps théorisé l'approche globale.
Ça c'était général Petraus hein en
Afghanistan. L'approche globale c'était
il faut effectivement euh la défense, il
faut faire l'économie la la bah c'est ça
voilà exactement hein avec puisque tu me
parles de la technique de l'anaconda et
pour pas être trop pour notre
téléspectateur c'était le fameux plat de
nouille qui avait été présenté c'était
antérieur à Petraus d'ailleurs. fameux
plat de nouille, on montrait les
imbrications de toutes les ethnies, de
toutes les de toutes les les seigneurs
de guerre, de tout en bref toute la
topographie, j'allais dire humaine,
l'écosystème humain de l'Afghanistan. Et
en gros, la conclusion du briefing,
c'est si vous avez compris le plan de
nouille et vous allez le résoudre, vous
aurez gagné la guerre. Bon, évidemment,
c'était impossible. Et donc, il y avait
c technique de l'anaconda pour insérer
cette complexité et faire en sorte de
traiter les problèmes globalement,
c'est-à-dire sur le plan militaire, sur
le plan sécuritaire, sur le plan
économique, sur le plan de l'état de
droit, sur le plan du développement, sur
le plan de l'éducation, les fameuses
écoles avec ce qui avait c'était très
très à la mode à cette époque-là, les
opérations simiques, c'est-à-dire civilo
militaire, voilà, avec une volonté. Et
puis quand on entendait les gens
parlaient des sim, il disaient "Non mais
moi je suis pas travaille pas dans
l'humanitaire, je fais de l'influence,
je suis là pour la la bataille du cœur
et des esprit hein, Joseph Naï et cetera
le bon bref donc c'était ça et ça a du
sens. Ça a du sens parce que ça le
mérite de montrer que le militaire ne
peut pas tout mais sans lui tu peux
rien. Donc si on en revient à un autre
sujet qui est Trump versus Israël euh
lequel s'impose, lequel va se laisser
entraîner euh dans éventuellement lequel
va faire un crochepat, lequel va faire
un crochepat, on n'est pas obligé
d'aller au sol. Et il est possible
que il est possible que qu'en qu'en Iran
ce soit la première révolution de
couleur qui marche. Et ça c'est pas moi
qui le dit. On en dit une idée que j'ai
mais en tant que prospectiviste mais je
me dis je ne crois pas aux vertus aux
vertus épistémologiques de l'histoire.
Je me méfie
systématiquement des parallèles
historiques. C'est jamais les bons. Ça
peut pas se reproduire dans les mêmes
dans les mêmes termes. Donc c'est bien
d'avoir une un toile de fond historique
bien sûr, mais vouloir la projeter
systématiquement et faire du plug and
play, ça ne marche pas. Donc ça a foiré
en Libye, ça a foiré en Afghanistan, ça
a foiré en Irak et Dieu sait que ça a
vraiment foiré en Irak. Mais euh mais
euh en Syrie
pour l'instant, j'allais dire et je le
dis d'autant plus qu'au moment où euh au
moment où ça s'est produit, je me disais
quand même il a fait ses classes, il a
fait ses classes chez Al-Qaïda, euh la
reconversion est quand même brutale.
Est-ce que est-ce que il va tenir le
rôle et cetera ? et il a l'air de le
faire avec une intelligence qui a
convaincu jusqu'à pas mal de dirigeants
européens et ça a l'air de tenir et a
priori ça a aidé été aidé un petit peu
par Israël d'ailleurs mais c'est pas ce
qu'on disait sur le moment. On parlait
beaucoup du rôle des Turcs qui n'est pas
démenti. D'ailleurs, on parlait un peu
moins du rôle d'Israël mais on parle
davantage encore. Donc ça a été,
j'allais dire aidé mais ça a pas été
produit provoqué. C'est venu de
l'intérieur quand même. Euh l'Iran, si
ça vient de l'intérieur en étant aidé
sans être provoqué, euh ma fois ça peut
peut-être fonctionner. Maintenant,
est-ce que ça suffira à installer un
équilibre qui fera pour revenir à ta
question que Israël se satisferait du
scénario 1 ou 2, c'est-à-dire la paix
par la paix ou la paix par la paix par
des actions ponctuelles, je ne suis pas
sûr. Je pense que ce sera toujours plus
ou moins la sécurité, c'est-à-dire la
version d'en dessous avec toujours un
état au sens double du terme, l'État
d'Israël et un état psychique sur la
brèche parce que je pense que c'est et
si tu le retraçais d'ailleurs pour le
coup dans ton dans ton liminaire
historique, c'est presque un peu dans
l'ADN en quelque sorte. Je suis pas là
pour faire de la la génétique des
populations, c'est pas mon sujet. C'est
ça reste imagé ce que je dis. On est
bien d'accord. Et puis voilà, je pour
les les spectateurs, ça reste imagé, ça
ne reste qu'une métaphore. Je pense que
c'est quand même un état qui s'est
construit sur la brèche, le le pardon,
comment ça s'appelle cette ah ce
polytechnique israélien là très en
pointe là, son nom échappe à l'instant,
mais ça me reviendra. Euh il y a une
imbrication avec le monde de la défense
qui est qui est ultra fort. L'innovation
est tirée par la défense. La la la
l'économie est tiré par la défense.
Quand on on se balade euh en Israël euh
c'est saisissant de voir euh tous ces
jeunes là euh femmes et hommes euh qui
sont euh entréis euh tu vois des jeunes
femmes entréis en sandal avec le sac à
main et le fusil d'assaut de l'autre et
ça s'en servir et sûrement mieux que moi
parce que ça fait quand même pas mal de
temps que j'ai pas tiré. Euh voilà,
quand j'étais jeune, ça m'arrivait.
Voilà. Bon, donc voilà. Et donc et donc
tu vois que tu vois qu'ils sont cet
esprit de défense, il est chevillé au
corps. Voilà, quand les réservistes,
c'est une armée avec beaucoup de
réservistes de salle quand ils sont
rappelés
non seulement ils viennent mais voilà,
tu as les commerces qui sont qui sont
vides et cetera. Donc c'est
consubstantiel à la population. J'allais
dire si euh s'il y avait la paix euh ça
ce serait sans doute une grande rupture.
Ce serait quelque chose qu'il faudrait
accompagner un peu comme quand les gens
prennent leur retraite quoi. Ça se passe
pas toujours bien.
L'Ukraine, l'Europe, l'Ukraine,
l'Europe, l'Ukraine les Russes,
l'Europe, l'Ukraine les États-Unis, les
Russes, les Chinois.
Est-ce que c'est le centre de
l'échiquier pour les Européens ?
C'est une question difficile parce que
en fait non mais particulièrement
difficile pour non plus difficile pour
moi. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'en fait non,
j'ai changé mon Tu as fait caca ce matin
? J'ai j'ai changé mon j'ai changé ma ma
vision des choses en fait.
J'étais convaincu en fait. J'étais
convaincu jusque jusque en 2000
22 au hasard que
il y avait une architecture de sécurité
européenne. Alors je le suis Attends
attends attends je continue je continue
laisse-moi finir. Une architecture de
J'en suis toujours convaincu, mais plus
sur la même temporalité. Voilà, ça c'est
la conclusion de ce que je vais dire
mais maintenant je vais un peu
développer quand même que tu crois que
mais non mais que demain oui peut-être.
Euh c'est pas demain. Oui, peut-être.
C'est demain. Oui. Il faudra de toute
façon sauf à ce que sauf à ce que la
dérive des continents fasse que la
Russie se détache si tu veux de
l'Europe. Voilà. Et ça, j'en suis pas
vraiment persuadé. Et en même temps,
Vladimir Poutine est quand même pas de
la première jeunesse et même si euh
voilà tout seul voilà et le jour le
régime tient quand même
énormément grâce à lui, le jour où il
part euh on sait pas ce qui va se passer
et les Américains savent pas non plus.
Et ça fait partie des scénarios. Il faut
pas être grand clair et c'est en source
ouverte dans toutes les analyses. Euh
chacun se demande ce qui se passerait si
le le le régime s'effondrait si Poutine
disparaissait. Vo c'est les mêmes
sources ouvertes qui disaient qu'il y
avait un cancer, une lecémie.
Cela dit, je sais pas, c'est les mêmes
sources ouvertes pour les
lave-vaisselles.
Est-ce que c'est les mêmes sources
ouvertes que Non. Bah, ce sont les
sources ouvert. Est-ce que c'est les
mêmes sources ouvertes qui disent qu'
faisit des attaques à l'appel en Non.
Euh non mais il y a des Est-ce que c'est
les mêmes sources ouvertes qui n'ont pas
vu le départ du conflit parce que il y
avait pas les hôpitaux de campagne
derrière la ligne de front ? Non mais
les Attends, qui a vu le départ du
conflit à part un peu les Américains ?
Un peu les Américains. Ah sûrement pas
la DRM. C'est un peu les Américains. Un
peu les Américains. Mais le
renseignement c'est pas forcément
prévoir. Le renseignement c'est pas
forcément prévoir. Voilà, j'écarte ce
sujet. Pas forcément prévoir. C'est
sûrement anticipé. c'est faire un bon
diagnostic de la situation. Encore
faut-il avoir tous les capteurs, encore
faut-il avoir le recul pour pouvoir
analyser la situation. Après, c'est la
pensée que tu met avec des mots plus
simples pour les gens qui ne comprennent
rien ou qui comprennent un peu plus avec
des parallèles médicales. C'est-à-dire
pour faire un bon diagnostic, faut que
tu es un bon généraliste qui t'envoie
voir le bon spécialiste qui a la bonne
infirmière, qui va te faire la bonne
injection, qui va t'envoyer avant faire
ta coronarographie ou ton scanner ou ta
la question la question c'est celle de
non, c'est la mise en perspective des
connaissances, du renseignement ou de
n'importe quelle information.
Tu vas voir ton chirurgien
gastroentérologue qui dit bon là on a un
problème. Oui mais c'est la c'est la
mise en perspective des connaissances.
C'est ça qui est important aussi. C'est
la façon dont tu es disposé à les lire.
Ça c'est hyper important. Tu es disposé
à les accepter. Don tu es disposé à les
accepter. C'est vrai qu'un des premiers
précepts de la prospective qu'il faut
pas avoir peur de déplaire. Ça c'est
certain. Tu as pas l'impression que là
il y a pas que des tu m'autorises à être
vulgaire, on est entre nous.
Tu as pas l'impression que dans nos
prospectivistes, dans nos analystes,
sont pas les mêmes analystes,
prospectivistes, mais OK, les analystes,
d'accord. Tu as pas l'impression que
Mais regarde le 7 octobre, attends
attends attends, je vais répondre à ta
question. Je vais répondre à ta question
et tu vas voir que c'est plus compliqué
que ça. Le 7 octobre, c'estàdire que le
7, le 7 octobre, ça a été l'attaque du 7
octobre, elle a été prévue, elle a été
documentée, ils avaient les plans, les
analystes des services israéliens et
c'est quand même, on va le dire hein,
parmi les meilleurs du monde, si ce
n'est les meilleurs du monde. Le
Mossade, c'est c'est le Mossade, quoi.
Voilà. Bon, un moment si il y a pas
l'écoute, si euh j'allais dire le le
prisme, la plaque photographique est pas
prête à se laisser impressionner au sens
physico-chimique du terme. Bref, s'il y
a pas l'écran l'écrain pardon pour
accueillir et mettre en perspective la
connaissance, le renseignement ça
devient un peigne pour les choses. En
fait souvent on a l'info, enfin souvent
on quand je dis on c'est pas moi ni
machin c'est le en général la nature
enfin l'homme d'une certaine manière a
les infos mais il ne sait pas forcément
les lire ou il sait pas les mettre en
perspective et c'est là que le rôle tu
me disais la prospective quel résultat
bah quel résultat si tu as réussi à
faire charger le politique là je suis
pas en train de charger le politique
c'est les victoires sont collectives les
défaites le sont tout autant si dans les
cadres intermédiaires dans tout
l'ensemble, tout l'écosystème, tout le
monde n'est pas pétri de prospective,
tout le monde ne s'est pas préparé à
voir les choses sous différents angles
et donc apte à les reconnaître quand
elles peuvent advenir. Et ben l'info en
tant que telle, elle est pas
revenons à ta phrase. Prospectiviste
analyste peur de déplaire. C'est ça
aussi. C'est c'est le précep premier.
D'accord. Donc qu'est-ce que tu fais si
en face de toi tu as quelqu'un qui sent
tamponne le coquill ? Mais là où les
choses, tu pars dans le privé, tu
l'attaques au nitrate d'argent pour lui
dire maintenant on va faire des photos
tous les deux. Là où les choses, tu fais
quoi ? Tu quittes la porte, tu prends
tes potes de ton service, tu dis écoute,
on est des lions dirigés par des annes,
on s'en va.
Mais là, tu serais surpris de voir, moi
je vois parmi les gens que j'essaie de
sensibiliser à la prospective, de former
et puis là c'est c'est balbuciant. On y
est, je propose, j'ai j'ai posé des Non
mais mais moi je parle de ce que je
connais et de ce que je fais. Donc je
suis pas là pour répondre de ce qui a pu
se produire ou des éventuelles des
éventuelles défaillances du passé. Je
suis là pour dire voilà ce qu'on va
faire et tu serais étonné de voir
l'écoute et non seulement l'écoute mais
le souci et la demande qu'il y a en
terme d'aiguillon. C'est-à-dire que les
gens souhaitent être aiguillonnés. Ils
souhaitent que tu leur apportes la
contradiction. Ils souhaitent que tu
leur fasses réfléchir, ils souhaitent
que tu que tu les bouscules en fait.
Pourquoi ? C'est pas parce que ils sont
devenus bienveillants à ton égard ou
qu'ils souhaitent ta réussite, c'est
parce qu'en fait ils ont compris que
c'était vital. Alors tu vas me dire
"Ouais, ils ont compris trop tard et
cetera. Moi, j'en ai 50 qui ont traversé
l'Atlantique. C'est possible. C'est
possible. Non, mais c'est possible. Mais
je dire il est pas trop tard et qu'il
l'it compris les uns et les autres dans
l'écosystème stratégique et stratégique,
c'est large hein, ça touche approche
globale, on a on en reparlait. Celui qui
fait les commandes de coton.
Ah et ben et ben c'est ça qu'il faut. Et
comme tu le dis, celui qui fait les
commandes de coton, il faut donner du
sens. Si chacun pardon si chacun n'est
que spécialiste du cerveau de la censu,
tout le monde aura reconnu reconnu la
référence à Nietzsche si tu es
spécialiste du cerveau de la censu et
que du cerveau de la censu, tu pourras
jamais avoir la big picture. Donc il
faut quand tu es spécialiste du cerveau
de la censu l'être parce que on peut pas
tout le monde peut pas tout faire.
Voilà, il faut bien se spécialiser en
tout cas tant que l'homme et homme. On n
pas parlé du changement de la nature
humaine, du changement anthropologique
qui est à l'œuvre. Faudra qu'on en
parle. Voilà. Mais très bien. Mais il
faut quand même mais il faut quand même
il faut quand même avoir un peu ne pas
perdre de vue et avant de ne pas perdre
de vue, avoir en vue même biaiser un peu
la big picture. Et donc il faut que
chacun y compris l'expert du cerveau de
la censu y compris mon architecte y
compris soit un peu prospectiviste. En
fait c'est quelque chose de transversal.
On se demande pas s'il y a que le
mathématicien qui doit maîtriser les
additions, s'il y a que le commercial
qui doit parler l'anglais. Bon ben alors
pourquoi il y aurait que le
prospectiviste qui ferait de la
prospective ? C'est en fait c'est un non
sens. C'est ne rien comprendre à la
prospective déjà que de se dire qu'il
faut qu'il y ait des prospectivistes.
D'ailleurs, d'une certaine manière, moi
j'ai vocation à disparaître.
C'est-à-dire que j'ai vocation à SM, à
former et cetera et puis euh quand
j'aurai fait mon temps ici-bas euh il y
aura plus de prospectiviste et on dira
ça n'a plus lieu d'être. Est-ce que il y
a des pilotes dans les avions ? Il y a
des pilotes dans les avions mais est-ce
qu'on dit euh ah bah moi je suis je suis
je suis conducteur de voiture alors tu
vas me dire un mauvais exemple il y a
des taxis et cetera, il y a des VTC. Bon
ok, je te l'accorde mais à peu près tout
à chacun conduit sa voiture et à peu
près tout à chacun est capable de se
déplacer. Le transport n'est pas une
compétence métier particulière. Alors si
parce qu'il y a des trains et cetera et
cetera, mais voilà, tu vois l'idée en
train de dire que les pilotes de ligne
sont des conducteurs de métro. Je suis
d'accord avec toi. C'est un métier qui
disparaîtra, c'est évident. Question
internet. D'un point de vue
philosophique, quelle est la définition
de la vérité et qu'est-ce qui est le
plus important ? L'opinion ou la vérité
?
Alors en fait l'opinion par alors je
vais donner ma ma vision de la vérité et
la conclusion ce sera que l'opinion
participe de la vérité et la vérité de
l'opinion parce que moi je vois les
choses d'une façon intriquée et je
reviendrai sur cette intrication. Euh la
vérité, il y a plusieurs conceptions de
la vérité. Question philosophique,
réponse philosophique. La première,
celle que on connaît tous parce qu'on
est tous un peu modernes, on est tous
issus du progrès, on est tous issus de
l'époque Belmondo, le steak frit. Voilà,
les années 80, on est tous un peu comme
ça. Les adultes d'aujourd'hui, je parle
pas des enfants et de la génération,
mais voilà qui sont adultes, c'est un
autre sujet. Je réponds à la question.
Je réponds à la question, mais c'est
c'est une vraie question au sens où
j'allais dire, ils nous ont beaucoup à
nous apporter par leur âme d'enfant,
leur leur syndrome Peter Pan, mais j'y
reviendrai. Donc voilà, théorie de la
correspondance. Le réel
correspond à l'idée qu'on s'en fait ou
l'idée qu'on s'en fait correspond au
réel. Ça c'est la vérité. Si je dis que
voilà, ça c'est une caméra parce que ça
obéit euh ça obéit en fait aux
caractéristiques de la caméra. L'idée,
le mot, chose, l'idée la chose pardon,
la chose et l'idée, la chose et le mot
coïncide. Correspondance. Je crois qu'il
y a à peu près 99 % des internautes qui
me diront bah oui, c'est ça la vérité.
Voilà. Euh, il y a une autre façon de
voir la vérité, c'est plutôt non plus la
correspondance mais la cohérence. Ça
c'est plus égulien. C'est c'est l'idée
est conforme à la chose. Alors,
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? Ça veut
dire que si je construis un monde un peu
fictif dans le monde mathématique par
exemple, bah dans le monde mathématique,
il y a des choses qui sont vraies dans
un système puis qui sont fausses dans
l'autre. Donc déjà la vérité c'est déjà
plus la même. Prend un exemple hein.
Voilà sur un plan,
le chemin le plus court entre deux
points, c'est la ligne droite. Sur une
sphère, c'est pas le cas. C'est la
géodie. Tu as un chat ? Tu as un chat ?
Tu l'as appelé Schrodinger. Non. Alors
voilà, j'aurais j'ai pas de chat mais
mon père un chat, il un sacré de
Birmanie, un superbe chat et il
s'appelle pas Et il s'appelle pas dans
un petit appartement
sur rue Sarasad, c'est ça ? Non, pas
encore. Et a priori et a priori a priori
jamais. Euh c'était quoi ma question sur
l'Ukraine ? Alors attends, je reviens
quand même, on reviendra à
l'architecture de sécurité européenne.
Je réponds à la la question de
l'internaute. Voilà. Et puis ensuite, on
reviendra à cette histoire
d'architecture, de sécurité à laquelle
tu ne crois pas, à laquelle je croyais,
à laquelle je ne crois plus à courte
échéance, mais à laquelle je crois à
longue échéance. parce que je pense que
s'il y a une tendance qui est vraie,
c'est celle géologique que malgré tout
euh voilà euh la pangée c'était il y a
longtemps et la Russie reste collé à
l'Europe. Donc pour revenir à la
question de notre internaute, théorie de
la correspondance, théorie de la
cohérence, il y a la théorie euh plus
intéressante sans doute pour la
prospective qui la théorie la vérité
selon le pragmatisme. Ça c'est des
philosophes que je dise pas de conneries
comme John de Way. Donc ça c'est l'idée
en gros pour faire simple, c'est ce qui
est vrai c'est ce qui marche. Si ça
fonctionne, si ça produit un résultat
utile, c'est vrai. Et donc à quelle
échelle de temps ? Et alors peu importe
l'échelle de temps, ce qui la bonne
question c'est de se dire qu'est-ce qui
est utile, qu'est-ce qui l'est pas.
Alors ça renvoie l'échelle de temps.
Est-ce que si c'est utile pendant 25
ans, c'est utile ? Bah pour mon fils,
oui. Pour moi, peut-être un peu moins.
En fait, que prolonger la guerre pour
éviter de passer devant les juges, c'est
utile ? Bah, c'est utile pour celui qui
le fait. Euh et je vois à qui tu penses
et tu seras sans doute c'est Oui, mais à
cet âge-là euh ils sont nombreux donc
euh ça permettra pas de discriminer.
Donc bon euh tout régime tu sais c'est
spinosist hein. Toute chose essaie de
persévérer dans son être. Donc
s'accrocher à un régime, s'accrocher au
pouvoir quand on est au pouvoir, je
pense que c'est presque humain. Est-ce
que s'accrocher à la connerie aussi ? La
fuite en avant,
c'est pas une fuite en avant. C'est
il n'y a que des il n'y a que il n'y a
que des petits pas. Euh la façon de
s'accrocher au pouvoir, de durer un
petit peu plus, refuser d'admettre de
refuser d'admettre qu'ils se sont
plantés. Attends, on parle de on a
changé on a changé de voilà. Le prisme
est valable pour les deux.
Oui, mais là je préfère parler du pour
le premier, c'est-à-dire parce que là,
c'est quand même de notoriété publique.
Effectivement, le le la sécurité par la
guerre permet aussi le maintien du
régime du régime israélien en place, du
gouvernement israélien en place et du
premier d'entre eux. Et ça c'est dire
c'est bon c'est presque un c'est pas un
secret de polyinel mais tout le monde le
lit comme ça et puis euh Tocville vient
à notre rescous on sait bien qu'on fait
la politique du dehors comme disait
Tokville avec les raisons du dedans.
Voilà et souvent on communique vers le
dehors en s'adressant au dedans. Mais il
y a des exceptions hein aussi Donald
Trump hier s'est plutôt adressé au
dehors pour toucher vraiment le dehors.
Il s'adressait plutôt à Netaniaahou
quand il a dit que merci à l'Iran, merci
d'avoir prévenu et les frappes sont
faibles. C'était plutôt à Netaniaou me
semble-t-il pour lui dire bon ben
maintenant on arrête un peu les frais.
C'est évidemment pas à son électorat.
Macron il s'adresse à qui ? Bah au
français j'imagine du dehors ou du
dedans en tant que citoyen. En tant que
citoyen, je pense que quand le président
parle je me sens concerné.
Je me sens concerné. La théorie de la
vérité, il y en a d'autres qui sont
utiles. Oui, mais le problème Oui. Non,
mais tu considères pas tes internautes.
lui, il veut la réponse, il a raison de
la vouloir parce qu'en fait, les vraies
théories de la vérité qui sont
intéressantes pour faire la prospective
sur laquelle je bosse et l'approche
cognitive de la prospective avec des
trucs hyper opératoires et pas fumeux,
c'est pas la théorie de la
correspondance, la théorie de la
cohérence, c'est un peu le pragmatisme
parce que qui dit qui fixe ce qui est
utile de ce qui l'est pas, ça veut dire
qu'en fait la reconstruction de l'état
de l'art dont tu me bassinais au départ
en me disant "Oui, mais il faut il faut
arriver à tout connaître." Moi, je m'en
fous de tout connaître. Je veux
connaître ce qui va m'intéresser pour
produire le résultat utile du
commanditaire ou de moi-même si je suis
mon commanditaire parce que tu as des
facultés limitées. Et donc c'est mais
mais tout le monde je te rappelle que la
théorie de la décision la théorie de
Simon c'est la rationalité limitée.
C'est un des quatre modèles, un des cinq
modèles de de prise de décision théorie
de la rationale limitée limitée. Tu ne
peux pas tout prendre de cuit.
Je l'ai jamais mesuré et je ne le ferai
jamais parce que s'il est trop fort, je
me dirais j'ai pas assez bien réussi et
s'il est trop faible, je serai déçu.
Donc dans les deux cas, j'aurai les
boules. Donc je préfère laisser ça.
Voilà. Ép et après je me rassurer en me
disant oui mais ça dit pas toute
l'intelligence enfin des conneries comme
ça. Dans les ÉPAD ça existe ce type de
test ou pas ?
des tests un peu parfois toutes les
institutions Oui, toutes leurs
institutions leur test c'est normal et
c'est bien dans une visée managérial ça
répond à un gabarit qui est celui du
moment qui une vérité du moment c'est
une logique pragmatique. Revenons à
l'Ukraine. Et juste un juste une
parenthèse pour dire moi la théorie de
la vérité qui m'intéresse, c'est celle
qui est constructiviste. Voilà,
c'est-à-dire celle où on participe de la
construction du réel et de ce qui est
vrai ou pas. Voilà. et par le récit et
par euh le pouvoir euh discursif,
c'est-à-dire véritablement le récit qui
va faire sens et qui va construire du
sens. Voilà, ça c'est plutôt fouo. Et
puis au-delà euh au-delà ça va être euh
ça va être Berkson, ça va être euh ça va
être Grotendic pour euh pour les Topos,
c'est l'état de vérité. Et Topo, c'est
un outil là, je fais mon coming out.
Alors pas celui de Rusarazat, mais celui
sur la méthode prospective.
Voilà, utiliser les top sans prospective
et j'aurai l'occasion de de de détailler
ça plus tard. Voilà, je referme cette
parenthèse un peu livresque qui
n'intéresse que moi et l'internaute
quand même. Ça peut être ça peut être
aussi géré comme ou perçu comme une
colopathie fonctionnelle verbale.
Revenons à nos moutons, on va parler de
l'Ukraine mais avant je peux je peux te
poser une question ? OK. Tu m'avais
coupé quand même mais OK. Bah je t'ai
laissé terminer. Tu veux du papier ?
Non, tu m'avais coupé sur l'Ukraine.
J'avais même pas dit architecture de
sécurité européenne que déjà tu m'as
sauté à la gorge. Est-ce que Non, bah ça
va, tu es tu encore tu trché hein. Oui,
mais c'est c'est limite quand même.
Ouais. Tu veux pousser la chansonnette ?
Est-ce que tu as déjà lu Siing Ping ? Ah
non, j'ai pas lu dans le texte. Non non,
j'ai j'ai lu ceux qui l'ont lu ou ceux
qui ou les journalistes qui rapportent
ses propos. Non, j'ai pas lu dans le
texte. Non. Donc euh allez
l'architecture de défense européenne et
les les prospectives foireuses de
l'Europe.
Alors cette architecture de sécurité
européenne euh tu sais à qui nous font
penser ? Tu as déjà été à Las Vegas ?
Oui, trois fois. Je l'ai même sur Las
Vegas au Bellagio. Au Bellagio trois
fois. Voilà. Alors non, une fois c'était
c'était moins moins moins faste mais
c'était en mission. Donc on est économe
des deniers de la nation ça arrive ça
pas au boaggio. Bah non tu confonds
tout. Je te dis c'était plus modeste
parce que c'était avec les les deniers
publics. Donc donc forcément voilà donc
on fait donc on fait attention et cetera
et cetera mais c'était quand même à Las
Vegas parce qu'il se produit quand même
quelques quelques entraînements autour
de Las Vegas mais je te parle de ça
c'était dans ma prime jeunesse. Ouais
ouais la base de Nell de Nice. Voilà
avec des exercices dont certains
s'appellent par exemple red flag. Bon
mais ça ça remonte à il y a long quelle
était ma question ? Et ben, tu me
demandais si aller à Las Vegas. Avais
question la question c'est tu as pas
l'impression que nos prospectivistes
européens, ceux qui nous font toujours
des prospectives foireuses, ça ressemble
au popoches
à 4h du matin devant les machines à sous
qui mettent 10 balles dans la machine.
Ils sont complètement ivremorts. Ils
passent les aides sociales, les crédits
de mamie, le compte en banque de maman,
le compte en banque du frère. Et vas-y
que je te continue de te tirer sur la
manivelle et que je te tire sur la
manivelle. Sauf que là, nos
prospectivistes européens, ils font ça
avec nos tunes et il est 4h du matin,
ils sont ivremorts mais ils continuent à
[__] 10 balles dans la machine, 10
balles dans la machine sans jamais se
remettre en question en disant "Bon, on
s'est planté, faudrait peut-être qu'on y
aille." Non, mais là, je pense que alors
là pour le coup, moi je prends la
défense de personne. Je suis au-dessus
des polémiques, non pas parce que je me
m'estime au-dessus, c'est pas du tout,
je dis pour les spectateurs. Non, mais
je dis pour les spectateurs, c'est pas
une forme d'arrogance ou de mépris.
C'est parce qu'en fait je veux pas,
c'est pas mon sujet en fait. Mon sujet
c'est véritablement d'engberiste. Oui
mais justement tu peux juger les
prospectives des autres. Bon et alors
sans sans sans juger les prospectives
des autres, mon sentiment mais en tant
que citoyen là confraternel. Non je suis
pas confraternel. C'est qu'en fait je
pense que ne pas faire de mal aux
autres. Pas du tout. c'est que je pense
qu'en fait on est collectivement
responsable de l'inertie des choses et
que après fini tu vas me dire on a les
politiques qu'on mérite. Non, je vais
pas dire ça parce que les politiques
pourraient dire on a les citoyens qu'on
mérite et en l'occurrence c'est assez
facile de frapper sur les politiques et
là euh euh j'ai plus envie évidemment
euh c'est imagé de de frapper sur les
citoyens parce que euh j'ai quand même
l'impression euh que
ça manque un peu d'élan vital parfois
tout ça quoi.
La population a un niveau intellectuel
trop fait pour qu'on C'est pas un niveau
intellectuel, c'est euh c'est l'audace,
c'est la résilience. C'est l'audace,
c'est la résilience, c'est l'esprit de
défense, c'est l'envie de sens, l'envie
de dépassement et tout à tous les
niveaux. Ça c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut reconstruire. Et là, les politiques
honnêtement c'est pas facile pour eux
parce que quand ils disent quand ils
veulent Non, mais prenons les choses. En
France, typiquement, moi je m'exprime en
tant que citoyen, quand on se dit bon,
OK, les collectivités territoriales, on
voit bien qu'il y aurait des économies à
faire, fameux frais fonctionnement. Mon
père est maire d'une petite ville, c'est
lui qui me dit ça, c'est pas moi, c'est
lui qui parle là. Bon, je parle sous son
contrôle, je sais pas s'il m'écoute. Il
me dit "Mais c'est impossible en fait de
de réformer quoi que ce soit parce qu'en
fait il y a des perfusions euh à
outrance au sein de ces collectivités
territoriales et tu sais pas par quel
bout attaquer." Et moi, maire de la
petite ville machin, on me commande des
expertises sur des échelles à poisson
pour que c'est c'est véridique he ce que
je dis hein, des expertises sur des
échelles à poisson pour que les saumons
puissent remonter le courant. Que
perturbe la centrale hydroélectrique qui
produit du courant de façon totalement
écologique
en surplus au point de pouvoir en
revendre à EDF, de faire une commune qui
du coup financièrement se porte bien est
en excédent au point qu'il a pu réduire
je dirais pas je pas dire de conneries,
je crois qu'il a pas annulé les impôts
mais il les a réduit considérablement.
Voilà.
Et on va l'emmerder avec une échelle à
poisson parce qu'il faut que le le le
saumon puisse remonter le courant. Très
bien. C'est sûrement c'est certainement
nécessaire mais tu n'as pas idée du coût
des expertises qui doivent être
produites pour conclure à ce qu'il faut
comme échelle à poisson. Et ça ça
chiffre en dizaines voire centaines de
milliers d'euros. Voilà c'est ça. Voilà.
Et donc ça multiplié à et qui paye. Bon
bah c'est la collectivité territoriale.
Voilà. Bon et ça c'est quelque chose qui
typiquement qui qui paye la collectivité
territoriale ? Bah il y a des revenus
qui lui sont propres. Euh et puis il y a
effectivement aussi bah des transferts
de l'État que l'on sait hein lié à la
décentralisation.
Bah c'est le contribuable bien sûr.
Voilà. Bon donc ça c'est un problème.
Après évidemment il y a la question du
social. Bon, la question du social, elle
est importante, mais ça nous renvoie à
ce qu'on disait au début de au début de
l'interview, c'est euh où les citoyens
veulent-ils mettre les ressources ?
S'ils estiment qu'elles doivent être
mises sur le social comme elles le sont
actuellement, et ben il y a rien à dire
de plus. Le peuple souverain a choisi
mais il doit pas après se retourner vers
le politique en se disant "Mais je
comprends pas qu'il y a un tel déficit
et je comprends pas que et que du c'est
pas voilà, il faut accepter. C'est ça la
démocratie." C'est difficile la
démocratie parce qu'en fait il faut
s'approprier les décisions des enfin des
autres. La nôtre en fait dont on est
coproducteur.
Le véritable problème de fond. Mais ça
c'est Attends, attends, je finis juste
là-dessus parce que c'est un enfin je ça
me semble important ce que ce que je
j'ai envie de te dire là, c'est que le
véritable problème c'est que personne ne
se sent dépositaire et coproducteur de
la décision qui est prise. Et en
prospective, puisque c'est mon sujet,
moi ce n'est que mon sujet, pour faire
de la bonne prospective, il faut que
tout le monde idéalement se soit se soit
senti coproducteur. Alors, il y a deux
façons. Soit on fait venir tout le monde
autour de la table et ça donne des
grands débats qui mènent à rien. Bon et
là il faut se contenter de travailler
avec les décideurs. Bon voilà
soit soit tu fais en sorte que chacun
soit un peu prospectiviste. Tu
décentralises la prospective et chacun
fait la prospective à son niveau. Et ça
renvoie une notion qui est capitale en
matière de stratégie, c'est la
subsidiarité. L'intelligence
collaborative. Oui. Et la Exactement. Et
l'intelligence collaborative on le fait
c'est fait pour les capacités
militaires. On parle de plus en plus du
combat collaboratif. Bon bah, la
coproduction collaborative en terme de
prospective, en terme de de politique
publique, ça a un sens et en terme aussi
au-delà de la politique publique de ce
que fait tout à chacun au quotidien.
Encore une fois, si l'architecte est
prospectiviste, ces constructions, même
les constructions qui ne sont pas des
ouvrages d'art, ça va être autre chose.
Et il y a pas que des gens nouvelles ou
des Tom Main ou des Frank Guerrier, il y
a une gens gens nouvelle, non mais je
préfère Frank Guerry. Voilà, c'est c'est
il y a un très bon resto dans le sud de
la France. Ah c'est c'est possible.
C'est possible. Voilà. Donc il faut que
chaque ça se décentralise et ben c'est
la même chose. Et donc du coup après si
ça se décentralise non seulement c'est
mieux fait mais en plus les gens tu les
gens que tu mets autour de la table pour
leur faire comprendre. Bon vu que j'ai
en t'écoutant j'ai l'impression que tu
as trois trains d'avance par rapport à
eux donc tu es obligé de leur remâcher
un peu le travail et ensuite de leur
donner un peu la béquille à tous pour
qu'ils comprennent.
Est-ce que tu leur expliques les risques
que s'ils ne font pas, ils s'exposent ou
ils exposent le système à Alors, en
fait, alors déjà humilité 1 et pas
finte, je suis humble mais pas modeste,
donc je reconnais mes mérites. Voilà, ça
c'est certain. Euh je reste je reste Non
non non, justement je reviens, je reste
humble parce que je sais euh l'humilité,
c'est savoir ce qui nous reste à
parcourir, c'est savoir
ce qu'on peut prendre des autres. C'est
voàmeè
de toasé
forcément tu passes
tu passes quelqu'un tu passes pour
quelqu'un d'arrogant. Non non je non
mais je est-ce que ça déjà arrivé ? Mais
mais combien de fois on m'a dit que
j'étais arrogant ? Je les compte même
plus. Je les compte même plus. Mais
c'est c'est se fourvoyer les gens qui
disent qui pensent de moi que je suis
arrogant, ils se gourent en fait. C'est
parce qu'ils me connaissent pas. Et ceux
qui sont très panés et non c'est qu'ils
me connaissent pas parce qu'une fois
qu'ils me connaissent, il voi que je
suis pas arrogant. Au contraire. Au
contraire. Et là, l'idée c'est pas
d'imposer quelque chose, c'est
véritablement de montrer déjà la méthode
que j'ai tenté de mettre au point. Euh
elle s'est construite dans le temps. Euh
euh bah autant que une habilitation à
diriger des recherches euh constitue un
brevet. Euh c'est pas le cas mais en
tout cas euh ça montre qu'en tout cas ça
voilà ça ça a fait son chemin dans
l'enseignement, ça a été expérimenté, ça
a été euh ça a été comment ça a été
salué aussi bien par le niveau
étudiantin que par les professeurs que
par des cadres qui ont eu à travailler
avec. Voilà, ça fait son chemin quand
même. Ça fait son chemin. Et peut-être
que ça se mettre sous la dent. C'est
possible. C'est possible. Et disons-le,
peut-être qu'au pays des aveugles,
parfois les borgnes sont rois, mais
c'est possible aussi. Mais mais au
final, voilà. Donc en toute humilité, on
fait les choses ensemble. C'est c'est ça
n'en est qu'au début.
la méthode la méthode la méthode que je
vais produire là septembre, décembre et
mars et par ailleurs, bon nombre
d'éléments sont encore inédits.
D'ailleurs, j'aurais le plaisir de de
faire une publication complémentaire à
l'ouvrage que j'ai que j'ai déjà publié
sur la prospective stratégique. Voilà,
donc ce sera un additif où on voit
comment concrètement on creuse la
dimension cognitive et comment on
utilise l'intelligence artificielle pour
se faire. Parce que l'idée c'est pas de
faire un truc à la grand-papa, c'est
vraiment de se démultiplier. Mais
attention, on délègue pas la pensée. On
délègue pas la pensée. La pensée pour
l'instant, elle reste humaine. Par
contre, on délègue la pouvoir de
démultiplication, le pouvoir de
combinaison et le pouvoir
d'interrogation des frontières, les
frontières catégorielles. Parce que tu
le disais, la complexité, être capable
de tout embrasser, c'est ça qui est
véritablement clé. Par contre, à
l'intérieur de chaque discipline, tu
m'as posé des questions sur le
nucléaire. Au bout des deux questions,
j'étais éc pardessus tête parce que
forcément c'est pas ma spécialité, c'est
pas mon sujet. Donc ton équipe de course
que tu es en train de faire mais en fait
elle est à géométrie variable. En
fonction du sujet qu'on adresse, bah on
se dote du des bons experts. D'accord.
comme un journaliste. Un journaliste, il
est pas spécialiste de tous les sujets,
même s'il a quand même une inclination
pour certains sujets. Et après, il va à
l'info, il se construit un savoir et il
fait en sorte que les choses soient
vérifiées et qu'elles puissent entrer en
dialogue. Et c'est ça qui fait le le bon
journaliste. Et il fait émerger la
vérité à travers une disputao. Il fait
remonter de l'information de haute
qualité pour que les gens puissent
prendre leur décision en leur âme et
conscience.
Revenons à l'Ukraine.
Ça va se terminer comment ce bourbier
selon ton toi prospectiviste ?
Alors pour la partie prospective botte
pas en touche, il faudrait travailler
sur l'architecture européenne de
sécurité, c'est-à-dire se dire qu'à un
moment ou un autre, de toute façon, de
toute façon, à un moment ou un autre, il
y aura plus il y aura plus Poutine et à
un moment ou à un autre, le peuple russe
avec lequel je ne crois pas déjà on
n'est pas en guerre avec la Russie, je
ne crois pas qu'on soit et on n'est
certainement pas en guerre avec le
peuple russe. Ça c'est Ça c'est parce
que de l'autre côté à mon avis ils
doivent se poser d'autres questions pour
le peuple russe je suis pas certain que
le tu tu as pas l'impression que le
peuple russe quand il voit des missiles
comment ça s'appelle des Taurus ? C'est
la version du scalp c'est ça ? C'est la
version de missile de croisière scalp
allemande. Tu as écouté un peu ce qui se
raconte ? Faut toujours essayer de de
C'est vrai, il faut rentrer dans le
logiciel en face. Mais quoi qu'il en
soit, je réponds à ta question. Non, pas
encore. Où est-ce que tu as vu une
question ? Bah tu m'as demandé
l'Ukraine, qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Comment tu vois la chose ? J'ai commencé
par un préambule sur l'après long terme
et après je te dirais le logiciel de
l'autre. Toujours commencer par ça. H
empathie. Empathie. Compréhension. OK.
Tu connais les avions ? Tu connais les
missiles un peu ? Non. Ça tuas Ah j'ai
quelques notions mais un scalp un Taurus
c'est combien de de péons derrière pour
faire fonctionner le bordel ? Combien de
combien de petits gens pour faire
fonctionner le bordel ? Faut un
satellite, pas de satellite, faut deux
gars, un gars, faut un mec avec un
joystick, pas de joystick.
de croisière ça met sous les ailes d'un
avion missile a missiles de croisière
naval aussi ça existe MDCN par exemple
voilà missile de croisière scalp on
parle pas de la même chose là tu Non non
là tu me parl tu parles sur un missile
non mais là alors là tu parles de
scrotal c'est défense solaire courte
portée c'està oui voilà et donc là on
parle scalptorus ce genre de bordel
scalptorus voilà ça ce sont pour nos
spectateur c'est combien ça vaut combien
hein. Oh, c'est un peu plus d'un million
pièces. Oh, ça fait une petite
maternelle, quoi. Voilà. Bon, c'est un
missile de croisière, ça va euh
allez à quelques centaines de
kilomètres. À quelques à plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres. Bon, ça dépend
si entre 200 et plus. Entre 200 et plus,
hein. Brid ou pas [__] ? Bah, c'est
pour ça que je dis 200 et plus. Ouais.
Avec une demi-charge ou une grosse
charge. Non, avec 200 et plus. Tu vois,
c'est mon dernier prix. C'est mon
dernier prix. Ce sera 200 et plus, tu
auras pas plus. Voilà, c'est entre 200
et plus pour la porter. Voilà, c'est une
précision métrique, c'est en navigation
autonome, GPS, central inertie. Donc ça
veut dire que même si à la fin il est
brouillé, c'est la centrale inertie qui
prend le relais, donc il tape quand même
aux coordonnées préremplies. Voilà. Euh
et ça fait contrairement les la charge,
ça peut être quelques centaines de kilos
d'explosifs et donc ça fait pas
énormément de dégâts en fait. C'est fait
pour frapper dans la profondeur, c'estàd
très au-delà des lignes ennemis et
cibler quelque chose, un poste de
commandement. un dépôt de munition, euh
une batterie de défense solaire. Voilà,
c'est pas fait pour faire une explosion
monumentale. Par exemple, les gens ont
s'entend doute parler de la la GBU 57
qui a qui a percé Fordau. Déjà, c'est
pas un missile, c'est une bombe. Et là,
pour le coup, c'est fait pour détruire
énormément en profondeur et entrée.
Donc, c'est pas du tout ça qu'on attend
d'un missile de croisière. Frappe dans
la profondeur, très ciblé, autonome. Et
ça permet quoi ? Bah ça permet déjà de
taper des objectifs stratégiques ou
tactiques d'importance supérieure he vu
le prix du missile faut éviter de taper
un pickup avec ça quand même he parce
que c'est c'est pas rentable. Ça dépend
qui est-ce qui est dans le pickup. Oui,
tout à fait, tout à fait, tout à fait.
Mais enfin, on prendrait pas a priori
les armées ne choisiraient pas forcément
un missile de croisière. Ils choisirent
d'autres modalités, un autre vecteur et
cetera. Euh et ça permet donc d'être
tiré en standoff, c'est-à-dire que les
avions qui tirent ça n'ont pas besoin de
l'espace, ils n'ont pas besoin de
pénétrer l'espace aérien ennemi et donc
ils sont à distance de sécurité. Soit
dit en passant, la quasi totalité des
premières vagues de frappe israéliennes
a été fait en standoff. Après, ils ont
été évidemment au-dessus du territoire
iranien pour faire ce qu'ils avaient à
faire, mais une grande partie s'est
faite comme ça au moment où ils ont
cherché à acquérir la supériorité
aérienne, voire même la suprématie,
parce que là, ils ont quasiment le ciel
iranien, enfin une grosse partie du ciel
iranien euh sous leur maîtrise. Voilà,
je sais plus pourquoi on disait ça, mais
c'était le la note de bas de page,
le prisme de lecture de l'ennemi ou de
l'autre. Oui, voilà. Bon, c'est
important pour faire de la prospective.
Bah bien sûr, évidemment. Le devoir
d'empathie, il est fondamental. Pourquoi
? Parce que je te disais, il faut voir
le le réel sous différentes facettes.
C'est toujours voir le réel autrement.
Quand les Chinois voi le temps de façon
processuelle et cyclique et nous on le
voit de façon linéaire et mécanique, bon
bah déjà en fait c'est toute la vision
du monde qui change. Je ne parle pas le
chinois donc je ne fais que qu'àner ce
que disait François Julien dans ce dans
son cahier de l'erre même pas si Jing
Ping. Il il dit très bien, c'est
important ça pour la partie empathique,
il dit "En chinois, le soleil ne se dit
pas le soleil comme The Sonception que
les anglais peuvent avoir ou les
anglophones peuvent avoir que les
francophones.
Ça se dit quelque chose qui se lève à
l'est et qui se couche à l'ouest. Il y a
un côté processuel même dans cet objet
là. Donc là où on va penser catégorie
statique et queon va mettre en mouvement
de façon euh mécanique avec euh des lois
physiques, eux aussi évidemment
connaissent ces lois physiques-là, mais
eux le pensent différemment en fait. il
le pense comme quelque chose qui est
s'inscrit dans un cycle un peu hors du
temps et qui est par nature dynamique.
C'est une toute autre façon de penser le
monde. Donc évidemment qu'il faut
changer et ça je le dis prospective sur
l'Ukraine parce que là tu fais des
grands poèmes sur nos frères qui se
lèvent. Oui mais c'est la prospective
sur l'Ukraine. Donc c'est pour ça que je
te dis sur le temps long j'en reviens et
avant que tu t'étouffes je le dis quand
même l'architecture de sécurité
européenne c'est fondamental. Pourquoi ?
parce qu'un moment il va falloir
construire quelque chose avec les Russes
et enjamber la question de Poutine qui
va pas vivre encore 25 ans. Bon voilà
donc la prospective c'est 25 ans. Donc
moi si je travaille sur 25 ans, je vais
pas dire bon qu'est-ce qu'on fait demain
? Je dirais ce qu'on fait demain si on
compte préempter un scénario que l'on
aura travaillé parmi d'autres avec de
l'empathie avec de l'empathie pour une
avec de l'empathie. Ouais sur 25 ans.
Maintenant qu'on aacé le débat et pour
répondre à ta question, ce qui me semble
se profiler c'est que euh
les Américains ne sont clairement pas en
volonté de poursuivre le soutien à
l'Ukraine.
Trump que Trump Bah oui, mais enfin
Trump les Américains pendant 5 ans, tu
me demandes à court terme pendant
pendant 5 ans, c'est quand même Trump.
Bon voilà
que l'Europe bien qu'elle fasse des
efforts et qu'elle ait fournie plus de
60 % de l'aide malgré tout faire
davantage et compléter l'aide américaine
qui pourrait ne plus ne plus affluer et
qui déjà est quand même réduite ça
paraît difficile. Le rapport de force on
est en slip le rapport de force est à
l'avantage de la Russie mais il n'a
jamais cessé de l'être. Présumé on est
en slip le rapport de force entre
ukrainien et pas européen et américain
mais rapport de force européens les
Européens sont en slip. sont à la corne
sont à C'est pas si simple que ça. Je
continue. J'ai pas terminé. Donc là on
est en slip. Non, on est à la tram non
parce qu'en fait on a fait des belles
promesses d'endettement pour renforcer
le budget, prendre 60 % pas en slip, on
n'est pas à la trame. La question c'est
60 % aux États-Unis et renforcer notre
industrie de défense européenne
inexistante. Non, tu m'as pas laissé tu
m'as pas laissé poursuivre. C'est
important. Non mais mais tu as raison.
Tu as raison. Mais en fait tout dépend
de ce que l'on veut faire et de la
vision stratégique qu'on a. Je parle
même pas de la vision prospective. Si
notre vision stratégique,
c'est que la question est existentielle.
La question ukrainienne est
existentielle. Si pour l'Europe, elle
est perçue comme existentielle. Non non
non mais pourquoi ? Je dis pas qu'elle
l'. Si certains pensent qu'elle est
existentielle, alors on n fait pas
assez. C'est évident parce que si c'est
existentiel, si on est menacé sur le
plan existentiel et on reviendra sur ce
que ça peut signifier par la Russie, bah
très clairement euh très clairement non
très clairement il faudrait en faire
davantage.
Peut-être certains diraient en
cobelligérance, mener une guerre par
procuration, tout donner. Après tout, si
c'est une guerre existentielle, on peut
imaginer que l'Europe se départisse de
ses avions,
si elle veut pas les piloter elle-même,
se départissent de ses armements et puis
les donne aux Ukrainiens qui seraient
formés dessus et cetera. Ça ne suffirait
certainement pas parce qu'il faut quand
même des RH et l'Ukraine a quand même
beaucoup de mal à mobiliser. Donc, il
faudra trouver des troupes françaises,
européennes, allemande et cetera qui
sont prêts à mourir pour l'Ukraine. Mais
si c'est existentiel, il y a pas de
problème. C'est existentiel. Si c'est
existentiel, par définition, tu es prêt
à tu parles des mercenaires ou des
trouples avec un petit drapeau ? Mais
non, mais des troupes régulières des
citoyens, si c'est existentiel, si le si
le diagnostique c'est ça, alors euh on
peut légitimement se poser la question
de savoir si on en fait assez. Qu'est-ce
qu'il a dit pour existentiel ? Attends,
si c'est pas existentiel
et au départ depuis le 22, ça a pas été
considéré comme existentiel.
Bah, dans ce cas-là, euh, j'allais dire,
on fait ce qu'il faut à la mesure de nos
moyens européens. Ça veut dire qu'ils
font tous des effets des effets
d'annonce. Bah c'est pas des effets
d'annonce, c'est que tout dépend
véritablement de l'investissement
stratégique qu'on y place. Et là, je
suis pas sûr qu'il y a un consensus en
Europe là-dessus. Il y a pas consensus
pour dire que c'est existentiel. Que la
Russie menace sur le plan de la guerre
hybride, c'est évident. Ça fait euh 15
ans qu'elle nous menace sur le plan de
la guerre hybride et qu'elle agit sur le
plan de la guerri. Pas l'impression que
l'Europe c'est un peu comme un un
tyrannosaur Rex. C'est une grande gueule
avec des tout petits bras.
C'est une puissance normative, on le
sait.
Mais effectivement, il y a pas de il y a
pas de de puissance déjà. Il y a pas de
drapeau, il y a pas d'armée européenne.
Bon, il y a pas de souveraineté
européenne aujourd'hui. Il y a pas de
souveraineté européenne. Donc il y a pas
d'armée européenne. On peut prendre dans
le sens dans lequel on veut. En général,
quand il y a souveraineté, il y a armée.
Quand il y a armée, il y a souveraineté.
Bon, donc il y a pas ça. Voilà. Après,
la défense européenne, c'est l'OTAN. Et
la partie la Oui. La défense européenne,
c'est l'OTAN. Et l'Europe de la défense,
c'est le et le et et le pilier européen
de la défense, c'est l'Allemagne. Le
pilier européen, pardon. Le pilier, je
vais y arriver, excusez-moi. Le pilier
euh européen de l'OTAN, c'est l'Europe
de la défense. Quand on parle d'Europe
de la défense, de défense européenne,
c'est le pilier européen de l'alliance.
Tous les mots comptes dans ce que je te
dis là. Ça veut dire que il y a une
alliance qui ne se réduit pas aux
États-Unis. Ça c'est hyper important
parce que il y a la masse, il y a les
capacités, c'est certain et on va pas
jouer face à l'oncle Sam. Mais euh
l'OTAN, c'est aussi une grosse machine à
produire de l'interopérabilité, à de la
capacité à opérer ensemble et à bien
opérer ensemble selon des doctrines qui
sont largement plus efficaces que celles
des Russes qui ont des doctrines pour
sur le plan aérien euh déficientes. Ça
c'est ils ont un peu progressé. C'est
d'ailleurs pour ça aussi qu'ils
obtiennent les résultats qu'ils ont
obtenus. On pourrait revendre sur le
plan tactique la bataille d'advivka
notamment qui est l'antiarkmout parce
que ils ont mieux utilisé leur sous 34
et cetera. Bon bref, il y a eu des
enseignements et des choses tirées sur
la question et publié. Donc voilà, c'est
documenté mais globalement ils sont
moins bons. Donc la la question ne
fonçait pas les capacités européennes et
des Européens et ils sont en slip et ils
sauraient pas faire. Euh s'il y avait
une guerre de haute intensité euh les
Européens sauraient faire mais pas
longtemps, ça c'est certain. Ils
sauraient faire mais pas longtemps,
quelques semaines, un mois et puis après
effectivement euh la la question des
stocks de munition poserait problème. La
question des stocks de missiles poserait
problèmes. La question de
l'acceptabilité des morts poserait
problèmes, voir éventuellement des
cercueils qui reviendraient.
Effectivement, je suis pas sûr que la
population soit prête à ça. Tu connais
le le vieil ? Certains oui, d'autres
non. Tu connais le vieil adage de la
guerre économique ?
Je sais pas. Vas-y. Un chômeur coûte
plus cher qu'un mort. Bon voilà, tu donc
l'acceptabilité là, on est là on est en
plein effort de guerre. Oui mais voilà.
Donc donc là on est en plein effort de
guerre. La question de l' mort à court
terme. Bah la question de l'effort de
guerre se pose aussi en ces termes. Il y
a la question des capacités, la question
à durée puis la question de
l'acceptabilité l'acceptabilité
des pertes de son côté. Ça effectivement
c'est les points sur lesquels l'Europe
doit travailler et l'ensemble des
États-membres j'allais dire cadre en la
matière avec des armées complète
Nagerre expéditionnaire pour certaines
puissances nucléaires doivent travailler
et elles y travaillent et ça va pas se
construire effectivement dans l'année.
C'est sur on reconstruit sur 10 ou 12
ans minimum un truc qui a été
déconstruit patiemment sur 30 ans. Soit
dit en passant, il y a quand même, il
faut quand même le dire, une petite
parenthèse quand même, il y a quand même
une reprise ascendante
depuis 2017. Ça c'est un fait, tu peux
regarder les courbes. Voilà, la LPM qui
est à 413 milliards. Certes, il y a des
reports d'engagement de 8 milliards qui
sont c'est toujours regrettable parce
que quand on peut pas convertir en
crédit de paiement des autorisations
d'engagement à hauteur de 8 milliards,
forcément c'est des programmes qui sont
retardés. C'est forcément regrettable,
mais ça reste sur une courbe ascendante
et ça reste inédit depuis euh depuis un
paquet de temps, depuis les 30 années où
tout a été patiemment déconstruit.
Voilà, donc ça faut quand même le dire.
Voilà, tout peut pas se refaire en un
jour. Donc euh il faut accepter si ça
prend 10 12 ans, c'est déjà euh pas
beaucoup. Voilà. Donc non, on n'est pas
à l'OS. Mais la question centrale, c'est
est-ce que c'est existentiel au point de
mettre tout ça à contribution
par proxy, par procuration ou
directement ou est-ce que c'est pas
existentiel et auquel cas, il ne faut
pas s'étonner que l'Ukraine n'est pas
davantage d'aide, qu'elle n'en a.
Pourquoi ce serait existentiel ? Alors
existentiel, ça veut dire quoi ? Ça ça
renjoint alors déjà ça rejoint les
intérêts vitaux he existentiel, vital,
c'est quand même un peu la même chose
hein, plan lexical. Bon, les intérêts
vitaux euh en France, seul le président
euh au nom de la nation au nom de la
nation et est fondé à s'exprimer sur ce
que recouvrent les intérêts vitaux et
par nature, ils ne sont pas définis, ils
sont laissés à sa libre appréciation et
c'est là où on rentre dans ce qu'est
l'ambité stratégique. Pourquoi ? Parce
qu'en fait le nucléaire et l'emploi de
l'arme nucléaire qu'elle soit en France
océanique ou aéroporté
dépend est à la discrétion du président
en fonction de s'il estime les intérêts
vitaux menacés ou pas. Voilà. Donc il y
a un pouvoir discrétionnaire qui fait
que au nom de la nation il en il en
dispose pleinement. Est-ce qu'il laisse
une ambiguité stratégique essentielle et
ça fait partie du jeu de la dissuasion
que l'ennemi ne sache jamais quelle est
la ligne rouge sinon il s'approche de la
ligne rouge et puis il se tient juste un
petit peu à distance de la ligne rouge
pour pas prendre un coup d'électricité.
Donc ça fait partie de c'est c'est le
fonctionnement même en fait. Qu'est-ce
que font les Iraniens en ce moment ? Et
les Iraniens n'ont pas l'arme nucléaire.
C'est pas parce qu'ils ont euh 400 413
kg ou je sais plus euh un peu plus de
400 kg d'uranium enrichi d'Xit la IEA à
un peu plus de 80 %. 60. Bon,
il y aurait de l'uranium enrichi à plus
de 80 % à hauteur de 400 et quelques
kilos. à vérifier là, je vais pas je
suis pas sûr de l'ordre de grandeur,
j'en suis sûr mais l'exactitude je ne
suis pas voilà donc c'est pas du tout la
même logique. Donc pour revenir non
parce que là on a abordé un problème
important sur lequel je non il faut il
faut que je je finisse sur ce pointlà.
La question du nucléaire des intérêts
vitaux et la question existentielle
c'est le président. Une fois qu'on a dit
ça, qu'est-ce qui est stratégique et
qu'est-ce qui pourrait faire qu'un
citoyen, moi, toi, nos camarades ici
présents euh des camarades euh voilà se
sentent menacés ?
À partir du moment où ça tape sur ton
sol, que ça tape une population sur ton
sol, que ça empêche le fonctionnement du
pays, tu sais pas si c'est vital et si
le président fera cette lecture, mais tu
es sûr d'une chose, c'est que la guerre,
elle est bien chez toi. Et ça, c'est
quand même assez inadmissible. On est
quand même d'accord. Bon, est-ce que
Attends, attends, attends, attends,
attends. Laisse-moi aller plus loin.
Laisse-moi laisse-moi aller. Non, non,
mais laisse-moi aller plus loin. Là,
est-ce que la Russie nous menace de ça ?
Euh, qui est de la guerre hybride ?
C'est certain qui est de la guerre
informationnelle. C'est certain qui est
de la cyberattaque. C'est certain qui
est de l'ingérance. C'est certain qui
est de l'intimidation au niveau des
espaces aériens que l'on protège pour le
compte de l'OTAN et de nos alliés en
police du ciel, dans les pays Baltes,
au-dessus de la Pologne et cetera qui
ait des inter c'est certain, ça fait 15
ans que ça existe. Est-ce qu'on est
véritablement menacé d'une frappe russe
sur notre sol ? Moi, en tant que
citoyen, mais vraiment en tant que
citoyen, j'ai pas ce sentiment là. En
tant que prospectiviste non plus. Ça
peut être un cas de rupture et je le
prendrai comme un cas de rupture si
j'étais prospectiviste et je prétends
l'être. Pourquoi ? Parce que je me dis
si ça devait arriver, qu'est-ce qui se
passerait ? Est-ce que je suis apte à
gérer ? Est-ce que ça me met en
inconfort ? Bah oui, ça me met en
inconfort parce que ça doit pas arriver.
Pourquoi ça doit pas arriver ? parce que
le nucléaire est censé dissuader ça et
dans une certaine mesure, il le
dissuade. En effet, la question qui se
pose et ça va être un peu technique mais
je vais aller jusque là et je veux que
tu me laisses développer et je souhaite
que tu me laisses développer ce propos
là, c'est la question du contournement
du nucléaire par le bas. C'est-à-dire
qu'on va se dire "Ah ouais, mais euh
évidemment s'ils envoient des pelos sur
Paris, il va peut-être se passer quelque
chose. Mais si c'est juste à la
frontière, que ça passe de l'autre côté,
que ça touche une garnison, c'est quand
même embêtant. Mais que bon, est-ce que
c'est vraiment susceptible ? Est-ce que
le président serait susceptible d'en
faire une lecture qui soit celui des
intérêts vitaux ? Ambiguïté stratégique,
on sait pas. Mais il est possible que
l'ennemi fait devoir d'empathie se
disent que
ouais non peut-être pas quand même. Donc
là je vais essayer quand même. Et là
c'est toujours la technique des petits
pas. Il va pas commencer par sur Paris.
Voilà, il va essayer, il va s'infiltrer,
il va faire tomber un truc sur quelque
chose de stratégique et cetera. Et c'est
là-dessus que des scénarios de guerre de
grande ampleur, de haute intensité Orion
2023, l'exercice Orion 2023, c'est
fondé. C'est on écorne, on contourne un
peu la dissuasion qui nous protège du
véritable affrontement et de de
l'escalade
et du vital et de l'existentiel, mais
néanmoins, ça vient quand même nous
atteindre sur notre sol. Donc c'est un
peu entre les deux. Voilà. Et donc il y
a la question de l'épaulement,
c'est-à-dire comment on va faire pour
agir avant l'épaulement. Avant
l'épaulement. OK, c'est bon, tu
m'autorises
chez toi. Tu t'es tu t'es déjà battu
avec un SPN ? avec un un spn je n'ai pas
le souvenir. Non, nous n'avons pas été
présentés. Tu t'es déjà battu dans un
bar ?
On tu as pas trop de physique pour te
Non non, j'ai pas le souvenir. Non.
Bon là mais toi tu fais preuve
d'empathie, tu te dis bon il y a il y a
il y a Fritz là qui nous envoie des
taurus via proxy l'Ukraine. Il fait sa
danse de l'ours et sa danse des petits
pas.
En face, il y a des spetsnazes. Comme tu
t'es jamais battu avec un SPNAS, tu sais
que quand tu le regardes un peu trop
longtemps dans les yeux,
il vient vers toi et il te met un coup
de boule des enfers direct.
Et je suis pas sûr que la métaphore fait
tes petits pas, écoute-moi. Toi, tu as
fait tes petits pas de Jérôme, tu
arrives, c'est bon, vas-y. Ou il y a
Fritz qui a fait ses petits pas de
Taurus.
Tu as pas l'impression ton argumentaire
que que tu viens de me servir sur les
petits pâes, l'engagement de la doctrine
nucléaire, les intérêts vitaux ? Tu as
pas l'impression que les mecs ils
pontent ce genre de scénario, ils se
mettent pas à la place des Russes comme
ils comprennent pas les Russes qui sont
jamais tabassés avec des SP dans un bar
que tu me diras notre président, il a
pas trop le physique à avoir eu des
combats autres que avec Brigitte. Je te
laisse la liberté de ses propos. Bah il
s'est pas battu dans ses dans son avion
là. Non non, c'était c'était de la
chamaillerie. C'est de la chamaillerie.
On est loin de la prospective. Non mais
en terme de perception empathique, tu as
pas l'impression que l'Europe est en
train de créer ses futur démon ? Et
c'est précisément de ce dont je te
parle, c'est-à-dire qu'on envisage la
possibilité effectivement qu'à un moment
donné dans les scénarios, il y ait une
guerre de haute intensité qui ne soit
pas celle qui déclencherait le nucléaire
mais qui ne soit pas celle non plus qui
nous ramène à du connu où nous pourrions
faire business as usual. Et donc il faut
l'épaulement. Tu parles du cas des
Russes qui nous font les petits pas
façon. Voilà. Et donc l'épaulement est
nécessaire. Ça veut dire qu'il faut
épaissir et ça c'est ce qui est dit
d'ailleurs, il faut épaissir les forces
conventionnelles. Il faut des dizaines
d'avions de chasse en plus pour pas dire
faut faire pousser les bras et arrêter
d'avoir des grandes il faut au lieu
d'avoir d'avoir
une force à 100000 hommes et 70000
peut-être projetable au mieux de force
terrestre si c'était toute la
c'est toute la pardon la force la force
opérationnelle terrestre. Il faut
peut-être en avoir le double. Voilà,
c'est de l'épaisseur qui nous manque.
Les savoir-faire, on les a. Il faut
l'épaisseur.
Et cette épaisseur,
la question maintenant, c'est
est-ce qu'elle doit servir, j'allais
dire mais non, mais est-ce qu'elle doit
servir
à dissuader, j'allais dire
conventionnellement
l'ours d'aller plus loin ? Voilà. où
est-ce qu'elle devrait remonter en
puissance faisant être transférée vers
l'Ukraine qui est pas sortie de
l'auberge. Voilà, soit elle capitule
et à des conditions de capitulation. Non
mais je finis, je finis, je finis. Tu
peux pas me laisser là là. À des
conditions Mais oui, mais à des
conditions Oui, mais c'est fin. À des
conditions de capitulation, à des
conditions de capitulation, la paix est
demain. Mais l'idée c'est pas qu'elle
capitule. Voilà. tu as oublié l'aspect
psychologique. Et donc si elle ne
capitule pas, c'est pour longtemps. Et
donc la remontée en puissance, la
question se posera de savoir si c'est au
bénéfice notamment d'une aide renforcée
à l'Ukraine pour qu'elle puisse mener la
guerre qu'elle doit mener. Mais ça ça
veut dire qu'on considère qu'elle est
existentielle cette guerre parce qu'à ce
moment-là, on se départit de ce que l'on
reconstruit. En tout cas, on le met à
disposition d'eux. Or, je constate qu'on
n pas on s'est pas départi de
l'essentiel de nos forces. On a on a
déjà beaucoup fourni, c'est valable pour
tous les Européens, mais on n pas on n
pas transféré nos moyens en se disant
fait la guerre qui est existentielle
pour nous. Donc c'est quelque part
l'analyse stratégique, c'est qu'elle est
pas existentielle. Si je pousse ton
raisonnement, on transfert notre force
nucléaire à l'Ukraine. Ah non mais ça la
souveraineté et le nucléaire ça se
transfère pas. Or le nucléaire c'est de
la souveraineté. Mais non, mais là c'est
ça fait là on est on est là on est dans
du café du commerce parce que il
faudrait que je réexplique non mais il
faudrait que je réexplique à nos
internautes comment fonctionne le feu
nucléaire ne se transfère pas, il est
viscéralement attaché à la souveraineté.
Il est il est Non mais attention
attention la dissuasion élargie. Non
mais c'est important là, il faut être
fin sur ce qu'on dit parce qu'on peut
pas comme ça et puis il restera ça pour
la postérité. Non non euh la dissuasion
élargie. Toute la question, c'est de
reconnaître que les intérêts vitaux
français peuvent procéder d'intérêts
vitaux de nos partenaires européens. Ça
c'est la première chose. Et ça a été
dit, c'est pas il y a pas que Emmanuel
Macron qui a dit ça, c'est un leg depuis
au moins Chirak et je crois même avant
d'ailleurs à vérifier mais je crois que
c'est c'est même antérieur à Chirac,
mais c'est Chirac le premier à l'avoir
dit de façon aussi forte. La première
chose. 2è chose, je te rappelle que les
Américains font transporter la bombe par
euh la bombe euh la bombe par les les
avions euh les avions allemands euh
voilà euh au titre euh du nucléaire au
sein de l'OTAN qui est une alliance
nucléaire. Bon euh la France a choisi de
pas faire partie des plans nucléaires de
l'OTAN, mais néanmoins euh elle se elle
est puissance nucléaire et elle est
membre de l'OTAN. Donc ça renforce le
caractère nucléaire de l'alliance. Et
s'il devait y avoir dissuasion élargie,
c'est davantage sur la question du
déclenchement que sur la question des
modalités. Mais sur les modalités, il y
aurait plein de choses d'envisageable.
Mais ça, il ne m'appartient pas d'en
d'en parler, y compris comme citoyen.
Revenons à les petits pas de danse. Tu
connais le proverbe,
c'est toi qui décide de commencer à
danser avec l'ours. Mais c'est l'ours
qui décide quand la danse s'arrête.
Là, j'ai l'impression de voir un un
énorme Grizzly
avec Jérôme Fritz et Jean-Michel.
Chétif,
c'est Jean-Michel qui est fait chez chez
chez Tifre Jérôme
ou Gunter. D'accord.
Chétif. Mais je crois que qu'on
commençait à danser. Non mais là je
pense que tu as pas la bonne analyse de
l'ours. Là, tu as 12 ans de retard. Non,
mais je crois que tu as pas la bonne
analyse de l'ours parce que l'ours là,
en fait euh euh il s'y prend comme un
manche en Ukraine, hein, honnêtement.
Euh pour en arriver au résultat auquel
il en est, hein, je suis pas dans la
tête de Vladimir Poutine et et Dieu s'il
existe, m'en préserve, mais je suis à
peu près sûr d'une chose, c'est que s'il
avait su qu'il en serait là aujourd'hui
en 2025, je pense qu'il aurait réfléchi
à deux fois en 2022. Donc rien qu'à ce
titre làà c'est pas une victoire pour
l'Ukraine, mais c'est déjà une défaite
pour la Russie. Et on parlait de ces
pouvoirs qui se maintiennent en place
par la guerre. Lui typiquement si la
guerre s'arrête son régime c'est fini.
Ça c'est important aussi à savoir.
Certitude. Question. Mais tu dis que
c'est une certitude, tu partages. Bien
sûr que je partage. Tu crois que le
peuple russe, il va pas demander des
comptes économiques guerrières ? Et et a
commencé par ses affidés, ses oligarques
et tout son régime. La guerre s'arrête
sur sur cet échec. 20 % d'inflation
Russie, mais les taux d'intérêt, c'est
20 %. Oui, je sais plus que ça et euh et
d'ailleurs la directrice de la banque
centrale a plusieurs fois alerté sur le
fait que il y avait surchauffe. Donc je
te pose la question,
on est parti un petit peu
la fleur au fusil. On a vu
l'augmentation des tensions.
On se retrouve avec des Russes qui ont
une mentalité différente de nous.
On voit la mayonnaise monter monter
monter monter.
En tant que prospectiviste, tu ferais
quel type de scénario tu tuis chercher
où pour faire trouver à tout le monde la
marche arrière ?
Alors curieusement, mais c'est une
prospective sur laquelle je me suis pas
penché. Pourquoi ? Parce que la méthode
que j'essaie de d'implanter euh tu es
pas penéché dessus. dis-moi les la
prospective que tu as eu sur nos
intérêts vitaux en Ukraine. Alors, je ne
parle pas d'intérêt vitaux en Ukraine.
Là, déjà, ce mot-là, il est à proscrire
parce qu'il est connoté, il est attaché
euh il est attaché à directement à la
dissuasion et donc à des process que
j'ai amplement décrit. Va faire en
Ukraine sauf pour sauver la veuve,
l'orpholin et la démocratie pour les
petites filles ? La question
ukrainienne, c'est euh le respect du
droit international, c'est ça ? Non,
mais déjà c'est quand même pas la
moindre des choses. Voilà. Oui. Non,
mais bon euh la souveraineté des États,
c'est quand même important. Bon, voilà,
ce qui est quand même non, ce qu'on va
faire en Ukraine, c'est qu'à un moment
si tu l'arrêtes pas en face, euh bah tu
sais pas jusqu'où il peut aller. Et
qu'il aille jusqu'à Paris, à titre
personnel, j'en suis pas convaincu.
Qu'il aille jusqu'à Berlin, j'en suis
pas convaincu non plus. mais qu'il aille
éventuellement dans les pays baltes en
Pologne et qu'éventuellement la Moldavie
et qu'il revienne faire un petit tour en
Geéorgie. Ça ça me semble tout à fait
possible. Alors après l'Estonie
l'Estonie oui. Bah les pays Baltes. J'ai
dit tous les pays Baltes hein. Bah il y
a trois Ouais. Ah il me pose des
questions de cours en plus il est dur.
Il y a combien de zé un milliard ? Bon
non mais voilà. A combien de zé 1
milliard un 9 ? Non mais j'ai vu George
marcha
je suis pas assez assez jeune pour ne
pas connaître George Marcha.
Voilà. Bon bref euh donc
ce que l'on va faire c'est il faut
éviter en fait c'est du containment,
c'est éviter que ça aille plus loin.
Donc dire que ça ira sur les membres.
Oui. C'est c'est contenir en fait ce qui
était une menace hybride et ce qui
semble s'agréger et se consacrer en une
menace proprement militaire. Voilà. et
euh ne pas répéter l'erreur de 2014 où
en 2014 bah tout le monde a laissé faire
collectivement. Et c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça avec aussi un certain nombre de
théâtres où on a laissé faire en Syrie
euh que sans doute Vladimir Poutine
s'est dit bon bah pardon pour le terme
mais ça va passer crème. Voilà et et ça
aurait pu passer crème funeste erreur
parce que ça n'a pas été le cas et
encore une fois s'il avait su que ça
finirait comme ça ou qu'on en serait là
il le ferait pas. Donc déjà ça c'est
quand même pas une mince victoire. Alors
ça suffit pas effectivement à faire en
sorte que l'Ukraine retrouve son
intégrité dans le Donbas et encore moins
en en Crimé. Mais ça suffit à lui faire
passer l'envie d'aller plus loin. Et le
fait d'avoir identifié gu information
oblige le fait d'avoir identifié et de
clamer le fait que sa menace pourrait
nous paraître existentielle même si
peut-être elle ne l'est pas. C'est
partagé comme diagnostic mais même si
peut-être elle ne l'est pas. Ça suffit à
ce qu'il sache que de toute façon on l'a
bien vu et qu'on le laissera pas aller
là où il aurait pu aller si toutefois il
avait attaqué moins fort, c'est-à-dire
les Pays-Baltes, la la Roumanie, la
Pologne, la Geéorgie, la Moldavie via la
Transnitrie et cetera. Donc, j'allais
dire de ce point de vue-là, sur le plan
des équilibres entre guillemets, c'est
déjà gagné. Mais euh c'est gagné,
j'allais dire pour l'équilibre et
l'architecture de sécurité européenne à
venir plus tard après l'après-Poutine.
Mais c'est vrai que pour les pauvres
ukrainiens euh bah euh il reste au
milieu du gay parce que le Donbas
il en a pris, il a consolidé quand même
ses gains un peu plus que ce qu'il avait
en 2014 hein, il a un peu plus de 20 %
autour de 20 %, il avait moins avant.
Donc il a cette langue de terre qui fait
la continuité territoriale autour de la
mer d'Azovof qui se trouve donc
privatisé avec euh la Crimée qui est
bien possédé même si c'est parfois
contesté avec des missiles taurus, avec
euh des missiles de croisière. Euh euh
la France a fourni aussi des missiles de
croisière donc elle s'est départie de de
capacités qui sont euh importantes. Elle
a donné des mirages de 1000 donc il y a
eu des gros efforts de fait. Oui, mais
il y a eu des grosses c'est pas rien de
donner des avions de chasse. Et de C'est
pas celui qui a le réacteur qui se
plante tout le temps ? Non, c'est un
avion qui fonctionne très bien. Très
bien. Le le celui le le marin, c'est un
avion qui fon Non non, c'est un mirage
de 1000 de l'armée de l'air et de
l'espace. Enfin, pas un d'ailleurs,
entre 5 et 12. Voilà, on regardera dans
les sources ouvertes. Entre 5 et 12.
Voilà. Et donc, on fait avec 5 et 12
avions. Bah, on fait plus qu'avec rien
déjà. Non, on fait plus qu'avec rien. Et
quand ça s'additionne à la flotte de
F16, lesquels sont interopérables, euh
bah ça permet de résister. Ça permet pas
de renverser le rapport de force. Le
rapport de force, il est à l'avantage de
la Russie. En tant qu'analyste pourquoi
Poutine sur le terrain ? En tant
qu'analyste, pourquoi Poutine n'a pas
fait la guerre à l'américaine ou à
l'israélienne ? Mais parce qu'il sait
pas la faire tout simplement. C'est
doctrinal. C'est ça. C'estd que pour toi
Poutine pour toi passer le bulldozer
faut 300 de cuit et pour faire de la
l'intégration des Mais il faut faut
avoir une doctrine construite pour le
faire. C'est pas la même philosophie.
C'est pas la eux effectivement c'est le
rouleau compresseur. C'est l'attrition
des hommes. Est-ce qu' Est-ce qu'il a
fait le rouleau compresseur ? Bah il a
tenté quand il va à l'assaut, il perd
des dizaines de c'est 1000 hommes par
jour l'Ukraine et pas que du côté
c'est 1000 hommes par jour. Donc quand
il lance des quand il lance des assauts
quand la Russie lance des assauts sur le
front est euh
c'est c'est des hommes qui sont perdus
en masse à chaque fois. C'est pas du
tout la logique otanienne.
Euh la maîtrise de l'air, la supériorité
aérienne préalable, ça c'est le mantra
hein, c'est le c'est l'alpha et l'oméga
de la guerre othanienne telle que la mè
d'ailleurs. Font pas partie de l'OTAN,
mais ils font de la même façon les
Israéliens. C'est supériorité aérienne
et quand on peut suprématie aérienne. Et
une fois qu'on a fait le ménage comme
ça, on peut taper et une fois qu'on peut
taper, après éventuellement on vient au
sol ou on vient pas au sol. Évidemment
euh la partie aérienne peut-être
confortée par toi, c'est une erreur qui
soit partie direct au sol. Ah ben non,
mais c'est pas une erreur, c'est c'est
évidemment c'est voué à l'échec. C'est
voué à l'échec. Attention, c'est voué à
l'échec si tu rencontres une résistance
euh telle que celle qu'il a rencontré.
Et la résistance qu'il a rencontré,
c'est au départ effectivement l'Ukraine.
Et si l'Ukraine avait pas été capable
d'offrir cette résistance là, elle
aurait jamais été soutenue, hein, ça
c'est certain. Elle elle était peut-être
soutenue avant.
Si elle avait pas démontré cette
capacité à résister euh elle aurait
jamais eu le soutien américain et celui
des Européens. Ça c'est c'est certain.
Elle a montré sa capacité à résister.
Elle a créé elle a créé une force
d'entraînement de proxy. Elle a créé une
force d'entraînement. Ça peut-être aussi
mais elle a créé une force
d'entraînement mais la vaillance lui est
propre là pour le coup. Voilà. Et
derrière, attends, je finis. Et
derrière, elle a été soutenue à 60 % par
les Européens, le reste par les
Américains avec des capacités critique
en matière de renseignement notamment et
elle peut résister et elle a toujours
résisté et ça a été toujours dans le
plan des Américains annoncés comme tel
permettre quasiment annoncé comme tel au
moins par les les éléments du Pentagone
si ce n'est par le président lui-même,
si même Biden l'avait dit mais voilà
permettre à l'Ukraine de résister et et
c'est repris aussi par les Européens.
Personne n'a jamais parlé de victoire.
euh et d'une victoire. Alors si la
victoire c'est permettre de résister et
de contenir et de s'en sortir le mieux
possible, c'est une victoire. Et le fait
de d'infliger une défaite stratégique à
la Russie qui n'est pas arrivé à faire
mieux au bout de 3 ans, c'est une
victoire. Mais si la victoire c'est
reprendre les territoires, la Crimée et
le Donbas, personne n' parlé de cette
victoire là. Et si elle a résisté, c'est
grâce à cette aide. Suis bien, si je te
suis bien, l'Ukraine résiste tant
qu'elle peut, du mieux qu'elle peut, le
plus vaillamment qu'elle peut. La Russie
se casse les dents dessus. Scénario
numéro 1, elle se pète tous les chicot.
Et ensuite nous, on va s'occuper des
Russes quand on sera réarmé dans 12 ans.
Non, on va pas s'occuper des Il y a pas
lieu de s'occuper des Haus. On n pas en
guerre contre la Russie. Si la Russie
reste là où elle est, il y aura jamais
de problème.
J'ai jamais dit ça. J'ai dit qu'il
fallait être en capacité. Il fallait
être en capacité sur 10 ans parce que ça
va pas se reconstruire demain. Sur 10
ans, il faut être capable comme un SP.
Il faut être capable sur 10 ans 12 ans
de reconstruire une épaisseur
conventionnelle pour éviter voilà pour
qu'il y ait l'épaulement nucléaire et
que ça lui passe l'envie d'aller plus
loin. Donc là mais toi avec ton empathie
d'analyste
bon je me mets dans la tête de Popov
prier
ou là on est en train de se casser tous
les chicots là.
Ils sont en train de se réarmer comme
des dingots. Il y a il y a Olaf qui va
mettre 1000 milliards de dettes. Mais
1000 milliards quand même. Il va faire
plein plein plein de petits taurus. Il
va se moderniser avec tout plein plein
plein de drones d'OP à l'intelligence
artificielle.
Qualité dodge qualitate
en face. Tuas Spnas Popov premier. Tu
crois qu'il va se dire quoi ? Bon alors
il se pète il se pète une incisive, il
se pète une molaire. Bon une fois, deux
fois trois fois.
Il lui reste tr quat chico, il regarde
son arsenal, son économie est en
surchauffe. Tu crois que ça va terminer
comment ? Ça va terminer que qu'est-ce
que tu veux qu'il fasse ? Et ben premier
va faire bon alors les Allemands, ils
commencent, il va envoyer les 5000 têtes
et il va nitrater le monde entier. Bon
ben alors voilà bah terminé. Une pompe à
essence et une pompe à essence et du
nucléaire. Exemple va faire un exemple.
Il y a que ça. Qu'est-ce que tu veux
qu'il fasse un exemple ? C'est pas parce
que il a envie de faire et que il
rongera son frin que scénario. Est-ce
que c'est un exemple est-ce que c'est un
scénario qui a été envisagé par les
Européens ? Quel scénario ? Un exemple.
C'est quoi un exemple ? Tu as Popof
premier qui regarde son arsenal qui
regarde ses serait quoi l'exemple ? Il
se farcit au-dessus de la mer noire un
petit pétard nucléaire en frappe
stratégique. Non mais là écoutez les
gars, le premier qui bouge, il s'en
prend une. Non mais il y a là il y a il
y a beaucoup de choses qui c'est quoi un
pétard en frappe stratégique ?
Ouais mais un pétard nucléaire en
satégique audessus de la mer ça bon il
fait un joli champignon pour les
émissions de télé du vendredi soir pour
que tous les commentaires de plateau
télé attends attends attends je t'arrête
tout de suite. Euh il premier scénari
une capitale. Non mais attends premier
scénario alors capitale. Bon voilà on on
élimine. Voilà premier scénario euh en
fait c'est du suicide. De quoi ? premier
sé faire péter un autour de la mer noir.
Suicide suicide politico stratégique et
suicide tout court. Voilà, j'espère que
tu as raison mais il il l'a pas fait
alors que il s'est retrouvé dans une
situation
au au point que et là pour le coup je
m'inscris en faux au point que certains
n'ont pas arrêté de nous dire mais vous
voyez bien que ça menace nucléaire c'est
rodo nucléaire c'est du flanc et qu'on
pourrait aider l'Ukraine beaucoup plus
et qui bougerait pas plus. Là pour le
coup, je dis votre paris il est fort les
enfants parce que c'est pas certain. Si
pour le coup parce que si la guerre elle
est pas existentielle pour nous, elle
l'est pour lui hein, pour le régime et
pour le pays parce que le pays il est
exangue donc on sait pas s'il peut
continuer encore. Oui mais il va pas
continuer 10 ans comme ça hein. Il y a
des p de l'économie. Voilà il va il va
pas continuer 10 ans comme ça. Il y a
des p de l'économie entièrement
entièrement sinistrée. L'inflation tu en
as parlé, les taux d'intérêt, tu en as
parlé. L'économie de guerre c'est bien
mais du coup il n'y a plus que ça et
puis concrètement il tape déjà dans les
stocks de la guerre froide. Donc la
rupture économique est totale. À quel
niveau ? En Oub. Oui, en OBU. Tout ce
qui avait été accumulé pendant la guerre
froide. Voilà. Donc euh si tu veux dans
une situation euh qui pour le coup est
existentielle et bien qu'étant pas mis
en échec mais en échec stratégique parce
qu'encore une fois c'est pas brillant sa
situation euh il ne va pas jusqu'à le
faire et lorsqu'il a voulu parce que ça
a été et on l'a su hein ça c'est aussi
c'est dans l'ouvert hein la la CAL l'a
dit il avait envisagé le nucléaire
tactique dit tactique alors il y a
beaucoup de conneries autour de la
nucléaire tactique. Ça c'est vraiment le
la comment
c'est vraiment la le ah la formule la
formule à proscrire parce que c'est
connoté, ça dit des choses, on pourrait
en parler des heures, on pourrait faire
un sink curview entre le nucléaire
tactique et le nucléaire préstratégique
et le nucléaire stratégique. Bon,
parlons du nucléaire et c'est pas la
puissance du nucléaire qui fait le
tactique ou le stratégique. Ça va bien
d'autre chose. C'est quelle cible qui le
tire à quel moment ? Mais enfin, si on
s'entend sur le fait que le nucléaire
tactique, mais c'est une connerie, mais
disons quand même, que le nucléaire
tactique, ça va être la puissance
d'Hiroshima, donc 10 kilonn, 12
kilonnes, on s'entend à peu près
là-dessus. Voilà, ça fait exception. Euh
rien que ça euh bah les Chinois n'ont
pas voulu, les Chinois ont pressuré pour
que ça ne se fasse pas, les Américains
l'ont su
qu'effectivement il avait été à deux
doigts de l'envisager. Bon donc en fait
euh même dans la situation calamiteuse
dans laquelle il est, il n'y a pas
recours. Donc il va pas se dire tiens,
il sait bien qu'on cherche pas à
l'attaquer.
Il sait bien qu'en fait l'extension de
l'OTAN, c'est il est il est il est pas
convaincu de sa connerie. En fait, il
sait bien que l'extension de l'OTAN,
c'est un narratif qu'il prend en compte
pour expliquer qu'il est dans une
situation de victime et cetera alors
qu'il y ait une volonté éventuellement
impérialiste de retrouver un certain
glac, se sentir un peu injustement poncé
par des pays qui préfèrent rejoindre
l'Union européenne et l'OTAN. Et soit
dit en passant, je pense qu'on vit mieux
aux États-Unis en Europe qu'en Russie,
mais je referme la parenthèse. Peut-être
à part Saint-Pétersbourg et à Moscou et
encore si on fait partie des classes
laer classe. Sinon pour le reste, ça
doit pas être ça doit pas être rose tous
les jours. Mais je referme la
parenthèse. Donc on comprend pourquoi
certains pays préfèrent venir en UE ou
être accroché à l'oncle Sam que qu'à les
côtés russes. Mais voilà. Bon donc il
sait bien que ce narratif il est
fallacieux. Oui l'autant m'attaque. Oui
l'autant me pousse. Il y avait une
entente selon laquelle il dépasserait
pas. Ils reprendraient pas les pays, ils
avanceraient pas sur les pays balles,
sur les et cetera. Bon, cette entente,
elle engage que Poutine. C'est pas du
tout sûr que ça a été dit et cetera et
cetera. Mais tout ça pour dire quoi ?
Qu' oui, non mais non, c'est pas non,
c'est qu'il est pas dupe de son propre
discours. Et donc, n'étant pas dupe de
son propre discours, euh il va pas pour
des conditions moindres que celles qu'il
a déjà connu et où il a été finalement
empêché et où il s'est ravisé. euh faire
un exemple pour tous, sachant que les
pays en question euh n'ont aucune
véléité. On va pas prendre la Russie,
c'est pas c'est je crois pas que ce soit
l'objectif des Européens. Je crois pas
que ce soit l'objectif des Européens
hein. Avant le début de la guerre euh au
CID ou à l'école de guerre, il y avait
des échanges euh d'armée histoire de
comprendre les autres.
Il y avait des échanges comme Mais ça a
toujours court. Il y a toujours soit
toujours des Russes chez nous.
faudrait regarder dans les dans les
armées et à l'école de guerre si c'est
le cas. À mon avis, je ne pense pas.
Voilà, je ne pense pas mais je laisse
les gens vérifier. Maintenant, des
échanges, il y en a il y en a pas mal
hein.
Tu verrais quel pays au milieu de tout
ça pour négocier la paix ?
Ah, les pays les pays européens sont
jugés partis, même si la diplomatie,
j' dire bah son jugé parti puisquon est
Non, non, la diplomatie même si bah on
peut on peut pas dire oui, pardon, on
peut pas dire que l'Europe
ne cherche pas à avoir un rôle
diplomatique dans les différents
conflits du monde. Donc, on ne peut
jamais mettre l'Europe l'Europe à part
lorsqu'il s'agit de rechercher la paix.
Mais dans les pays évidemment qu'on voit
en premier lieu, il y a évidemment la
Turquie. Euh la Turquie euh a envie a
envie à sou le peu
euh s'agissant euh s'agissant de l'Iran
et Israël euh Erdogan avait euh monté
une réunion euh qui devait se tenir
lundi dernier, je crois ou lundi
d'avant. lundi d'avant et qui a à chopé.
Bon voilà euh il a un rôle de médiateur
étant à la fois dans l'OTAN, étant pas
loin des Russes, même si c'est quand
même une imitié forte, une inimitié
forte. Il y a cette ce caractère hybride
en fait hein de des Turcs euh qui leur
permet de se positionner effectivement
comme parmi les Chinois aussi peuvent
avoir un rôle sont peu partis non ?
Oui, mais il temporisent quand même. Ils
temporisent, il s'accommode.
Il s'accommode plus qu' alors les
Chinois, ils s'en accommode. Est-ce que
tu as pas l'impression il s'en
accommodent et ils savent en tirer
parties ? Voilà. Est-ce que tu as pas
l'impression quand on stratège analyse
prospectiviste
qu'en fait l'Europe, les Ukrains, on est
un peu les dindons de la farce.
On est en train de se faire fracasser
notre économie, on est en train de se
faire fracasser nos partenaires, nos
nos échanges. On est en train de
s'épuiser dans une guerre qui est
peut-être la nôtre ou peut-être pas la
nôtre, que ça renforce les Chinois, que
ça renforce les États-Unis et que nous
ça nous neutralise pour les 25
prochaines années.
C'est-à-dire que la voie européenne est
en train de se faire dépesser
et qu'en fait on n'est même pas en train
de s'en rendre compte
et qu'on voit des beaux prospectivistes
faire des des plans sur la comète alors
qu'ils ont dans le caca. Ils sont même
pas au courant. Quelle est la différence
entre tous les pays que tu m'as cité et
l'Europe ? Il y a une différence majeure
qui fait que déjà c'est que nous on n
pas de matière première et qu'on a pas
d'énergie. Non mais je vais dire on a
des cerveaux
ça pourrait largement suffire. Le sujet
il est pas là. On a des cerveaux. Le
sujet on a pas d'énergie mais on a des
cerveaux. Non, on n pas d'énergie mais
on a du nucléaire. Non. Euh euh on a du
nucléaire pour certains mais pas tous.
On a des cerveaux, ça c'est certain. Et
et parmi les plus brillants. Et parmi
les plus brillants. Et je rappelle quand
même que les États-Unis ont jamais été
faits que par essentiellement que par
des Européens quand même pour justice.
Voilà, c'est possible. Mais ça forge le
caractère. Les repris de justice. Ouais,
ça forge le caractère. Tu parles ça
parce qu'on a eu 137 ministres qu'on a
né. Non, je dis je non non, je dis ça
parce que tu sembles dire depuis le
début que la mauvaise graine c'est ce
qu'il faut pour pouvoir la mauvaise
graine Ben si au début au tout tout
début de l'entretien mais c'est pas le
sujet. Voilà. Oui. Le bad boy. Le bad
boy. Bah c'est ça la mauvaise graine.
Voilà. Bon mais c'est c'est à la rigueur
dire mauvaise herbe parce que tu sais
pas la préparer. Voilà. Mais c'est c'est
tu sais pas la manger. Ah bah la
préparer. On est dans l'éducation. On
revient à ce que je disais. Tu vois que
tu vois que c'est la question de
l'éducation, faire pousser la graine. On
en revient toujours à ça. Ça pas
l'impression qu'on est en train de se
faire dépesser. Je Qu'est-ce qui
différencie ? C'est que l'Europe est pas
souveraine. C'est ça le problème de
fond. Alors soit c'est toujours pareil,
il faut jamais rester au milieu du gay.
Soit on considère qu'il faut vraiment un
projet européen. C'est toujours pareil,
il faut savoir ce qu'on veut. Mais on
sait ce qu'on veut quand on a formulé
les choses. On les a formulé quand on a
fait de la prospective. Mais une vraie
prospective, c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce que
l'on veut ? Est-ce que entre européens,
on veut une Europe souveraine et auquel
cas il y a des abandons de souveraineté
nationaux, il faut l'accepter. Voilà.
Mais non, mais c'est c'est une
possibilité. Et effectivement après, on
a la taille critique au niveau
technologique
sur le plan de du capital humain, sur le
plan du du capital économique.
L'économie, c'est déjà la plus grosse
économie du monde et cetera et cetera.
Bon, et l'accès aux ressources, ça se
sécurise. C'est je dire c'est presque
même pas le sujet en fait. Voilà. Euh
ressources, ça sécurise, ça se sécurise
bien sûr, mais si tu as la tête
critique, il y a pas de problème. Si un
moment donné Taïwan est pris par la
Chine, là
c'est vrai que l'Indo-acifique
l'Indo- Pacifique l'Europe va avoir du
mal à peser toute seule et les États
membres pris individuellement vont avoir
de voir vont avoir pardon du mal à peser
tout seul. Et donc là effectivement, ce
sera encore la question américaine.
Comment se positionnent les Américains ?
Est-ce qu'on va être sous leur parapluie
ou pas ? Est-ce qu'on va participer à ou
pas et cetera et cetera. Toujours les
sans piternelles questions. Bon voilà.
Donc est-ce qu'on veut une Europe
souveraine ou pas ? Si on veut pas ça et
qu'on veut agir en tant que puissance
moyenne et rester puissance moyenne,
c'est tout à fait là. Mais c'est un
choix de société et ça ça se débat, ça
se ça se construit avec nos jeunes, avec
ceux qui qui mangeront la soupe qu'on va
leur préparer. Voilà. Et c'est ça la
prospective au sens plein d'humot. Bah
si on veut ça après, faut pas vouloir
peser sur les chiqu mondial de la même
façon. C'est pas possible. la grenouille
peut pas se faire aussi grosse que le
bœuf mais c'est un choix, j'allais dire
c'est le choix au départ. Voilà, quant à
ce qui se passe avant ce choix-là, et
ben du coup tout en est, j'allais dire
totalement totalement euh totalement
comptable, totalement asservi.
effectivement, n'étant pas une puissance
stratégique et militaire, n'étant qu'une
puissance économique, bah l'Europe
effectivement se retrouve dans une
situation où elle a pas le poids et la
liberté de manœuvre des Américains qui
quand même est malgré tout emputé, mais
qui a quand même rappelé qu'il savaient
être les gendarmes du monde bah pas plus
tard que cette semaine, malgré tout,
avec des Israéliens qui étaient quand
même très véléitaires s'agissant du du
régime. C'est pas fini, mais enfin
voilà. Euh évidemment, on n' pas cette
capacité euh qu'à la Chine à euh à
pouvoir euh se développer euh d' dire
sur des technologies là, on voit bien la
la capacité de rattrapage de la Chine en
matière euh de technologie et de avant
ils avaient pas l'innovation de
production d'ingénieur. Oui.
D'innovation. Voilà. Le rattrapage en
matière d'innovation. Sais combien la
Chine produit d'ingénieurs par an ? Non,
j'ai pas l'ordre de grandeur. Tu sais
combien la France produit d'ingénieur
par ? Oui. Non, mais voilà. Mais là et
la taille critique, on reparle de la
taille critique mais si on parlait de
l'Europe, ce serait un tout autre sujet.
Mais on peut pas vouloir l'Europe. On
peut pas vouloir l'Europe. L'Israël,
c'est Israël, c'est 9 millions
d'habitants, c'est ça ?
Euh oui, une dizaine de milliers une
dizaine de millions d'habitants. Oui.
L'Iran, c'est combien de millions
d'habitants ? 90, pas loin de 100, donc
10 fois moins. Oui, oui, oui, oui.
Ils ont maîtrisé le ciel aérien iranien
là. Donc, oui, mais là pour le coup euh
pour le coup pourquoi les Ianiens, ils
veulent leur bombe atomique ? Mais pour
le coup là, on n'est pas là la question
de la masse fait pas sens parce que
on n'est pas dans un rapport qui la
masse ou la volonté. Il y a il y a la
masse, il y a la vol enfin là c'est
c'est un tout autre sujet en fait. Là
c'est une question de non c'est un tout
autre sujet parce que le niveau
capacitaire en fait Israël est un OVNI.
C'est-à-dire que un si petit pays avec
autant de capacité militaires, mais
c'est parce que c'est un pays qui s'est
construit sur la guerre, après la guerre
et sur la guerre, en fait, il est consub
consubstantiellement en guerre. Voilà.
et son innovation et son économie est
tirée par la guerre avec le soutien
d'effectif des Américains, avec la
supéri la supériorité qualitative dans
la région. Quand tu quand les les pays
de France et de Navar et et d'ailleurs
euh européens exporte exporte dans la
région du Moyen-Orient, c'est toujours
en s'assurant que Israël conserve la
supériorité qualitative. Tu peux pas
fournir ce que tu veux au Qatar. Voilà,
faut faut négocier avec les Américains
et cetera parce qu'ils s'assurent que
Israël est toujours donc voilà c'est un
OVNI et donc là la masse quand tu as à
faire un OV Catard des des bouteilles
des bouteilles en plastique avec des
petits capuchons et des chargeurs
universels. C'est ça pour pour le Qatar.
Nous on va vendre ça c'est tranquille
c'est inoffensif. Non mais au Qatar la
France a fourni des rafales quand même
avec un certain nombre de matériels qui
vont avec. Ta prospective qu'un rafal
soit fait euh des inguis en Inde ? Du
moins, c'est c'est en Inde qui s'est
fait des inguis. Non, c'est au Pakistan,
un rafal indien avec un immatriculation.
C'était quoi son immatriculation ? 00 1
2 Non, j'ai j'ai pas le C'est un vecteur
nucléaire le rafale. Bah, c'est un
vecteur mixte parce qu'il peut
transporter la bombe nucléaire bien sûr
et il peut transformer transporte du des
de l'armement conventionnel. Tu as pas
fait peur qu'il se fasse dzinguer par un
avion chinois qui coûte 10 fois moins
cher. Non mais ça c'est c'est Attends,
c'est c'est pas ou c'est parce que c'est
un pilote indien. Non mais c'est pas le
sujet de savoir s'il transporte là il
transportait pas du Alors c'est quoi
c'est quoi ta question en fait ? C'est
quoi la question ? Est-ce que ça te fait
peur que le le vecteur nucléaire aérien
français soit obsolète ? En fait pour
avoir peur il faut savoir exactement ce
qui s'est passé et pourquoi il est
tombé. Or, c'est toi qui dit il faut
connaître l'effet jusqu'au fond et pas
les bruits de chiotes qui sortent à
droite à gauche. Et ben à ce jour, on
sait pas exactement. Voilà, on sait pas
ou on veut pas voir. Non, pour l'instant
on ne sait pas exactement les raisons
pour lesquelles il est tombé. Qu'un
avion soit perdu en tant que tel dans un
affrontement haute intensité, ça n'a
rien d'extraordinaire. Non mais même
même il peut prendre un pelot mais il
peut prendre un pelv il peut y avoir
plein de choses en tant que tel quand il
y a un engagement de haute intensité
plus de quasiment 200 avions je crois
été mobilisés sur cette affaire donc
c'est quand même une des opérations
aériennes parmi les plus grandes avec ce
qu'on connaît dernièrement Israël Iran
euh alors l'Ukraine les avions il pas
tant que ça le problème de l'Ukraine et
j'avais pas eu le temps de le dire et
c'est ce qui fait qu'ils sont dans dans
cet enlisement c'est que aucune des deux
parties n'a la supériorité aérienne.
Aucune des deux parties fait comme dans
le bouqua otien. Et ben voilà où ils en
sont. Alors les Ukrainiens, on comprend,
ils ont pas la capacité.
Voilà, mais les Russes ils devraient
l'avoir mais ils n'ont ni la capacité,
enfin ils n'ont ni le matériel ni la
doctrine. Donc ils n'ont pas les
capacités. La capacité et la réunion des
deux. Ah mais non mais il y a longtemps
qu'il leur employé s'il savaient le
faire. Ils ont appris de leurs erreurs.
Ils font un usage de des avions de
chasse polyvalent un peu meilleur que ce
qu'il faisait mais euh mais pas et pas
beaucoup plus en fait. Voilà. Est-ce que
tu as trois bouquins à conseiller à
notre communauté ou est-ce que tu as un
sujet que tu souhaiterais aborder avant
de conseiller trois bouquins ? Un sujet
qu'on a pas on a pas aborder. Alors le
le le prochain bouquin que j'espère
sortir qui sera le sujet le sujet
d'abord le sujet qui sera en gros le
sujet qu'on a pas abordé. Alors le sujet
qu'on alors qu'on a pas abordé euh
le sujet qu'on a pas abordé. Tuis parler
de l'évolution de l'homme. Oui, c'est
c'est important parce qu'en fait euh et
de la femme. Oui. Alors, merci
infiniment de revenir sur ce sujet-là.
Oui, évidemment. Et de la femme
anthropologie, c'est important parce que
euh dans le prochain bouquin que je
sortirai qui montrera la méthode par le
menu avec des exemples aux éditions.
J'attends de voir encore. Voilà,
j'attends de voir. Mais il y aura une
bonne édition, ça c'est point
vétérinaire. Hm. Point vétérinaire. Non
non non. pas point vétérinaire, point
une édition qui va bien. Voilà, ce sera
un complément du premier bouquin et ça
montrera la méthode telle qu'on la
pense, telle qu'on peut la dérouler par
le menu et l'exemplifier. Et sur
l'exemple justement, il y aura un
exemple sur l'évolution anthropologique.
Et pourquoi elle est intéressante
celle-ci ? C'est pas unissement pour le
plaisir de la masturbation
intellectuelle.
C'est aussi un parce que il me semble
qu'il y a des signaux faibles qui en
attestent. Des signaux précurseurs ?
Oui, précurseur faible qui mérite d'être
Ça veut pas dire que signaux faible ça
va se produire. Ça veut dire qu'il y a
des choses qui si on y porte attention
pourrait faire en sorte qu'on pourrait
les développer et faire en sorte que ça
advienne et il y a un côté
autoréalisateur. Mais donc intéressant
de le voir et intéressant de le faire.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'en fait si l'homme
change, sa perception du monde change et
nombre de sujets que l'on a à traiter
pourraient être traduits différemment.
Et en fait, il y a énormément de
solutions auxquelles on pense
aujourd'hui qui seront peut-être en fait
complètement caduc au moment où elles
devront arriver. Alors, je dis pas qu'on
va abolir la guerre, attention, je dis
pas qu'on va abolir la finitude des
ressources et le fait qu'on est sur une
terre qui nous oblige à faire une petite
cure d'amaigrissement ou à nous
entretuer ou à sécuriser les
approvisionnements stratégiques, surtout
quand on est européen, qu'on a des idées
mais pas de pétrole.
Mais ce que je dis c'est que il y aura
certainement des solutions qui nous
semblent être celles qu'il faut
forcément fourcher aujourd'hui et il n'y
a que celle-là et tout le monde se met
autour comme un totem voilà avec des
signaux de fumée pour savoir si c'est
oui ou si c'est non. Alors qu'en fait le
sujet dans 5 ou 10 ans ce sera même plus
ça. La question du travail par exemple
modification anthropologique
modification du rapport au travail et de
la question de la production des
richesses. Qu'est-ce que seront les
richesses véritablement dans 5 ou 10 ans
? Est-ce que seront les mêmes
qu'aujourd'hui ? c'est pas certain. Il
risque d'y avoir des ruptures très
fortes. En tout cas, là pour le coup, ça
vaut le coup de les envisager. Voilà.
Alors, il y a les tendances, il y a
voilà, ça c'est effectivement ça veut
pas dire que à court terme, encore une
fois, il faut dire bon bah à court
terme, on s'en fout parce qu'on engemble
les problèmes. Non, il faut jouer et
vivre dans plusieurs temporalités. Mais
là, mon propos dans ce bouquin, ce sera
de faire de la prospective à l'horizon
de aller d'une génération et donc de
penser les choses. Qu'est-ce que
pourrait être l'homme dans une
génération ? Comment il va voir le monde
? Comment il pourrait voir le monde ? et
quels seraient les vrais problèmes qui
se poserent à lui parce qu'alors c'est
dès maintenant qu'il faudra préampter
les choses et s'inscrire dans le
scénario qui nous semblera souhaitable,
désirable et le préhempter. Et c'est là
qu'il faut être offensif parce qu'à ce
moment-là, il faudra gagner le cœur et
les esprits, produire les récits,
produire des récits qui, comme tous les
récits depuis que l'homme et homme, sauf
s'il devait y avoir une modification
anthropologique majeure qui qui change
ça, euh comme tous les récits qui
portent, ce sont toujours des récits
mythologiques. C'est ça. C'est le mythe
qui porte, c'est l'écriture mythique. Et
le mythe, il y a des mythes dans la
silicone vallée aujourd'hui qui n'ont
rien à qui n'ont rien à envier. Il en
faudrait il en faudrait et ne pas que
sur les chandailles, voilà, et et qui
n'ont rien à envier ces mythes là au
mythes au mythes d'Adam et Ève, au mythe
de DIP, au mythe d'Icar, je resterai sur
le myth d'Icar par exemple. Voilà, on on
en profite pour dire à notre communauté,
abonnez-vous sur notre compte Twitter,
vous qui nous regardez sur YouTube,
soutenez-nous sur Tipi, activez la
petite cloche, préparez-vous à à une
prochaine rentrée Tony Truante. On a
quelques comptes à régler cette année.
Nous aussi, on va sortir un bouquin et
ce sera pas
ce sera fait comme il faut.
Euh est-ce que tu as trois conseils à
Est-ce que tu as un conseil à pour les
jeunes générations et trois bouquins
pour notre communauté ? Trois bouquin et
un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Alors, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, si je peux me permettre,
c'est
intéressez-vous à ce qui va se passer au
mois de septembre, au mois de décembre
et au mois de mars. Ça c'est concret et
c'est tout de suite. Oui, mais c'est
concret et c'est tout suit. En temps de
météo, en tant que quoi ? En tant que
tous, je t'ai bien dit que septembre, il
y a quoi ? septembre, il y aura euh il y
aura un premier atelier de prospective
qui va toucher les jeunes sur des un
sujet qui va forcément les intéresser.
Financé par qui ?
Et tout le monde pourra s'asseoir. Quel
est l'objectif ? Faire de la prospective
et sensibiliser les jeunes à la
prospective et alors montrer des
méthodes sur des sujets qui peuvent les
intéresser. Le niveau intellectuel
minimum. Mais mais les citoyens, tous
les citoyens sont les bienvenus. Tout le
monde doit parler anglais et tout le
monde doit faire de l'informatique et
tout le monde fait des additions. Donc
tout le monde doit pouvoir un jour
considérer le temps long. Septembre
ensuite et ben décembre forcément et on
ira un cran plus haut non ? Bah on fera
bah ça peut être ça. OK du sapin. Voilà
et ben exactement tu sais crois pas si
bien dire parce que l'événement c'est ça
en fait la prospective c'est un
calendrier de l'avant c'est toujours
aller chercher derrière les mots et
derrière véritablement les notions qu'on
croit connu ce qui peut se cacher
derrière. Voilà qu'est-ce qui finance au
mois de décembre ? C'est pareil, c'est
tout le monde pourra s'asseoir, il y a
pas de problème. C'est la voilà la
laponie extérieure. C'est la France qui
finance ou c'est la perfid Bion ? Ce
sera ce sera ce sera soutenu et tous les
jeunes seront les bienvenus.
Ce sera soutenu des capitaux français.
N'y allez pas si c'est pas des capitaux
français. Est-ce que j'ai pas l'air
d'être un peu patriotique quand même ?
Voilà. quand même parce que je prends un
soin quand même à chaque fois à garder
des distances sur les débats polémiques
mais quand même un peu patriotique quand
même. Je te reconnais comme alors si tu
me reconnais comme tel, la
reconnaissance par autrui, c'est la
meilleure consécration. Oui, c'est
jamais ce qu'il faut chercher. Ah non,
j'ai pas dit j'ai pas dit la
reconnaissance au sens de la validation.
Je cherche pas la validation mais être
reconnu pour ce qu'on est, c'est je dois
l'être un petit peu pas et janvier 2026,
c'est ça et et mars. Voilà. et Mars, on
verra tout ça au plan européen. Donc
c'est Mars attaque. Ce sera dans le même
esprit, sauf que financé par qui ?
Toujours dans le même esprit, j'en
diraiis pas plus, mais dans un cas, on
découvre, dans le deuxième cas, on
pousse plus loin et dans le troisème, on
se compare et on apprend des différences
des autres. Voilà. Trois bouquins pour
notre communauté et et trois bouquins.
Alors,
parmi ceux que j'ai lu dernièrement,
la dernière fois que j'ai lu un bouquin,
c'était il y a plus de 2 mois. Qui t'a
transcendé ? qui m'a alors transcendé
qui m'a vraiment plu, c'était j'espère
ne pas écorner le titre mais vous allez
le retrouver c'est le monde univoque ou
vers un monde univoque Bower alors non
de j'ai plus son prénom c'est un
islamologue allemand qui a pris comme
terrain d'étude son terrain mais qui l'a
étendu très largement pour montrer et
bien l'inverse de ce Thomas Thomas Bower
l'inverse de ce la jaquette est pas mal
fait. C'est deux couleurs qui finalement
aboutissent à du gris. Bien la jaquette
avec tes mains.
Je sais pas si je dois prendre ça pour
un compliment mais refais-moi la
jaquette de deux couleurs qui se met
parce qu'en fait c'est deux sphères qui
s'interpénètrent, n'est-ce pas ? Et
l'une rouge, l'autre verte, je crois. Et
ça aboutit à une espèce de gris. Et en
fait il dit qu'en fait bah sous couvert
de diversité et de pluralité en fait on
arrive à un monde univoque et que les
choses sont monocolores il le démontre.
La couverture c'est un cercle noir, un
cercle orange et un cercle vert.
Et si et si on veut faire de la bonne
prospective et ben c'est exactement de
ça dont il faut sortir. Parce que si on
voit le monde comme ça et qu'on est
capable d'appréhender le présent et donc
d'envisager le futur à travers j'allais
dire ce socle cognitif qui nous permet
ou pas de voir les choses et en
l'occurrence c'est plutôt ou pas
puisqu'on irait si on le suit vers un
monde univoque et la thèse est hyper
solide, hyper étayée, hyper documentée.
On peut ne pas être d'accord mais c'est
assez solide. Bah, si on veut éviter ça
précisément euh l'antidote, enfin moi
celle que j'y vois, c'est celle sur
laquelle je travaille. Un deuxème livre,
celui-ci je l'ai lu il y a un peu plus
de temps et ça n'a absolument rien à
voir. Là aussi, je vais essayer de pas
écorner le titre, c'est Murakami sur la
la cité au je sais plus si c'est au mur
invisible ou au ah comment ça s'appelle
? Au mur, je l'ai lu il y a quoi ? Il y
a un peu plus de 6 mois.
Euh ce que j'aime en fait dans ce
bouquin, c'est le côté là aussi c'est
pour la prospective, c'est la cité au
mur. Ouais. Jaqu est extraordinaire.
Oui. Et j'aime la couleur aussi. J'aime
les couleurs parce qu'en fait ça renvoie
un un bouquin que j'avais c'était au mur
incertain. Au mur incertain. Voilà. Je
savais pas si c'était invisible ou
incertain mais j'aurais dû m'en souvenir
que c'est un incertain puisque je
j'essaie de moissonner et d'exploiter
l'incertitude et non pas de l'exploser
ou de me laisser accabler. Et ce que
j'aime dans ce bouquin en fait c'est le
côté le pouvoir d'évocation. Je disais
il faut pour construire des bons récits
prospectifs qui ça tiennent un peu du
mythe. Gaston berger disait faut que ça
fleur bon le parfum un parfum d'éternité
une bonne prospective fleur un parfum
d'éternité. Faut qu'il y a un côté
intemporel. Voilà. Tu as lu la Bible ?
Alors j'ai pas lu la Bible extin mais
elle est à côté de mon lit. Elle est à
côté de mon lit et
l'apocalypse j'y reviens fréquemment
parce que pour moi c'est sans doute un
voilà c'est sans doute un bon morceau de
prospective. euh ça prévoit pas, ça
prédit pas, mais euh qu'il trouve une
pouvoir d'inspiration et de retraduction
du réel présent infini. Voilà. Euh c'est
aussi un sacré mythe. Et ben le mythe de
la pomme, le mythe qui montre qui montre
alors la pomme typiquement qui montre
que la vérité, pour revenir à la
question de notre internaute, en tout
cas en terme de prospective, dépend
largement de la finalité et de l'usage
recherché. Adam et Ève ne se sont vu et
la nudité n'existait qu'à partir du
moment où ils ont croqué la pomme et que
le bien et le mal leur était connu.
C'est-à-dire que c'est une vision
éthique. Tu me décris le conflit. C'est
une vision éthique sur le sol ukrainien.
C'est une vision éthique qui permet
d'aboutir à une vision du monde comme on
dit en philosophie théorétique. Tu as le
tr alors c'est voilà pour le deuxème.
Donc voilà, j'aime bien ce bouquin pour
ça parce que voilà. Et euh le troisème
euh rac
lisez donc euh Yanaï une vie réussie.
Voilà, une journée réussie. Alors ce
bouquin là, il a été euh Yanaï une
journée réussie, il a été réédité à la
faveur d'une d'un partenariat avec
achète livre. Voilà. Euh
et vous y trouverez à peu près tout euh
ce qui est pour ceux que ça intéresse
qui est au
j'allais dire euh à la jeunèse à la
graine. Tu parlais d'algraine qu'il faut
développer de cette méthode prospective
que j'ai développé. Tout part évidemment
de là. C'est ésotérique, c'est
transdisciplinaire, c'est un ovni.
C'est 9 ans de boulot. Ça veut pas dire
que c'est bien parce que c'est 9 ans de
boulot. Ça peut être merdique au bout de
9 ans mais c'est quand même 9 ans de
boulot. Donc ça veut dire que ça a été
fait quand même de façon stratifiée.
C'est pas un truc jeté comme ça. Et puis
l'obstacle que tu viens de faire à
Emmanuel Macron là quand même c'est
dingue. Ah non pourquoi si bah 7 ans 7
ans de mandature c'est quand même merde.
Non mais il y a 9 ans. Mais le bouquin
le bouquin et c'est ça oui c'est la
force du bouquin. Il a été publié une
première fois en 2018 après 9 ans de
boulot. En 2018 après 9 ans de boulot.
Donc il faut remettre dans le contexte.
il a été republié là récemment et
en y réfléchissant, je pense que il y
avait pas une virgule à changer. Voilà.
Et donc euh quelque part quand euh ça
subit un peu les affres du temps et de
sa propre relecture, c'est pas toujours
le cas. C'est loin d'être le cas en
général quand je relie un truc, j'en
laisse rien debout parce que je me dis
"Ah oui, il aurait fallu réécrire ça
comme ça." Bon, c'est pas grave. Comme
disait Rousseau, il faut se pardonner
d'avoir écrit un livre. Donc je me
pardonne d'avoir écrit un livre. Mais
celui-ci, je me dis quand même, ouais,
parfois des longueurs, des lourdeurs,
des trucs un peu machin mais c'est tu
sais, c'est un peu comme Astérix
Legolois, le premier dessin d'Astérix
Legolois. Est-ce que vous vous en
souvenez ? C'est c'était pas même
c'était un peu euh hein brouillon.
C'était brouillon. C'était on sentait
que ça se cherchait, le coup de trait se
cherchait. Ouais. Mais aujourd'hui, si
on disait il faut réécrire Astérix
Legolo le premier, personne n'y
toucherait. Voilà, et ils auraient
raison. Et ben là, je me dis qu'il faut
pas y toucher parce qu'il y a déjà pas
mal de trucs là-dedans. Voilà. Donc
c'était mes trois bouquins euh enfin pas
les miens mais enfin trisème il va
s'appeler ton bouquin à toi.
On verra mais il va s'appeler mais euh
ce sera pas le titre le dernier s à
combien d'exemplaires ? Ah ça je ne dis
pas mais il a bien marché. Il a bien
marché. Bah bien marché. édition alorsah
bah parce que édition Airman, donc
édition reconnue, édition scientifique
sinon même académique avec donc
sélective et malgré tout il a bien
marché et surtout c'est quoi bien marché
et surtout attends j'insiste, il y a une
note de tot, une note de cœur et une
note de fond c'estàdire qu'il continue à
marcher et ça c'est bien et c'est ce que
me disait l'éditeur, il me disait faire
un bang sur le moment bon voilà ça à la
limite avec un peu de télé, un peu de c
un peu de là tout le monde y arrive
passage suriew tout le monde y arrive.
Bon ok mais le fait que ça dure et qu'il
y a une note de fond, tu sais comme le
parfum là, il y a une note de fond qui
dure, ça c'est plutôt bon signe. Ton ta
dernière interview chez nous et ta
première interview chez nous est monté
pratiquement un million de vues. Oui, je
crois que ça les gens ils sont revenus
et honnêtement
j'ai eu pour les gens qui m'ont qui
m'ont vu et qui m'en ont parlé souvent
un retour intéressé euh et de gens qui
veulent aller plus loin. Tu avais pas
ménagé, on avait Non non non mais
d'ailleurs les commentaires, il y en
avait pas tant que ça. Il y avait
peut-être 200 300 commentaires qui
étaient pour certains euh effectivement
euh euh en mode en mode cassage cassage
de genoux, mais euh c'est pas
grand-chose sur la masse. Et puis les
gens qui vient pas la blanche les gens
qui viennent au contact qui te
questionnent sur LinkedIn qui te
questionnent sur Twitter qui sont
demandeurs d'aller plus loin qui veulent
que sont hyper intéressés et ça c'est
c'est ça qui compte et j'allais dire il
il y en a plus que malheureusement que
de gens auxquels on j'aurais la
l'attitude de travailler pour l'esprit
de défense IHDN les jeunes de l'Idn
ah ben c'est c'est parfait c'est parfait
de qui sont sympas acculturés ils ont
des super sujets Oui, et c'est la
culture et puis aussi l'occasion de
travailler, c'est-à-dire que ils
produisent, c'est pas unilatéral où il
viendrait que recevoir. Ils reçoivent
mais ils donnent aussi beaucoup, ils
coproduisent. Donc ça pour l'esprit de
défense effectivement ta bibliothèque
préférée ? Ma bibliothèque préférée
c'est la bibliothèque Mazarine. Pourquoi
? Parce que c'est là où j'ai développé
toutes ces idées-là. il faisait une
chaleur à crever dans la bibliothèque
Mazarine. Je crois que j'avais à peu
près la même tenue que toi.
Voilà. Et voilà. Et j'y et j'y et j'y
repense parce que j'ai eu l'occasion
d'être invité récemment
à la réception et à la présentation des
travaux des nouveaux académiciens de
l'Académie des Sciences. Là aussi, c'est
un un j'allais dire une somme de de
comment de d'inspiration, ça peut
paraître creux de dire ça, mais que j'ai
pas totalement encore digéré, mais je
sais que j'en ferai quelque chose et il
se trouve que c'est juste en face.
Voilà. et ça m'a ça m'a remémoré pardon
voilà cette bibliothèque Mazarine et je
me suis dit qu'il faudrait que je
revienne travailler dans ces ces ces ces
ces ces locaux qui enfin locaux c'est
pas le terme mais c'estes ah ces murs
pardon qui sont là aussi chargés et
voilà c'est comme quand pour le coup on
se balade à Jérusalem on sent quelque
chose les murs sont chargés de quelque
chose qu'on soit croyant ou pas il se
passe quelque chose personne ne ressent
indem bah voilà qui conti c'est pareil
tu t'es déjà baladé àeniz
euh ça me dit rien ça. Est-ce que tu as
un conseil pour les jeunes générations ?
Je crois que je l'avais déjà donné mais
je le redonne parce que ça me réussit
plutôt pas mal. Enfin au sens ça me
réussit ça. J'ai trouvé mon équilibre de
vie. C'est vraiment faire ce qu'on aime.
Voilà. Et euh surtout alors surtout ne
jamais se laisser décourager
par ceux qui vont vous expliquer que ça
réussira pas, euh que ça dérange euh et
encore moins par ceux qui éventuellement
auraient voulu faire la même chose,
l'ont pas fait, sont aigris et vous
mettre des bâtons dans les roues. Voilà.
Donc faire ce qu'on aime véritablement,
c'est trouver du sens.
Voilà, ça peut passer par aller de
l'autre côté de l'Atlantique pour ceux
qui veulent avoir une réussite
matérielle. Mais je crois que on peut la
trouver, enfin c'est pas je crois, je
suis certain d'ailleurs qu'on peut la
trouver là où on se trouve. Je pense que
l'herbe est plus verte ailleurs en fait
tu sais. Et si je peux me permettre de
Je sais pas si je vais finir mais sur ce
sera pas une citation mais c'est allez
j'évoque en substance ce que disait
Prou.
Il disait à un moment donné, le
véritable voyage euh ce ne serait pas
d'aller à droite, à gauche et de
parcourir le monde entier. Le véritable
voyage ce serait voir le monde avec les
yeux d'un autre, avec les yeux de 1000
autres. Et il prenait Verneœil, un
peintre que je connais pas d'ailleurs.
Euh
et il disait des peintres comme lui et
les artistes en général, ils
s'exprimaient sur l'art. Il
s'exprimaient sur l'art. nous permettent
ça, ils nous permettent de voir les le
monde avec les yeux d'un autre. Et ça
c'est la véritable cure de jouvance.
Pourquoi je dis ça ? Parce qu'en fait
celui qui va vouloir faire ce qu'il
aime, celui qui va vouloir euh trouver
du sens, c'est lui ou celle, en fait
la décision est à ses pieds. Elle est
pas à chercher là-bas, elle est pas à
chercher après-demain, elle est tout de
suite et maintenant et elle est dans la
façon dont il choisira. Tout est un
choix. Donc il choisira de voir le
monde. Et là les capacités de
reconfiguration sont infinies. Et c'est
ça qu'il faut c'est ce que je je
souhaite faire dans cette proposition
prospective. C'est proposer un art
cognitif. Voilà pourquoi je parle des
arts. Un art cognitif en fait c'est ce
que doit être la prospective. Une façon
de voir les différents présents avec un
du réel. Et ces différents présents du
réel sont à mon sens les réels au futur.
Jérôme Ch, merci. Merci à vous et merci
à toi Sky.
[Musique]